JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE.
ROUTE HERE WIENER.
HURRY WE NEED SOME AUTHORS MA'AM.
YEAH WE CAN DO CONSENT BUT HOLD
ON ALLOW ME TO ANNOUNCE THAT.
CHANGES IN THE AGENDA.
AB THREE TEN SANTIAGO WILL NOW
BE A TO YOUR BILL SOON BE HEARD
TODAY.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS RUN CONSENT
ITEM FIVE AB SIX FORTY MISTER
FRAZIER.
AND ITEM TWELVE AB TEN SIXTY ONE
MISTER [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
IN ORDER.
DOES ANYONE TO CONSENT OKAY.
SO WITH THAT LET'S.
SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
EXCELLENT -- LET'S TO ROLL CALL
AND CONSENT [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY YOUR AYE MOORLACH OR LIKE I
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL TO OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS COME IN WE WILL.
HOPEFULLY WHEN NOT TOO MANY
MINUTES.
FOR SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MISS WEBER LET'S
START WITH YOU.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. SEVEN OH ONE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ALL MY
GOODNESS IS THE WRONG.
ONE IT'S AN WOULD NEVER MIND AB
SEVEN OH ONE SEVEN A ONE I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU SEVEN OH
ONE WHICH IS A BILL THAT
BASICALLY -- TALKS ABOUT
PRISONERS AN EXONERATION.
AND THE EXONERATIONS ARE
INCREDIBLY PAINFUL FOR ALL THAT
ARE INVOLVED.
BUT NO ONE SUFFERS MORE THAN THE
FIRST PERSON WHO'S BEEN
INCARCERATED. FOR SOMETHING THEY
DID NOT DO AND MUST START OVER.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE OVER
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE.
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN EXONERATED
IN CALIFORNIA PRISONS. THIRTEEN
POINT SIX YEARS IS THE AVERAGE
TIME SERVED BY WRONGFULLY
IMPRISONED IT'S NOT A REDUCE.
CURRENTLY EXONERATED ARE
RELEASED WITHOUT PROPER ACCESS
TO HOUSING.
AT A GOOD MONEY FOR LIVING
EXPENSES.
THEY HAVE BEEN ROBBED OF
TRADITION TO WORK HISTORY.
CREDIT HISTORY AND ARE FORCED TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE STIGMA OF
BEING INCARCERATED WHICH INSIDER
WHICH HINDERS THEIR ABILITY TO
FIND AND OBTAIN HOUSING.
AS A RESULT AT LEAST 44% OF ON
EXOTIC REEF LIVE IN SOMEONE
ELSE'S HOUSE INDEFINITELY.
RELYING ON FRIENDS AND FAMILY
FOR THEIR ATTORNEY.
AB SEVEN ONE PROVIDES ALL OF THE
BILLS ON THE PREVIOUS WORK TO
RIGHT THE WRONGS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN.
WHO WHO HAVE BEEN FAILED IN THE
MOST HARMFUL WAY?
THIS BILL WOULD ENTITLED IS
HONOREES A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR HOUSING COSTS UPON RELEASE.
AND ALLOW THEM TO SPEAK FUNDS
FOR A REASONABLE HOUSING COSTS
AFTER THE RELEASE TO HELP.
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND REJOIN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
THE EXONERATED NATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND TENANTS
TOGETHER.
A TO SPEAK ON TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL IS OB ANTHONY AND
EXONERATED NATION.
OF WHO'S A MEMBER THE EXONERATE
NATION AND I THINK IT MAYES YOUR
HERNANDEZ MAYBE HERE FOR
TECHNICAL CUTS CONSULT
CONSULTATION.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESS CAN
PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND TO ALSO TO COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BRINGING HIS BILL AND
REPRESENTED -- SEVEN OH ONE ARM
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT CON THE
STORE WAS SEVEN ONE BECAUSE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT.
A THE BASES -- BELIEVE OF ANY
SORT OF FEASIBLE PART KIND OF
WAY OF BEING IS HOW.
STABLE HOUSING -- SOMEWHERE ON
WILL YOU THE HOUSE SOME PLACES
SAFETY SOMEPLACE WHERE YOU CAN
REVENUE WE CAN GO BACK AND STUDY
TO DO THOSE THINGS AS NECESSARY
TO BE.
PART A SOCIETAL AFFAIRS -- MRI
SITUATION WHEN I CAME HOME AFTER
MY GENERATION -- I STAY WITH MY
ATTORNEY FOR THIRTY DAYS.
OF FULL FORTY FIVE DAYS AFTER MY
EXONERATION -- WILL YOU HAVE
ANOTHER YOUNG MAN BUT ANYMORE
STE MAURICE CAR WILL WHO
EXONERATED NATION HAS BEEN
HOUSING FOR THE LAST PAST
FOURTEEN MONTHS.
BECAUSE HE'S HOMELESS AND HE'S
BEEN HOME FOR A YEARS WITHOUT
ANY SORT OF ASSISTANCE.
AND SO IT IS A BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY FOR HIM HOME
BUT ALSO FOR THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS AND SAVVY ON JOSH
WHO'S ALSO STAND ONE ATTORNEY
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I'VE BEEN A FOUNDER EXONERATED
NATION.
CALL TO THE COMEDIAN ACTS THAT
NOT ONLY TO TO PASS HIS BILL BUT
YOU SUPPORT THIS AND OTHERS
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS TO COMMITTEES NASSER
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
SEE WHY SO SUSAN PREVENTS A
TERMS WE ARE CO SPONSOR THE
MEASURE -- I ONLY HAVE A LITTLE
BIT TO ADD -- BECAUSE MISTER
ANTHONY'S.
VERY ELOQUENTAND ALSO VERY
HUMBLE.
A FEW YEARS AGO.
MISTER ANTI CAME TO US AND SAID.
YOU KNOW TO LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH EGGS HONOREES.
AND THE LACK OF SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO THEM UP UNTIL THREE
YEARS AGO UNTIL HE CAME START
LOBBYING ON THESE ISSUES.
IF AN EXONERATION Là SOME
PRISON THERE IS NO GATE MONEY.
NO SERVICES.
NOTHING A PAROLEES SOMEONE
ACTUALLY COMMITTED THE CRIME WE
GET QUE MONEY.
AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT INTO PRO HE
PROGRAMS JOB TRAINING.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ALL OF
THESE.
KIND OF FULL SPECTRUM SERVICES
ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO FRAWLEY'S
BIGGS HONOREES GOT NOTHING.
ONTO HIS EFFORTS -- TO HIS OF
HIS WILLINGNESS TO SHARE HIS
ERSONAL EXPERIENCES SPENT
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN PRISON. FOR A
CRIME HE DIDN'T COMMIT.
I AM BECAUSE HE PUT IN ALL THE
ENERGY WEEK HE STARTED MEETING
WITH EXONERATION TALKING ABOUT
WHAT THEY NEED JOB TRAINING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS IN THE
END OF THE DAY REALIZE THAT
HOUSING WAS REALLY AN ANCHOR TO
MAKE ALL OF THOSE.
ARE AVAILABLE WITHOUT STEADY
HOUSING IN IMMEDIATE HOUSING.
IS OWNERS HAVE A VERY EVEN
TOUGHER TIME.
NOT JUST SURVIVING BUT THRIVING
WHEN THEY GET REALLY SEVENTY DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO HELP
EXONERATE SOMEONE THANK HIM ON
WHAT THE DOCTOR WEBER. FOR THE
WORK ON THIS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING THE
PRIOR BILLS AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
CAN'T CARRILLO.
ACLU CHECK OUT SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IRVING OUR IS YOU JUST COALITION
PRESENCE OF COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
OR IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT TIME.
BEFORE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
CLOTHES MISS WEBBER.
MISTER BRADFORD TEACHER NO -- I
WANNA THANK -- DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BEFORE US.
STRENGTHENING A PRE SHEET YOUR
WILLINGNESS.
TO TESTIFY AND ALSO -- TO DO THE
ADVOCACY.
I'VE ONLY IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS REALLY BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT THE STATUSES.
FOR OUR FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEASED DUE TO A WRONGFUL
CONVICTION.
AND DIE IT'S INTERESTING WHAT
I'VE LEARNED THAT -- WHILE THE
STATE.
DOES IN STATUTE HAVE SOME VERY
MEAN FIGURINE MINIMAL --
RESTITUTION OR COMPENSATION OR
WHATEVER FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN HELD FOR WRONGFUL
CONVICTION.
IT CAN TAKE YEARS IT IS ON THE
PERSON WHO WAS RELEASED TODAY
THEN.
PETITION FOR IT AND IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH LOTS OF HOOPS AND I'VE --
NOW MET PEOPLE WHO IT'S TAKEN
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS BEFORE
THEY GET.
EVEN A PENNY FROM THE STATE FOR
THE WRONGFUL CONVICTION -- AND
IT'S JUST WRONG THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE AT THIS IS MORE THAN
MAHDISTS BEYOND MODEST.
THE BUDGET THAT WE ADOPTED JUST.
TWO WEEKS AGO INCLUDED AGAIN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY MODEST AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO AN ORGANIZATION IN
OAKLAND.
THAT.
PROVIDES A SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
EXONERATION -- I HOPE THAT WE I
HOPE THAT THIS BILL SUCCESSFUL
AND I HOPE THAT WE DO FAR FAR
MORE.
IN FUTURE.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I TO
JUST ONE MONTH THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS COMMONSENSE MASURE AND
THE WITNESSES WHO'VE COME BEFORE
SHE DAY.
IT MAKES NO SENSE AND A FAIR AND
JUST SOCIETY THAT WOULD PROVIDE
MORE RESOURCES TO SOMEONE WHO
HAS COMMITTED A CRIME.
AND HAS BEEN RELEASED VERSUS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN WRONG
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED.
AND HELD -- WHETHER IT'S ONE
YEAR SEVENTEEN YEARS OR TWENTY
YEARS -- THEY DESERVE SOMETHING
THEY SHOULD JUST BE LEFT OUT ON
THE STREET SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE CAN EXPAND UPON THIS AS WE
DEAL WITH.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM HERE AND
CALIFORNIA AND JUST FAIRNESS AND
THIS IS JUST THE ISSUE OF
COMMONSENSE FAIRNESS SO I THINK
DOCTOR BEFORE LEADERSHIP.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I I REALLY I THINK MY THE
SUPPORTERS AND OBVIOUSLY THANK
MISTER ANTHONY FOR COMING HERE I
THINK FOR MOST OF US IT WOULD BE
INCONCEIVABLE -- FIRST OF ALL TO
BE INCARCERATED IT'S IT'S THAT
IN ITSELF IS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS DIFFICULT.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW YOU
FEEL IF YOU WOULD THEIR
WRONGFULLY THAT YOU DID NOT
COMMIT THE CRIME.
AND AND THE PROCESS YOU LOSE
YOUR FAMILY YOU LOSE SHELVE
RELATIVES PEOPLE HAVE DIED SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN INCARCERATED AND YOU
COME OUT WITHOUT OFTENTIMES
WITHOUT CONNECTIONS. TO THE
PRESENT YOUR FAMILY AS WELL AS
OTHERS AND SO AT THE YOU CAN
ONLY IMAGINE HOW YOU FEEL THE
TWO BEEN TRULY WRONG AND THEN
YOU COME OUT AND YOU'VE LOST.
ALL YOUR WORK HISTORY YOU'VE
LOST A JOB THAT YOU HAD LOST THE
HOUSES THE RESOURCES AND HAVE TO
START ALL OVER.
AND WE DON'T PROVIDE ENOUGH
SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE TO START OVER
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT HOUSING IS
CRITICAL IN TERMS OF STABILIZING
ANY FAMILY ANY GROUP OF PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK FOR A JOB. TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SOMETHING STABLE
THAT THEY CAN HAVE IT'S AN
ADDRESS THAT'S IMPORTANT SO THIS
IS A MODEST REQUEST BUT I I I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT LIFE WOULD
BE LIKE IF YOU WERE WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED.
OF THE EMOTIONS THE HEARTACHE
THE PAIN AND THEN FOR PEOPLE TO
EVEN STILL HOLD YOU SOMEHOW
ANOTHER GUILTY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT IT THAT THAT
THAT HAPPENED TO YOU -- SO I
THINK I I RESPECTFULLY ASK WE
AYE BOTH OF THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
WRONGFULLY LOSING THEIR LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM AND MOVING THEM FROM
THAT FAMILIES AT THE LEAST WE
CAN DO IS TRY TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE I PULLED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE GUYS.
BUT LET'S DO A ROLL CALL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI THERE
I MOORLACH. FOR LIKE AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
I WILL HAVE THE BILL AND CALL TO
MY MISSING MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
ADD ON HERE THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
LET'S GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES ITEM ONE AB
.
ONE THIRTY FIVE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FIVE
TODAY THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY RE
INTRODUCTION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED.
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
THAT HAS EMERGED WITH THE
GROWING USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA BY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RINGS
ACCORDING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THERE IS AN ALARMING TREND OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
HI BY USING THE INTERNET USING
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES POPULAR
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES SUCH AS
INSTAGRAM AND FACEBOOK TO WAR
POTENTIAL VICTIMS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALONG FORSMAN
TASK FORCE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SET UP A DECOY
ACCOUNT -- IS SOLICITING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS PART OF A STING
OPERATION THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WERE TAKEN ABACK BY HOW
MUCH TRAFFIC WAS GENERATED BY
THESE ACCOUNTS.
THE TEMPS TO TROPIC USING SOCIAL
MEDIA HAS A REAL IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN.
A QUICK THINKING TICKET AGENT
SUCCESSFULLY STOP TWO TEENAGERS
ARE FROM BOARDING A FLIGHT AT
SACRAMENTO INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TWO TEENAGERS WERE
ATTEMPTING TO FLY TO NEW YORK
AFTER TRAFFICKERS CONTACTED THEM.
OVER INSTAGRAM PROMISING THEM
MODELING OPPORTUNITIES LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BELIEVE
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN TRAFFIC IT
HAD THEY'VE FLOWN TO NEW YORK.
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
EXISTING LAW ONLY PENALIZES
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS WHO ACTUALLY
INDUCED OR PERSUADED MINOR TO
ENGAGE IN A COMMERCIAL SEX ACT.
THERE'S NO PENALTIES FOR THE
MIDDLE MAN IN THAT CHAIN THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CONTACTS A MINOR
OVER SOCIAL MEDIA TO PUT THEM IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE AT
RISK OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN.
IN THE SACRAMENTO AIRPORT
EXAMPLE THAT I JUST GAVE THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CONTACTED THE TWO
TEENS MAY NOT HAVE BEEN HELD
CRIMINALLY LIABLE.
THEIR INVOLVEMENT SPECIFICALLY
ARRANGING THE FLIGHT TO NEW YORK
MAYBE TOO ATTENUATED FROM THE
INDUCEMENT OF COMMITTING A
COMMERCIAL SEX ACT.
THAT IS REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FIVE
WILL CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE THAT
DANGEROUS LOOPHOLE TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN ARE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY BY MAKING IT A
FELONY TO CONTACT A MINOR WITH
THE INTENT TO ENGAGE IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
HOW WITH ME TODAY THIS MORNING
IT IS MY HONOR TO HAVE ALL THE
MEANING COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY?
NANCY O'MALLEY THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- THIS BILL IS REALLY
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
SAID IS ABOUT CONTACTING OR
LOWERING.
A MINOR FOR COMMERCIAL SEX.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT WHAT WHAT IS ABSENT IN THE
LAW RIGHT NOW IS HOLDING
PURCHASERS RESPONSIBLE.
RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE LAW IS
STRUCTURED THAT THE SAME
PUNISHMENT EXISTS FOR SOMEBODY
WHO.
SOLICITS AND IT AN ADULT WHO
SOLICITS AN ADULT SEX WORKER AS
IT IS FOR AN ADULT WHO
SOLICITING A MINOR FOR SEX FOR
COMMERCIAL SEX.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE IN THE
PUNISHMENT AND THIS BILL IS
REALLY DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE
PURCHASERS OF CHILDREN.
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN IN THE
FOREFRONT OF ADDRESSING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT WE HAVE OVER FIFTY CASES
PENDING.
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN WE
HAVE PROSECUTOR WERE.
SIX HUNDRED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES INVOLVING CHILDREN ALL
TRAFFICKERS.
I AND WE'RE BUT VERY LITTLE IS
DONE TO THE PURCHASERS.
WE KNOW ALSO THAT WE HAVE A DE
QUOI WEBSITE AS WELL AND ON A
MONTHLY BASIS WE HAVE OVER TWO
THOUSAND HITS.
OF ADULT MEN WHO ARE SEEKING TO
BUY CHILDREN NOT ADULT SEX
WORKERS BUT CHILDREN FOR SEX.
AND OF COURSE WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
DATELINE STORIES WHERE THEY SHOW
UP AT A HOUSE. TWO THIRTY SIX
POINT A POINT ONE SEE ADDRESSES
THE TRAFFICKER Q. PEOPLE ARE
TRAFFICKING CHILDREN.
AND TWO THIRTY SIX POINT ONE D.
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES.
OUT HOW WE DETERMINE IF A CHILD
HAS BEEN LOWERED OR INDUCED INTO
TRAFFICKING AND IT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS LOOKING AT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE CHILD AND THE
TRAFFICKER.
BUT NO WE'RE TWO THIRTY SIX
POINT ONE DOES IT SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THE PURCHASERS WERE AS IT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD WHICH I CHAIR --
WE HAVE ADDED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE ARE
NOW STUDYING AND RESEARCHING
BECAUSE WHAT WE DETERMINED.
INITIALLY IS THAT WITH OUR
INITIAL RESEARCH IS THAT
PURCHASERS OF CHILDREN FOR SEX
ARE ON THE SPECTRUM FOR SEX
OFFENDERS AND YET THERE'S NO
CRIME.
THAT EXISTS TO PUNISH PEOPLE
THAT ARE.
THAT ARE LITTERING OR TRYING TO
BUY CHILDREN FOR SEX.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT A OF WHICH WHICH ONLY
APPLIES TO CHILDREN UNDER
FOURTEEN IS A PROTECTION FOR
MINORS BUT THOSE CHILDREN THERE
BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
HAVE NO PROTECTION.
UNDER OUR LAW A AND THIS BILL
WOULD REALLY AT PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF PROTECTION.
HELLO SO ADD THAT.
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I KNOW THIS TO THE
HEAT INSTITUTE WHICH IS A
RESEARCH INSTITUTE I HAVE --
THAT AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
MINERS ARE BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN AND AN OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY ARE GIRLS OF COLOR --
WE'RE FOCUSING NOW ON BOYS AND
THE IMPACT ON BOYS AND THE
SOLICITATION OF BOYS.
AND THAT RESEARCH IS UNDERWAY
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A CRIME
WHERE THOSE CHILDREN ARE
UNPROTECTED FROM.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BUYING THEM
FOR SEX.
AND WITHOUT I JUST URGE OF NOT
NOT A VOTE TO MOVE THIS BILL
ALONG THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
ENTER MEMBERS STAND FOR THE SALT
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY O'MALLEY STATED OUR
OFFICES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MORNING MANAGER -- MEMBERS COREY
CELLS ALONG BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THE MORNING BRANDED UP ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
MELANIE CUEVAS WITH CAN TANA
WATSON HEARD MEN ON BEHALF OF
CAST THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ARE ATTENDING ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STUFF
IN AND SUPPORT.
THE MORE YOU LEARN MORE SOME
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION THE
ANALYSIS IN ADVERSE LEE LISTED
US AS AN OPPOSITION.
WHEN IN FACT WE ARE VERY
ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
LESLIE CALDWELL -- CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
IN OPPOSITION FIRST WE DO WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY PERSON
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL -- AND HER
STAFF -- FOR THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE HAD HOWEVER WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL I ALSO HAVE
A BRIEF CONVERSATION WITH --
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY
WHO IS CLEARLY VERY VERY WISE
AND EDUCATED ON THIS PARTICULAR
TOPIC I WANT TO BE CLEAR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE ISN'T.
AS HORRIFIED BY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS ANYONE.
HOWEVER THIS BILL -- IS NOT.
THE RIGHT.
APPROACH -- DA O'MALLEY SAYS
THAT IT FOCUSES ON THE PURCHASER
HOWEVER MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
HAD SEVERAL LAWYERS REVIEWING
THE BILL AND IS CLEARLY SUBJECT
TO MISINTERPRETATION IF THAT WAS.
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR.
WE DO BELIEVE IT'S WELL
INTENTIONED THE BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY.
THERE'S A MYRIAD OF STATUTES
PROVIDING PUNISHMENT FOR
COMMERCIAL SEX ACT AS WELL SEX
ACTS AS WELL AS USING PAYING OR
EMPLOYING MINORS TO COMMIT
COMMERCIAL SEX ACTS.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO DETAIL --
ABOUT PENAL CODE SECTION TWO
THIRTY SIX POINT ONE SUBDIVISION
C. BUT IT DOES COVER THESE ACTS.
AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT IT COULD
CRIMINALIZE BEHAVIOR THAT ARE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
BILL. FOR INSTANCE YOU HAVE TWO
SISTERS WHO ARE BEING ABUSED AT
HOME AND THEY DISCUSS RUNNING
AWAY.
THEY OF ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE MONEY AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BECOME.
PROSTITUTES BECAUSE THEY CAN
MAKE GOOD MONEY THAT WAY AND
THEY SHARE THAT.
THOUGHT WITH ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE YOUNG WOMEN SOME.
MINOR BOYFRIEND WHO SAYS HE CAN
HELP THEM FIND WORK AS SEX
WORKERS IN THIS SCENARIO ALL
THREE WOULD HAVE COMMITTED A
FELONY WITH THE INTENT TO COMMIT.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IS WHAT THE
INTENTION OF THIS THE BILL
REALLY IS AND WE ALREADY HAVE
LIKE I SAID.
THESE ACTS -- THAT.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND THE
AUTHOR WANT TO COVER WE HAVE
THAT IN THE LAW.
SO IN CONCLUSION OBVIOUSLY
VIOLATING PENAL CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT THREE BY
CONTACTING OR COMMUNICATING WITH
THE MINOR TO VIOLATE PENAL CODE
SECTION TWO THIRTY SIX POINT.
ONE DUPLICATES WHAT PENAL CODE
SECTION TWO THIRTY SIX POINT ONE
ALREADY PROHIBITS [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA --
I WILL JUST ECHO THE THE
COMMENTS OF OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FROM C. PDA AND SAY THAT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE THE CONDUCT THAT AT
ISSUE IS ALREADY -- IS ALREADY
SUBJECT TO CRITICIZE A SEVERE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES UNDER
EXISTING LAW -- WE ARE JOURNAL
PHONE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IGNITES YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE OPPOSE FOR THE
SAME REASONS.
I'M COMMENT SIR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES EXCUSE ME IF I COULD
JUST ADD MINE BOB SOLUTIONS.
AT TECH CARRILLO MEMBER OF THE
US SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
ACLU THANK YOU.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
I'M.
I WILL COMMENT IBM.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS ABHORRENT.
IT IS ON THE RISE.
IT ATTACKS VULNERABLE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THE DATE AROUND -- THAT
IT'S ARE.
OUR CHILDREN THAT ARE IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ARE HIGHLY
LIKELY TO BE TRAFFICKED.
AND WE DO WANT TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO STOP HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
HOWEVER A NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED A VERY
SIMILAR IF NOT THE SAME BILL.
LAST YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE.
AND I KNOW THE SEAL USE COMMENTS
[inaudible]
AND SO [inaudible]
I I'M TORN ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
I WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD.
NOT TO ADD SUPERFLUOUS CRIMES
WERE TO ADD CRIMES THAT COULD BE
MISINTERPRETED.
AND PUT -- PEOPLE THAT.
AT RISK THAT FOR SAY A FELONY
THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE NOT BE.
AND THERE'S BY THE VETO MESSAGE
ALONE.
IT WOULD APPEAR THAT THERE IS
EXISTING STATUTE.
MANY THAT COULD COVER THIS SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR -- LAST YEAR THE
BILL BIT SO RIGHT MENTIONED
EARLIER THEY GOT WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
ARE WITH THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION
WE ARE EAGER I'D LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS THE VETO AND IS ABOUT
WHETHER THIS BILL IS REDUNDANT.
BUT WHAT WERE INTERESTED TO TO
SEE IF THIS GOVERNOR THIS NEW
GOVERNOR WILL BE INTERESTED IN
SIGNING THIS LAW IN PARTICULAR --
THIS BILL INTO LAW AS YOU KNOW I
I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR D. A. O'MALLEY WHO'S
BEEN WORKING ON THESE CASES --
HER ENTIRE CAREER HI IN I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S AFTERWARDS AS WELL
WELL IF YOU COULD ADDRESS PUBLIC
DEFENDER SINCE I DIRECT I COULD
ADDRESS THE PUBLIC RIGHT
UNDERSTATED SO THE CONCERN THE
HYPOTHETICAL ABOUT THE BOYFRIEND
SISTER COMMUNICATION FIRSTLY.
THE CONDUCT WOULD ALREADY BE
PROHIBITED UNDER AYE PENAL CODE
SECTION TWENTY THREE SIX POINT
ONE BY HELPING THE TWO SISTERS
ESCAPE OR ENCOURAGING ONE OF THE
SISTERS TO ENGAGE IN A SEX
TRAFFICKING.
INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE CAUSING OR
IN DO YOU SEE IN THEM IN
VIOLATION OF PENAL CODE TWENTY
THREE SIX POINT.
ONE I IN ADDITION AT THESE IN
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE -- WE DID ATTEMPT TO
WORK WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE SHOULD DRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AS THEY MENTION THE
ONLY SUGGESTED AMENDMENT THAT WE
RECEIVED -- WAS NOT ACCEPTABLE
TO THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AT THE TIME AND THEY
BELIEVE THAT CRAZY WERNER
GREATER A LARGER LOOPHOLE I DID
ALREADY EXISTS -- TO IN THE
CURRENT GOVERNING STRUCTURE I
WHICH IS WHY WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL SO IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS NOW
AND CONTINUE TO MOVE AFFORD.
HI TO PROTECT.
OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE AT RISK
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS A HUB FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATUS
QUO IS CURRENTLY NOT ACCEPTABLE
WHICH IS WHY WE WANT TO CONTINUE
PUSHING THIS BILL.
FOR AND TO WORK WITH THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION I TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
DEAR MILLION MAY RESPOND BRIEFLY.
YES I I'M FOR ME.
I AGREE THAT THE LAW IS VERY
STRONG AGAINST TRAFFICKERS I
DON'T AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS OF
THE TEENAGERS BUT AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS LOOKED AT THESE CASES FOR
PURPOSES OF CHARGING.
I CAN SAY THAT I'M FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON FOURTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD CHILDREN WHO
ARE BEING SOLICITED.
BY PURCHASERS THAT THE
PUNISHMENT FOR SOMEONE WHO
SOLICITS FOR SEX FOR COMMERCIAL
SEX IS A MISDEMEANOR WITH
ESSENTIALLY NO TIME ATTACHED.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN
ADULT SOLICITING AN ADULT SEX
WORKER FROM AN ADULT WHO'S
SOLICITING AND LOOKING FOR ITS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY FOR CHILDREN
TO BUY.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT
POPULATION.
AND THERE IS NO OTHER BILL
BESIDE SIX FORTY SEVEN BE A IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS A BILL
THAT I SPONSORED.
BROKE SIX FORTY SEVEN BE THE ONE
SOLICITATION STATUTE IN THE LAW.
BROKEN INTO THREE SUBSECTIONS A
WAS THE THE NUMBER ONE ADULT
SOLICITING TO SELL BE WAS AN
ADULT SOLICITING AN ADULT SEX
WORKER AND SEASON ADULTS
SOLICITING A MINOR.
BUT THE PUNISHMENT IS NOT
DIFFERENT.
AND WE KNOW THE BEHAVIOR AND THE
THE MENTALITY OF THE PURCHASER
TROLLING OUR STREETS OR TROLLING
THE INTERNET SPECIFICALLY FOR
CHILDREN.
IS A VERY DIFFERENT THAN ADULT
WHO'S ENGAGING IN ADULT SEX
WORKER SO THIS BILL IS THE ONLY
BILL RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD EXIST.
TO ADDRESS THOSE PURCHASERS.
AND GIVE PROTECTION FOR THOSE
YOUTH THAT ARE NOT UNDER
FOURTEEN WHICH THERE ARE PLENTY
OF LAWS FOR THAT.
BUT BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN WHERE THEY'RE
PRACTICALLY NO LAWS AND AGAIN
THESE ARE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN WERE PUT IN AS YOU KNOW
PUT IN THE MOST VULNERABLE PART
OF CIRCUMSTANCES THERE ARE NO
OTHER LAWS THAT ADDRESS.
THAT PURCHASER FOR THIS
POPULATION.
SO I DON'T WANNA GET INTO
DIALOGUE RIGHT NOW BUT I JUST
NOTE THAT IN YOUR OPENING YOU
TALKED ABOUT THOSE WHO WOULD
LOWER NOT TO JOHN.
AND SO -- NOW THE PURCHASER
THAT'S THE JOHN THAT'S NOT THE
PERSON LEARNING SOMEONE DEMON
SEX TRAFFICKING SO THIS IS PART
OF WHY I AM CONFLICTED ON THIS
BILL -- AND I IT'S CLEARLY
BECAUSE OF THE SENSITIVITY OF
THE SUBJECT A HARD BILL TO
OPPOSE BECAUSE ALL OF US WANT TO
END HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND YET IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
THAT WE REALLY.
REQUIRE IT ON THE BOOKS SO I'M
MAY STAY OFF TODAY -- AND I AND
I AND AS I SAID TORN I DON'T
HAVE A HARD RECOMMENDATION TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ON BERMAN SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I'M OF THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WHICH LIKE CLOSE YES I I
RESPECTFULLY AUSTRALIA VOTE AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
SHOULD THIS BILL GET OUT.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S TO
ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LOCK MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MORALE.
WELL I AM WIENER.
WE'LL KEEP THE BILL ON CALL.
AND WE'LL HAVE SOME MAPS MEMBERS
WHO ARE RETURNING THANKS.
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WILL GO
TO ITEM TWO AB
.
THREE HUNDRED ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO
YOU MAY BEGIN TO MODERN CHAIRS
AND SENATORS.
IN ON THE FURS ARE LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE OR OR OR STRUGGLE
WITH THE AB.
THREE HUNDRED ALL RIGHT AND I
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME.
AND MY STAFF ON THIS BILL I THE
SEPTIC COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENT THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
INFORMATIONAL INCIDENT AND CRIME
REPORT USED BY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO INCLUDE A
CHECK BOX INDICATING WHETHER.
THE CASE AT HAND IS.
SUSPECTED HATE CRIME OR A HATE
INCIDENT.
IT ALSO REQUIRED THAT FOR EACH
HATE CRIME OR HATE INCIDENT THE
AGENCY MUST COMPLETE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT TO REPORT SUBMITS FOR US
TO FIND A TYPE OF BIAS
MOTIVATION INVOLVED.
AND OTHER IMPORTANT INFORMATION
THAT WILL HELP AID.
IN THE INVESTIGATION OR
PROSECUTION OF THE CASE.
AB THREE HUNDRED HATE CRIMES AND
HATE INCIDENTS SINCE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ACCURATELY
IDENTIFIED REPORTER AND
INVESTIGATED.
THIS BILL ACTUALLY STAYING FROM --
BUT ALL THE REPORT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH I WORK WITH.
OTHER MEMBERS IN SOME CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS TO REQUEST.
THE REPORT SUGGESTS THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY UPDATE THEIR
POLICY AND PROCEDURES ON THE HAY
CRYING AND IMPLEMENT.
A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING THE
TIME TO DO THIS IS NOW BECAUSE
TO HATE CRIMES ARE ON THE RISE
IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IS OF GREAT DE JUROR FROM ARC
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MAY START.
GOOD TO HEAR SPEAKING FOR THE
ARK AND UNITED THROUGH HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION.
A COALITION OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
THE AUDIT REPORT THAT.
YOU REFERRED.
TO I HAD A TITLE WHICH SAYS
PRETTY CLEARLY WHAT THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE REPORT WAS.
THE TITLE WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS NOT ADEQUATELY IDENTIFIED
REPORTED OR RECKONED RESPONDED
TO TO HATE CRIMES.
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN TOLD YOU MAY
BE TOLD TODAY.
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ALREADY COLLECT ALL THE
INFORMATION.
NECESSARY FOR THAT -- THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE -- ANY IMPACT MANY
DO THERE ARE MEN THERE MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS A DIRECT.
HOWEVER THE AUDIT.
REPORT THREE OF THE THE
CONCLUSIONS ARE ARE -- SAY
OTHERWISE.
NUMBER ONE NONE OF THE AGENCIES
THAT THE AUDITORS DID A DEEP
DIVE INTO HAD ADEQUATE TOOLS TO
IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES.
NUMBER. TWO TWO OF THE FOUR
AGENCIES HAD NO SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT FORMS THE PATROL OFFICERS
NEED TO IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES
NUMBER.
THREE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
UNDER REPORTS HATE CRIMES
STATISTICS BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SUBMIT WHAT
IT CALLED INCOMPLETE AND
INACCURATE INFORMATION -- ONE
ONE OF THE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE AUDIT REPORT LISTED HERE
AND THERE.
ACTUALLY.
IS THE THAT IS TO IMPLEMENT
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
HERE IS THE LOS ANGELES.
POLICE DEPARTMENT'S SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT FORM IT'S TWO PAGES LONG.
IT ASKS FOR COMPLETE INFORMATION
ON BIAS MOTIVATION WHICH IS.
PART OF THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
HE CRIME IS WITHOUT INFORMATION
A BUYER'S INFORMATION NOBODY
EVER KNOW HAD CAMERAS REPORTED
NOBODY EVER GETS CONVICTED
[inaudible]
AND OF THE THIS THIS GIVES THE
SUPERVISORS IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE D. A.'S THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER TO REPORT IT
STATISTICALLY THEY CRIME AND
DETERMINE WHETHER TO PROSECUTE
IT.
AS A CRIME.
THE TRIGGER FOR COMPLETING THIS
OF LITTLE REPORT FORM IS A HATE
CRIMES CHECK BOX ON THE AGENCIES
STANDARD FORM AGAIN SO THAT
AGAIN AS THE BILL REQUIRES.
AND AS MANY AGENCIES ALREADY DO.
SB LAPD IN PARTICULAR SAID THAT
WHEN THEY IMPLEMENTED THAT TO
THEM WHEN THEY ADDED A CHECK BOX
TO THEIR THEIR HE GRABBED TO
THEIR STANDARD A CRIMES REPORTS.
IT INCREASED THE NUMBER OF A
CRIME REPORTS WHICH SINCE WE
KNOW FROM FEDERAL STATISTICS
HATE CRIMES ARE GREATLY UNDER
REPORTED ANY INCREASE CAN ONLY
BECAUSE IT.
WAS A WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CLOSE
BURKE HEARING BEHALF OF THE JEWS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE J. PACK
AND EIGHTY ALIENATED FROM
ACTUALLY.
ARMOR THANK ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HATE CRIMES
IN HIS WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WEEK THE THIS BILL IS IT
IS IMPORTANT -- TO DEAL WITH THE
RISING TIDE OF HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTRY
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASED INCIDENCE OF HATE
CRIMES THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
IN IN CALIFORNIA IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT THOSE CRIMES BE
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT THEY ARE
WHEN THEY HAPPEN IT AND IT.
THAT ENHANCES THE ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH BOTH PREVENTION AND
WITH RESPONSE TO HATE CRIMES AND
THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND ABILITY CPN SUPPORT.
TERRY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
AILING KIPLING MAJORITY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
PART WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME TO THE
TABLE.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS CORSO'S
ALONE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- AS THE AUTHOR SAID
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REPORT
HATE CRIMES -- INCLUDING
INFORMATION REGARDING THE NATURE
OF BIAS INHERENT IN THE CRIME AS
WELL AS VICTIM CHARACTERISTICS.
OFFENSE TYPE AND LOCATION OF THE
OFFENSE -- THE DETAILS OF REPORT
WILL SHOW WHETHER OR NOT AN
INCIDENT IS SUSPECTED HATE CRIME --
AND WHETHER.
THAT SHOULD BE ACTED UPON IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW IT CHECK BOX ITSELF
WHICH IS ALL THIS BILL REQUIRES.
WE'LL GET TO THAT NEXT STEP OR
WILL CREATE SOME SORT OF REMEDY
TO THE ISSUE THAT THE AUTHOR IN
THE PROPONENTS HAVE REYES WHICH
IS THAT THERE IS UNDER REPORTING
OR INCOMPLETE REPORTING OF HATE
CRIME INCIDENTS.
THIS JUST SAYS YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A CHECK BOX IT'S ANOTHER FORM
IT'S ANOTHER.
ENTRY INTO A COMPUTERIZED
RECORDS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT.
WE'RE NOT CLEAR WHAT INFORMATION
MERELY HAVING A CHECK BOX WILL
PROVIDE -- AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LARA ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF RECORDS
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
OUR RATE -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THE BILL SORRY WE HAVE A MOTION --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE ACTUALLY --
IN THE START OF THE IMPLEMENTED
THIS -- I IDEA WHEN I WAS ON THE
CONSOLE AND DO REPORTS AND
ASSAULTING INCREASING THE
ACCURACY AUTHOR HATE CRIME
REPORTING SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
RIGHT LET'S DO A ROLL CALL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- BROKE OFF.
SKINNER HI THERE I MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND [inaudible]
WIENER.
IT WILL HAVE THE BILL ON CALL TO
WE GET ARE MISSING MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE TO MORE
BILLS.
AND THEN I JUST WANNA KNOW IT'S
FROM THE DICE THAT WE WILL ONCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU IS CONCLUDED
HIS -- REMAINING BILLS WE WILL --
HAVE -- WILL HEAR THE BILL OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
K..
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AGAIN
CHAIRS AND THREE OFF SENATORS ON
PRESENTING A BE SIX EIGHT ZERO
AB SIX EIGHT ZERO WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING OR POST. TO ADOPT
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS.
THE DISPATCHERS WOULD TAKE
MENTAL HEALTH IDENTIFICATION AND
AWARENESS TRAINING IN ADDITION
TO THEIR ACCOUNT AND INCLUDED IN
THEIR CONTINUING TRAINING EVERY
YEAR FIVE BE DEAL.
DISPATCHERS ARE THE FIRST POINT
OF CONTACT FOR EMERGENCY THE
INFORMATION BE COLLECTED AND
RELATE TO PEACE OFFICER IS
CRITICAL TO THE OUTCOME OF ANY.
A POLICE CONTACT.
THOSE TRAINING MEANS TO
STRUCTURE AN OF THE RESPONDING
OFFICERS WOULD BE MORE A LYING
IN COMMUNICATION.
AND APPROACHES SPEAKERS PEACE
OFFICER ALREADY TAKE SIMILAR
TRAINING.
DOES TRAINING WILL PROTECT ALL
INVOLVE BY IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF THE INFORMATION SENT TO THE
RESPONDING OFFICERS WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IS JESSICA CREWS TO SEAL OFF NOT
ME CALIFORNIA AND ADRIAN SHELTON
OF TO USE STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE
REST THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JUST THE CRUISE CEO OF THE
NATIONAL LANDS ON MENTAL ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA OR NAMI -- WE
REPRESENT FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND THIS BILL REALLY
DOES -- EXPAND ON SB ELEVEN AND
TWENTY NINE THAT WAS PASSED
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO -- WHICH
REQUIRED OFFICERS TO GET CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING -- THIS
WOULD REALLY HELP THOSE
DISPATCHERS.
IN NOT ONLY DE ESCALATING THE
SITUATION LIKE THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT IN SACRAMENTO WHERE
THERE WAS A YOUNG MAN WHO WAS ON
THE FREEWAY OVERPASS.
EONS THE PERSON WHO CALLED FOR
EMERGENCY ACTUALLY TALKED TO A
DISPATCHER THAT NOT HAD ANY
FORMAL TRAINING BUT HAD
OBVIOUSLY THE SKILLS AND
TECHNIQUES TO HELP THAT.
INDIVIDUAL DE ESCALATE THE
SITUATION AND TELL A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT WAS
TRAINED IN CRISIS INTERVENTION
WAS ABLE TO CALM AND
SUCCESSFULLY -- HANDLE THE
SITUATION SO NOT ONLY WITH THIS
TRAINING HELP THOSE DISPATCHERS --
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE THOSE
SAME SKILLS THAT THIS UNIQUE
DISPATCHER HAD TO HELP WITH THE
SITUATION.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP -- IN
CONNECTING ERVICES.
THE THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO ALSO HELP DIVERT PEOPLE
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND A
CRISIS AND THEIR FAMILIES INTO
SERVICES RATHER THAN INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SO THE DISPENSER BATCHES WILL BE
TRAINED ALSO IN THEIR LOCAL
AREAS TO IDENTIFY -- SPECIFIC
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO
FOR INSTANCE IN LA THEY HAVE A
CRISIS INTERVENTION AND RESPONSE
UNIT THAT COULD COME OUT TO THE
DISPATCHERS WOULD UNDERSTAND AND
KNOW WHO TO CONNECT TO AN WHO TO
CALL.
SO NOT ONLY WOULD IT HELP DE
ESCALATE CONNECTED SERVICES BUT
IT WOULD ALSO DIVERT FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND SO
THAT IS WHY WE ARE THE SPONSORS
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
X. WITNESS GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE
ARE ALSO PROUD TO SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX EIGHTY AND JOIN NAMI
CALIFORNIA AND MANY OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AND CALLING
FOR THIS BILL.
NOT ME CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE POLICY ADVOCATES FOR
DECADES AND PROMOTING THE VISION
THAT INTERACTIONS BETWEEN.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SOMEONE IN A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS BE SAFE AND
ACCOMMODATING AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION GIVES DISPATCHERS
THE TOOLS AND THE TRAINING THAT
THEY NEED TO FACILITATE SAFETY
AND EFFICIENCY OF ENCOUNTERS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SOMEONE IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
THIS TRAINING REQUIREMENT WILL
ENSURE THAT DISPATCHERS PROVIDE
THE MOST ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
THOSE WHO CALL AND ULTIMATELY
PROTECT THE COMMUNITY AND THE
PEACE OFFICERS WHO ARE
RESPONDING.
WE FURTHER BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION BUILDS ON THE
EXCELLENT WORK THAT POST HAS
BEEN DOING WITH REGARD TO THE
TRAINING STANDARDS FOR CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND ALSO THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE TO
PAIR MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO ACROSS CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS ARE DEPENDING ON
DISPATCHERS AND THEY'RE OFTEN.
OVERLOOKED IN A REALLY CRITICAL
LINK IN THE RESPONSE THAT
HAPPENED SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AT THE
MIKE -- CARES WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AND A KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
BRENDAN UP ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN OUR
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY DISPATCHERS
AND SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TYLER IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
COUNTY SURE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THEY FIND BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES IN
SUPPORT.
LARA TANNING ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STUFF IN AND SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
RATE THE NEW.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION KNOWN TO
SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KERRY SCENE NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
EXCELLENT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WILL DO A ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER BUY IT OR I MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
HI MORRELL AYE WIENER.
I WILL HOLD AN ON CALL AND NO
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE THE
NOT SAME BUT ANOTHER BILL THAT
DEALS WITH TRAINING ITEM ELEVEN
A. B. TEN FIFTY TWO YOU MAY
PERCENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AGAIN A.
B. TEN FIFTY TO ENSURE THAT
PEACE OFFICER GIVE STANDARD AMP
PERIODIC TRAINING ON HATE CRIME.
AS SPECIFICALLY THE BILL REQUIRE
PEACE OFFICER TO WATCH THE
SPECIFIED HATE CRIME VIDEO
COURSE.
THAT WAS DEVELOPED AND RELEASED
BY POST.
THIS TRAINING VIDEO WOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO THE BASIC
TRAINING CURRICULUM.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT.
IN SERVICE PEACE OFFICER TO TAKE
REFRESHER COURSE EVERY THREE
YEARS AND OPPOSE DEVELOPS AND
PERIODICALLY UP THE DISCOURSE.
DISCOURSE WILL COVER THE TOPICS
OF HATE CRIME LAW.
INVESTIGATION TRAINS AND THE
BASS ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES.
THIS IS AGAIN AS A RESULT OF TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HATE CRIME AUDIT
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S.
REPORT HIGHLIGHTED THE HOUSE
SOME OF TO SURVEYED AGENCY DO
NOT PROVIDE REFRESH HEY CRYING
TRAINING. TO DO YOUR OFFICERS
WHICH LED TO THE IN THAT THE
COULD IDENTIFICATION OF HATE
CRIME BY THE AGENCIES.
WITHOUT PROPER KNOWLEDGE AND
CURRENT LAW GUIDANCE TO
PROCEDURES HEY CRYING WILL BE
CONTINUE TO BE UNDER REPORTED A
MIS REPORTED.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE TO PEACE
OFFICER MORE INFORMATION AND
TOOLS TO ADDRESS HATE CRIME IN
OUR COMMUNITY WITH ME TODAY
ATTEND SUPPORT IS GREG.
THE DANGER FROM THE ART
[inaudible]
LUCIEN -- GREG HERE ONCE AGAIN
REPRESENTING THE ARK AND UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY I JUST TO NOTE
THE LAWN PORTION CONSIDERS HATE
CRIMES. TO BE HIGH IMPACT LOW
FREQUENCY OCCURRENCES WHICH
MEANS MADE MANY OFFICERS WILL GO
FOR YEARS WITHOUT HAVING SEEN.
ONE THESE THESE SKILLS TO DEAL
WITH THE MARK PERISHABLE SKILLS
TO HAVING -- PERIODIC READ READ
THE PETITION OF THE TRAINING IS
IMPORTANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MA'AM SHERMAN CLIPPER HERE AGAIN
FOR JEWS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE G. PACK IN EIGHTY L.
AND IDEA OF DEFAMATION LEAGUE --
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ON WANT TO AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK IS CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON HATE
CRIMES.
AND FOR HIS WORK WITH THE
AUDITOR GENERAL WE THINK THIS
BILLS IMPORTANT RECOGNIZING IN
RESPONDING TO HATE CRIMES
ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CAN COME TO THE MIKE.
HI THERE A LITTLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS ARE AT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING.
NINE BY COMMENTS SERVER
CONCERNED QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SORRY WE HAVE A MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
PUT.
OKAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER BY.
AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I BRADFORD JACKSON.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
BILLS ON CALL.
ON OUR MEMBERS SPOKE COME BACK
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO -- TO
ITEM.
LET'S SEE.
WHAT NUMBERS AT ITEM NINETY TEEN
AB?
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CALDERON AND JOINS SORRY --
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT HOPE
SORRY.
OR WORSE SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WILL
GO FIRST.
SORRY WHICH IS SIMILAR JONES
SAWYER FOLLOW IF YOU GO AHEAD
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTELLIGENCE
AND I THANK MY FELLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR UNDERSTANDING --
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO SHARE.
I DID WRONG [inaudible]
ONE DID [inaudible] SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND I AM SO SORRY THEY
GAVE ME TORONTO AREA.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING -- THE
FOLLOWING TWO TECHNICAL.
AMENDMENTS REPLACING THE TERM
JUDICIAL WITH THE PUBLIC.
AND REMOVING POTENTIAL FROM THE
TERM FUTURE POTENTIAL BENEFITS.
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN A BILL THAT
SIMPLY CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
AND CODIFIES APPELLATE COURT
CASES ARE PLEA BARGAINS.
PLEA BARGAINS ARE BENEFICIAL
TOOLS THAT ALLOW PROSECUTORS TO
REACH EXPEDITIOUS RESOLUTION
SOME CASES IN EXCHANGE FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
PROSECUTORS CAN USE TO BRING TO
JUSTICE AND MORE DIFFICULT CASES.
COURTS HAVE FOUND THAT FOR PLEA
BARGAINS TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
A DEFENDANT MUST ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT KNOWINGLY.
INTELLIGENTLY INVOLUNTARILY.
ADDITIONALLY COURTS HAVE RULED
THAT PLEA BARGAINS ARE SUBJECT
TO CHANGE THE LEGISLATURE OR
VOTERS MAKE ANY CHANGES IN STATE
LAW THAT WOULD AFFECT THE
AGREEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY A RECENT LOWER
COURT DECISION HAS CREATED SOME
CONFUSION ABOUT HOW STATE LAW
SHOULD APPLY TO PLEA BARGAINS
ANY ABILITY OF DEPENDS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR RIGHTS UNDER FUTURE
LEGISLATION. TO CLEAR UP THIS
CONFUSION AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH SIMPLY STATE THAT TO STAY
THE SAME THE STATE THAT TO STAY
CONSISTENT WITH APPELLATE COURT
DECISIONS AND LONGSTANDING.
JURISPRUDENCE A STATE DEPENDENT
IS NOT ABLE TO SIGN AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER FUTURE LEGISLATION.
THIS IS A SENSIBLE CHANGE THAT.
FOR PRESERVES THE INTEGRITY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS ENSURES
THAT CHANGES MADE IN STATE LAW
BY THIS BODY OR THE VOTERS.
ARE NOT CIRCUMVENT IT OR USURPED
BY LOCAL PROSECUTORS FOR THE
MORE NO ONE SHOULD BE ASKED TO
SIGN AWAY RIGHTS WHEN THEY DO
NOT KNOW WHAT THOSE RIGHTS ARE.
WE HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUE WITH
PROSECUTORS SO THAT WE CAN
PRESERVE THE EXISTING SYSTEM A
PLEA BARGAINS.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU I WILL.
THANK YOU SEVEN REMEMBER LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION LESLIE CALDWELL IN
SUPPORT.-KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NEEDS HIM ALLEY ALAMEDA COUNTY
DA IN SUPPORT.
LORRIE MOORE'S CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON
THIS BILL YET BUT WE ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLYMAN
JONES OR OFFICE AND HOPEFUL THAT
WE WILL FIND COMMON GROUND ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- ANY OTHER
TRAINERS.
ALL RIGHT ANY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE I WANTED THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL -- I THINK WE HAVE --
OVER THE YEARS.
WE HAVE REVISITED AND LOOKED AT
SOME -- THINGS THAT WE WE ARE
THE VOTERS HAVE PUT INTO STATUTE --
AND WE HAVE MODIFIED THOSE MEAN
DRUG CRIMES ARE OBVIOUSLY THE
MOST AND MOST PUBLIC ARE KNOWN
EXAMPLE OF THAT -- BUT WE HAVE
BOTH.
RE RE DEFINED CRIMES
RECONFIGURED THEM AS WELL AS
ADDED CRIMES TO THE BOOKS.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS CLEARLY
THE PRIVATE OF OF BOTH THE
VOTERS AND OF THE LEGISLATURE.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THOSE --
CHANGES TO BE RESPECTED AND I
THINK THIS IS NEEDED AND
APPRECIATED -- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
WE CAN HOLD AN WE CAN HAVE A YOU
PERCENT ON THE NEXT BILL AND
THEN WE CAN GET A MOTION BUT YOU
CAN CLOSE ON THIS -- ONE THIS
PRESERVES THE THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS -- WHETHER TO LEGISLATOR
WHO PUT US HERE OR WAS ABOUT IS
THEMSELVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
SO WILL HOLD TO GET A MOTION BUT
WILL ALLOW YOU 2% ON YOUR NEXT
BILL.
THANK YOU.
WITH YOUR CO AUTHOR.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO SHARE
PRESENTATION OF AB SIXTY EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH THE BILL'S JOINT
AUTHORS AND THE NUMBER JONES
SAWYER -- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS BILL TODAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING WE WILL WORK ON
AMENDMENTS THIS WEEK AND TAKE
THE BILL UP. FOR A VOTE NEXT
HEARING NEXT WEEK.
LAST YEAR WE PARTNERED.
ED TO REQUEST A THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE AN AUDIT TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CC ARE IN
PRISON REPEAL A DATE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
THE RESULTING AUDIT FINDINGS
WERE CONCERNING THE ARTISTS
FOUND THAT IN MAY TWO COMPLETED
THEIR RECOMMENDED REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS RECIDIVIST AT THE AT
ABOUT THE SAME RATE AS IN MAY
TWO WERE NOT ASSIGNED TO THOSE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
PERHAPS THE MOST ALARMING ON THE
AUDIT FINDINGS WAS THAT THE CDC
ARE FAILED TO MEET ANY OF THE
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS 462% OF THE
INMATES RELEASED.
LAST YEAR WHO HAD BEEN ASSESSED
AS A RISK OF RECIDIVISM AS A
RESULT WE INTRODUCED AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH ENDEAVORS TO
PURSUE THE ODDEST
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THANK YOU AND IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT CDC OURS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WERE CARS YOU SEE ARE.
TWO ONE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE NCDC ARW
COMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ESTABLISH PERFORMANCE TARGETS
INCLUDING ONES FOR REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AN ATTORNEY TO
PROGRAMS COST EFFECTIVENESS.
THREE PARTNER WITH EXTERNAL
RESEARCHERS TO EVALUATE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND
IMPLEMENT MEANT A COMPREHENSIVE
THREE YEAR PLAN TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST ISSUE AN
ANNUAL REPORT BEGINNING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWO THAT SHOWS A
PERCENTAGE OF REDUCTION OF
RECIDIVISM THAT CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS WE HOPE THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
PROPERLY UTILIZED.
AND THE STATE IS FULLY FOR
FILLING THE REHABILITATIVE
COMPONENT OF THE CORRECTIONAL
EXPERIENCE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
NEXT WEEK.
THANK YOU LET SEE IF THERE'S
SOME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IRVING ALVAREZ CAME OUT THE
PRISON SYSTEM AND I'M TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD I STILL HAVE NOT
GOT MY SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
THERE IS NO OLD REHABILITATION
AND THE CDC PRISONS SO PLEASE
MAKE THIS PAST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ART -- OF WE WE MAY GET A MOTION
WHERE WE WERE WE'RE GOING TO
WAIT BUT LET ME SAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL I'M VERY
GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD.
I THINK I IS ALL OF US WERE
ALARMED BY MANY OF THE FINDINGS
THAT THE AUDITOR FOUND.
THAT THE THERE WERE -- THE
ASSIGNMENT OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS TO THE INMATES DID NOT
MATCH THE INMATES NEED THAT WAS
ONE OF THE FINDINGS THAT CAME
OUT.
THE THERE WERE WAITING LISTS
THERE WERE FACILITIES THAT DID
NOT HAVE -- THERE WERE AND WE
HAD PRISONS THAT DID NOT HAVE
APPROPRIATE FACILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
THAT WE HAVE A REALLY --
INVESTED IN NOT ONLY DO TO PROP
FIFTY SEVEN BUT ONCE WE GOT OUT
OF THE RECESSION WE BEGAN TO BE.
VERY CLEAR THAT WE NEEDED TO PUT
REHABILITATION BACK INTO OUR
PRISON SYSTEM.
AND SO WE OBVIOUSLY.
INSTANCES AT OUR INTENT AND WE
KNOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
THAT SERVE TIME IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM WILL RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
ALONE WE WANT THAT RETURN TO BE
AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE AND IT
IS THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD ALLOW US -- TO SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE BRINGING
FORWARD AND I ALSO GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
LET US -- JUST IN AGREE THIS
SECTION THE CHAPTER EIGHT POINT
THREE WITH THE SECTION ONE
BECAUSE I NOTED IN THE BILL.
US FOR REPORT WHICH WE I THINK
WE NEEDED WE ONE HAVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT YOU ALSO ASK
THE LEGISLATURE TO YOU WE
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS TO DO SOME THINGS
AND I THINK WE MIGHT WANT TO
INTEGRATE THEM.
SO AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
REQUIRING THEM WE'RE ALSO HAVING
THEM REPORT TO US ON WHAT WE
REQUIRE SO THE IT'S PRETTY
SIMPLE AND I HOPE I THINK WE
WILL GET TO A GOOD PLACE.
AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS SO -- LET'S SEE WHAT
WE DON'T NEED THE MOTION BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA DO VOTE ONLY NEXT
WEEK.
AND THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
STATEMENT THAT'S PERFECTLY LEGIT.
YEAH NO I APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US
ON THIS BILL HAPPY TO DO THAT.
A MAN AND AS FAR AS WE'RE
CONCERNED.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO SEE MORE
MONEY GOING TO MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
IN THE SYSTEM ARE GETTING THE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED.
WE'VE NEVER HAD AN AUDIT. TO
DETERMINE THE EFFICACY THIS IS
WHAT IT WAS DETERMINED AND SO WE
ARE REALLY HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE OUR GOAL I THINK IS A
STATE SHOULD BE TO MOVE TOWARDS
REHABILITATING FOLKS THAT ARE IN
PRISON BUT THEN ALSO MAKING SURE
WE SPENT MORE MONEY TOWARDS
PREVENTATIVE PROGRAMS OR
PREVENTATIVE ALTERNATIVES LIKE.
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO SCHOOLS
THAT ARE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF THEM FEEL LIKE
THEY NEED.
TO COMMIT THE THINGS OR DO THE
THINGS UP LET THEM TO PRISON THE
FIRST PLACE -- BUT THIS IS A
GREAT FIRST STEP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT ONCE THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
AND I AND I BELIEVE ONCE.
WE GET THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT HOW
WELL THESE FOUR PROGRAMS WORK
THOSE WHO ARE NOT.
REALLY BEHIND REHABILITATION
WILL SEE THE BENEFITS OF IT ALSO
MOST IMPORTANT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT IS MUCH AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID IT'S MUCH BETTER
TO REHABILITATE SOMEONE STATUS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THEN TO CONTINUE TO LOCK PEOPLE
UP.
THANK YOU BOTH.
ALL RIGHT SIR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM. EIGHT AB EIGHT OH THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
OH THREE WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THE OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH.
AND WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS -- AS THEY
TAKE ON A STRESSFUL THE STRESS
OF LIFE IN STATE PRISON
FACILITIES CALIFORNIA'S
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS EXPERIENCE
A VARIETY OF MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
TRAUMA -- AS A RESULT OF THEIR
CAREER ACCORDING TO THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS SURVEYED
28% THE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
REPORTED FEELING DEPRESSED AND
10% -- HAVE BEEN CONSIDERING
SUICIDE.
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ALSO FACED A HIGH INCIDENCE OF
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE AS WELL AS
DIABETES MORE THAN THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
BECAUSE OF THIS -- WELLNESS
PROGRAMS ARE NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY
IS INTIMATE I'M CURRENTLY THIS
CD SEE OUR PROVIDES RESOURCES
FOR OFFICERS BUT THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT INPUTS FROM
OFFICERS.
BE SOLICITED AND TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION -- THIS GAP EXISTS
IN EXISTING LAW AND HAS LED TO A
PATCH WORK OF POLICIES RESULTING
IN MANY OFFICERS -- BEING
RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT THESE KINDS
OF SERVICES AB -- EIGHT OH THREE
WHAT X. STATUS WITHIN CDC ARE A
PEER SUPPORT LABOR -- MANAGEMENT --
COMMITTEE TASK FORCE WITH
CREATING -- IT UPDATED
STANDARDIZES STATEWIDE POLICY UP
WITH DEPARTMENT OF PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BENEFITS
TRUST FUND AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALL WILL SELF
INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS NAMELY PETRON WITH MAKE
YOU CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
BENEFIT TRUST FUND WE'RE HERE
TODAY AS CO SPONSORS OF THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
I HAVE WITH ME DâN BIãU MAN
WHO IS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BENEFIT
TRUST FUND AS WELL AS THE
CHAPTER PRESIDENT AT KERN VALLEY
STATE PRISON AND HE WILL BRIEFLY
SPEAK -- ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THE
NEED FOR A BE ABLE.
THREE CURRENTLY RESEARCH
SUPPORTS AT ONE OF FOR
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS SUFFER FROM POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
THIS IS HIGHER THAN THAT OF
COMBAT VETERANS.
I MYSELF IN THE UNITED STATES
MARINE COMBAT VETERAN.
WHEN I SAW WHILE DEPLOYED TO
IRAQ IS NOTHING TO A WE GET
EXPOSED TO ON A DAILY BASIS?
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
THE KEY TO MAKING POSITIVE
CHANGES IN THE STATISTICS IS A
WELL ESTABLISHED AND
STANDARDIZED SUPPORT PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL DO THAT.
IT WILL ESTABLISH A PEER SUPPORT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE.
THAT WILL BE TASKED WITH
CRAFTING.
AND UPDATING A STANDARDIZED
STATEWIDE POLICY FOR THE
APARTMENTS SUPPORT PROGRAM.
FROM FIGHTS THE THREE HUNDRED
MEN RIGHTS FROM SUICIDE TO
MURDERS. TO US COMING ACROSS
DISMEMBERED BODIES.
THE HUMAN MIND IS NOT DESIGNED
TO SEE THESE LEVELS OF VIOLENCE.
YET OUR CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ARE SUBJECTED TO THIS ON A DAILY
BASIS.
AND THEN SENT BACK. TO CARRY ON
NORMAL LIVES. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
REASONS CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
DON'T SEEK HELP THAT THEY NEED.
IS BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
TALKED TO ONE UNDERSTAND WHAT WE
GO THROUGH BECAUSE THEY'VE NEVER
BEEN IN OUR SHOES.
SUPPORT USES CORRECTIONAL STAFF
AS COUNSELORS.
THERE BY DEVELOPING A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE COUNSELOR AND THOSE
OF US THAT ARE IN NEED OF THE
HELP.
HOWEVER THIS PROGRAM ALSO NEEDS
TO BE TRUSTED.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO TALK AND
IN SOME CASES EVEN BE REFERRED
WITHOUT THE FEAR OF STIGMA
[inaudible]
OR RETRIBUTION.
THE CURRENT DIRECTION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM IS HEADED WILL
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO IT SELF
DESTRUCTION.
WELL ALL OF US AND OUR FAMILIES
ARE LEFT TO SUFFER IN SILENCE.
I'VE HAD TO BURY NUMEROUS
OFFICERS DUE TO SUICIDE BECAUSE
OF THE STRESSES.
THAT ARE IMPOSED UPON US.
THESE ARE OUR PARTNERS IN OUR
FAMILY.
THESE ARE YOUR COACHES YOUR
VOLUNTEERS AND PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY.
WE WILL NO LONGER STAND BY AND
LISTEN TO THE SCREAMS OF
CHILDREN AND SPOUSES AND THEY
BURY THEIR LOVED ONES BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T THE RIGHT KIND OF
HELP. FOR THIS WE ARE PROUD OF
THOSE THAT WILL STAND WITH US TO
STOP THIS CRISIS.
AND THE CCPOA BENEFIT TRUST FUND
IS A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
[inaudible]
EIGHT OH THREE THANK YOU.
HAVE WE HEARD FROM ALL THE
WITNESSES.
NO SIR.
THEN PLEASE GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS STEFAN WALKER I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
FOR CCPOA.
I AM ALSO YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER -- THE PURPOSE FOR EIGHT
OH THREE IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IS A LEGACY.
OF A TOUGH ON CRIME -- MENTALITY.
HEY IN DID WE HARDENED OUR
FACILITIES WE HARDEN THE
OPERATIONS -- AND AN ENHANCED
PUBLIC SAFETY.
HOWEVER WHAT WE FOR GOD IN THE
PUBLIC PART.
ARE THE PEOPLE.
AND THE PEOPLE CHANGE
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
ARE GOING TO EVOLVE THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED MORE ASSISTANCE
AND WHAT ARE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS SHOULD RECOGNIZE IS
THAT THEY HAVE TO BE RESPONSIVE.
TO THAT FACT THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE UNDERNEATH THE SYSTEMS.
THE AXIOM OF THIS IS THE WAY
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IT.
IS PART OF THE PROBLEM OF WHY
WE'RE DEALING WITH A BROKEN
SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CDC ARE OPERATES WITHIN A BOX.
AND THEY KNOW THIS.
THE KEEPING ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY DO AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER TODAY.
THE KEEPING THE THINGS THAT THEY
DO TO THEMSELVES WITHOUT ANY
EXTERNAL INCLUDE OR INSIGHT AS
TO HOW IT OPERATES AND THE
EFFECT THAT IT HAS ON THE PEOPLE.
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
SERVING.
WELL HERE WE'RE HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT IT'S NOT SERVING US.
IT'S A PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM.
BUT WE HAVE NO SAY SO IN WHO
THOSE PEERS ARE.
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR IN THE
ONE OF THE BASE TENANTS THAT
THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON YOU
WILL NOT REVIEW WILL NOT IMPOSE
UPON US SOMETHING WE HAVE NO SAY
SO IN.
WE ARE ASKING TODAY [inaudible]
FOR HELP.
WE'RE ASKING FOR A RE EVALUATION
OF THE SYSTEM THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY FAILING THE PEOPLE
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING.
OUR MEMBERS ARE DYING.
AND THEY'RE TINKERING AROUND THE
AGES.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE A WHOLESALE
CHANGE OF THE IN WAIT THIS
SYSTEM OPERATES.
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR FOR TO
ASK MEN AND WOMEN TO BE HELD AT
A HIGHER STANDARD. TO BE HELD AT
A HIGHER STANDARD. TO BE.
TO GET A HIGHER PAY.
GET A HIGHER RETIREMENT.
IN THE RECOGNITION THAT THE JOB
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
IS MORE DANGEROUS.
BUT THEN YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE WHOLE PERSON.
THAT'S IT'S NOT FAIR WE'RE WE'RE
LITERALLY TREATING PEOPLE AS IF
THEY'RE COGS IN THE MACHINE.
AND WE'RE DISPOSABLE.
WE WILL NOT.
WE CANNOT AS THE REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
STANDING ON THE LINE THAT IS
STANDING IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THE FORTIFICATION THAT HAS
OCCURRED.
AND JUST KEEP TOSSING US LIKE
WE'RE KINDLING ON THE ON THE ON
THE FIRE.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
AND WE'RE ASKING WE HUMBLY ASK.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
X. KOBE PRESIDED WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS WE WORK ALONGSIDE
OUR BROTHER AND SISTER CO --
OFFICERS ON THE DAILY BASIS
THEY'RE THE ONES TO KEEP US SAFE.
YET WE SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THE TRAGEDIES FROM THE TRAUMA
THEY INDOOR -- SO WE ARE HOPEFUL
ORDERLY IN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN SEIU LOCAL --
ONE THOUSAND WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS FOR A SEAT OUR OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO WORK WITH US IN
THOSE FACILITIES.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS
WITH -- THE SPONSOR I'M ON TO
TAKE SOME CARE SOME ISSUES THANK
YOU.
IT LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THREE NINE ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR BRAD BIRD.
ON BELIEVES MUCH OF THE QUESTION
IS A STATEMENT AND I WOULD.
I HEARD TO PASSION IN MISTER
WALKER'S TESTIMONY AS TO NOT
TREATING THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EVERY DAY -- TO TO THIS JOB AND
I THINK IT'S A TWO PRONGED
BENEFIT IF YOU TREAT THE MEN AND
WOMEN BETTER I WOULD HOPE THAT
WOULD BE BETTER.
INTERACTION WITH THOSE AND MADE
HIS WELL SO THEY TOO WILL SEE A
MORE HUMANE ENVIRONMENT IF THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE CHARGED
WITH LOOKING OVERSEE AND LOOKING
AFTER THEM.
WERE TREATED IN A MORE
RESPECTFUL MANNER SO DO YOU FEEL
THAT WILL BE ONE OF THE BENEFITS
AS WELL THROUGH THROUGH THIS
MEASURE ABSOLUTELY.
I BELIEVE THE IF WE WERE TO
BRING ANY OF THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES -- CLINICIANS
PRACTITIONERS IN DAY WILL TELL
YOU THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
DURING TRAUMA.
HAVE A DIFFICULTY EMPATHIZING
WITH ANYONE ELSE IT'S AN DURING
TRAUMA.
AND THIS SYSTEM FUNDAMENTALLY
IMPACTS EVERYONE ENGAGED IN IT.
AND WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF REALIZING THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE.
UNDER INVOLVED IN UNDERNEATH THE
SYSTEM SO YES.
THE SERMON GIPSON I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHY THIS IS DONE
LEGISLATIVELY AND NOT AS A MEET
AND CONFER OPPORTUNITY.
WELL.
LET ME ASK.
MISTER WALKER TO RESPOND TO THAT
NOW COMMENTS I DON'T KNOW I WANT
TO HEAR FROM YOU THE DESTRUCTIVE --
I'LL TELL YOU IN IN ALL CANDOR.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE THE
ASSOCIATION HAS FAILED AT FOUR
USE WE'VE THOUGHT.
WOULD LIKE THE SYSTEM DOES DID
REPRESENTATION WAS ABOUT MONEY.
WAS ABOUT SAFETY EQUIPMENT WAS
ABOUT RETIREMENT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD AN
OFFICER KILLED HIMSELF ABOUT.
SEVEN YEARS AGO WE'VE HAD.
MANY SINCE THEN.
BUT THAT WAS IF YOU WILL AN
AWAKENING. TO THE REALITY DID
ALL OF THAT STUFF DOES NOTHING
FOR THE PERSON OFF AND IT'S UP
ZERO COMFORT TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
THE OTHER SURVIVING THAT
INDIVIDUAL -- SO WE BEGAN AN
EFFORT OF ENGAGING.
IN OUTSIDE THE NORMAL
NEGOTIATING PROCESS -- WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION DURING GOVERNOR
BROWN'S ADMINISTRATION AND WE
WERE TOLD THAT THIS WOULD NOT.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE NORMAL NEGOTIATING PROCESS
THAT WE WOULD CARE DID EVERYBODY
RECOGNIZED IT ALL WHILE DO
PEOPLE.
THAT ARE SUFFERING -- SAID WE
THEY'VE PROVEN THAT NOT TO BE
TRUE THERE DISINGENUOUS IN THEIR
IN THEIR WHOLE EFFORT.
OF CARING FOR PEOPLE SO AT SOME
POINT PROBABLY THIS NECKS
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS YOU WILL
SEE [inaudible]
SOME -- HOPEFULLY SOME SOME
AMENDED -- CHAIR ARTICLES
INCORPORATED INTO OUR AMMO YOU
BUT FOR RIGHT NOW.
THEY WON'T DO IT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE WITH
HERE TO YOU WE'VE WE'VE S.. TO
BE PART OF THIS SYSTEM.
AND THEY JUST FLAT OUT NO.
SO THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO
GET IT IS EITHER.
THROUGH YOU OR THROUGH
NEGOTIATIONS ON UNFORTUNATELY
NEGOTIATIONS IS A MEET AND
CONFER.
PROCESS SO IF THEY'RE TELLING US
NO ON SOMETHING THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A HEALTH RELATED
EFFORT.
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA TELL US
NO WITH THE TABLE AS WELL.
SO WE HAVE TO COME TO YOU.
WHO ARE MEMBERS ARE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND WE'RE?
THE BILL LITERALLY AT YOUR MERCY
TO TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE HURTING.
AND DISS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A PIECEMEAL
EFFORT -- I WOULD SAY IT'S A
VERY DEMANDING MISS CHANGES TO
THEIR POWER AND CONTROL. TO
SIMPLY SAY NO YOU HAVE TO TALK
TO YOUR EMPLOYEES.
SO -- MISTER WALKER.
TO REPEAT ON RIGHT AT IT.
HE SAID WE HAVE NOT PUT IT IN
THEM -- YOU REQUEST AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE.
OUT BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
KIND OF HINTED OR TOLD THAT IT.
IT WOULD BE A NON NEGOTIABLE
ITEM.
SO SO WE HAVEN'T PUSHED THE MEET
AND CONFER OPPORTUNITY YET BUT
YOU PLAN TO DO IT AT THE NEXT.
BARGAINING ROUND.
WHICH WHATEVER YOU WE JUST WE
JUST APPROVED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVE ONE FOR ONE
YEAR RIGHT RIGHT SO SO.
SO YOU DIDN'T DO IT. FOR THE
CURRENT CONTRACT BUT YOU PLAN TO
DO IT FOR THE NEXT CONTRACT WELL --
CONSIDERABLY MORE HOLISTIC
EFFORT YES BUT THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT IS DID THEY HAVE TO AGREE
TO DO IT AND THUS FAR.
THEY'VE BEEN UNWILLING TO MATE
ANY WHOLESALE CHANGES TO THE
SYSTEM AS I SAID THEY WANT TO
TINKER AROUND THE AGES AND AND
PUT A NEW VENEER OF OF PAINT.
ON IT TOO ON THE OTHER ONE I I
DO WANT TO GET INTO TO THE
EMOTION YES.
YES I'M JUST LOOKING AT IT
ADMINISTRATIVELY WE KNOW WHAT'S
THE PROCESS AND HOW SHOULD I
RESPECT THE PROCESS THE PROCESS
IS THE DAY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
THE SYSTEM DO IT BUT YOU'VE
YOU'VE TOLD ME THAT YOU HAVEN'T.
BROUGHT IT INTO THE BARGAINING.
BECAUSE WHEN I SOLD WE WOULD
NEED TO DO IT AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE DID WE JUST DO IT IN THIS
UNOFFICIAL CAPACITY.
BUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS TAKEN
OUR IDEAS AND I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
YEARS OF WORK AND DAVE.
BASICALLY SKIM THE TOP OF IT OFF.
AS AN ATTEMPT FOR ANYONE THAT
LOOKS AT IT NOW.
YOU'LL SEE AT THE VERY SERVICE
OF IT DID IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'VE
DONE SOMETHING BUT ON THE GROUND.
THERE'S NO FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE.
SO I'M TELLING YOU DE IN SHORT.
THEY'LL TELL YOU THEY'LL COME
BACK AND TELL YOU ALL YOU DON'T
NEED THIS BILL YU DON'T NEED TO
DO THAT LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE.
BUT AND JUST THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE.
DALY DECIDED ON THEIR OWN
WITHOUT ANY INPUT FROM US TO GO
OUT AND BUY MASSAGE TEARS.
AND PUT THEM IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING I DON'T
KNOW IF I WANT TO GO THERE.
SIDE YOU KNOW THE BIG DAY -- I'M
I'M AGAIN JUST TRYING. TO TO
DETERMINE THE PROCESS TO BE FAIR
TO THE TO THAT YES.
SO SO WITH THAT I I AM I HAVE A
LITTLE DIFFICULTY WITH YOUR BILL
SOON.
GIPSON SIDE JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THE THAT THAT THERE'S A A
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATIONS AND I I
WONDER IF IT THAT'S BEING SHORT
CUT IT SO MAYBE IN YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENT YOU CAN.
TELL ME I'M NOT GETTING THIS
BILL RIGHT.
I PREFER THE QUESTION SENATOR --
LET ME JUST WILL BY WALK YOU
THROUGH -- THROUGH ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO WHEN I HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET WITH FAMILY MEMBERS I'M
AT THE BILTMORE HOTEL IN LOS
ANGELES.
I WAS A GATHERING OF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AT THAT
GATHERING I HEARD FROM -- WIVES
AND CHILDREN WHO LOST THEIR
LOVED ONES DUE TO SUICIDE -- IF
YOU EVER.
ACTUALLY VISIT A STATE PRISON
BEFORE -- WHERE YOU SEE -- THE
HARD CORE INDIVIDUALS AS THERE
AND TAKING HOME I'VE HEARD FROM
A MOTHER.
pCOMMITTED SUICIDE AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER TAKING THAT
HOME WITHDRAWING THEMSELVES FROM
THE FAMILY ROUTINE.
ISOLATING HIMSELF -- AND THOSE
SITUATIONS -- WAS NOT NOTICEABLE --
TO THE POINT WHERE -- HELP COULD
BE RENDERED IMMEDIATELY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES -- TAKE THAT WORK AND
THAT STRESS LEVEL HOME EACH AND
EVERY DAY AND TO THINK.
AS THE ASSOCIATION HAS WORKED
WITH A MANAGEMENT TO TRY -- TO
GET -- YOU KNOW A COMPREHENSIVE
PEER SYSTEMS REVIEW KIND OF
PROGRAM IN PLACE TO THINK THAT
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY FACILITATE
THAT THAT'S THE REASON WHY THIS
BILLS BEFORE YOU BECAUSE THERE'S
NO BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL IN
FACT DO JUST THAT KIND OF THING.
THERE'S NO BELIEVE THAT THEY
WILL STAND BY THE WORD SO THAT'S
THE REASON WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO SIMPLY
SAY.
ON THAT WE NEED A PEER --
SUPPORT GROUP SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH IN THE
CORRECTION FACILITY CAN HAVE A
PEER -- TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT THEY FACE EACH
AND EVERY DAY -- AND SO TOO
AGAIN LOOK AT THOSE WHO HAVE WHO
HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE AND WHAT --
THE OFFICERS HAVE TO GO THROUGH
ON A DAILY BASIS -- I INDICATED
ABOUT THE HYPERTENSION -- I
INDICATED ABOUT THE DIABETES
MORE THAN ANY AVERAGE AMERICAN
FACE WITH AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT
GOES ALONG WITH THE JOB AND SO
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY CERTAINLY
THEY COULD TRY TO GET AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE BUT ALSO THEY
CAN.
REQUEST THAT WE DO NOT GO TO BAR
pHE DOES THAT HELP -- OFFICERS
WHO ARE AGAIN DEALING WITH THE
STRESS OF THE WORK AND THE
TENSION AND THE DEPRESSION AND
THE SUICIDAL TENDENCIES GO ALONG
WITH THE WORK THAT DOESN'T HELP
THEM AT ALL AND SO THIS BILL IS
VERY ECESSARY I THINK IT'S VERY
TIMELY.
AND I THINK CCPOA FOR ALLOW ME
TO BE THE THE CONDUIT TO BRING
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I'VE SIMPLY
ASKED WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU PASTOR GIPSON OF THANK
THE MOTION OR IS THERE A MOTION
READY ON THIS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BETTER.
CLERK IF WE COULD TAKE THE ROLE.
AT FIFTY PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORLOCK.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
RIGHT WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN.
SERVER GIPSON THANKS FOR YOUR
PASSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE TEXAS NOW TO A BEAT NINE OH
ONE YES.
THE LIGHT IT UP.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR
SENATOR OF ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE A ONE WHICH
SEEKS TO IN IN -- WELL TO
ENCOURAGE THE APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION FOR YOUTH WHO ARE
AT RISK AS OPPOSED TO BEING
CRIMINALIZE ON THE BASIS OF
TRUANCY AND OTHER BEHAVIOR
ISSUES -- WHICH ARE UNRELATED TO
THE ACTUAL CRIMES -- IT IS THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL THAT TRUANCY
AND OTHER STATUTES OF FANS -- BE --
DIVERTED FROM CITATIONS A REST
AND COURTS MIGHT BE -- WOULD
DELETE THE AUTHORITY -- TO A
JUDGE.
A PERSON WHO IS BETWEENTHE AGES
OF TWELVE AND SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
AGE AS A WARD OF THE CURT BASED
ON TRUANCY.
INSTEAD OF PEACE OFFICERS AND
NEEDING TO REFER ANY MINOR UNDER
THE JURISDICTION -- TO A
COMMUNITY BASED DIVERSION
PROGRAM -- UNAVAILABLE MY BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT TO CONTRACT.
TOOK TO CONTRACT OR OFFER
SERVICES THAT READ THAT PROVIDES --
UP LOCATION JOB SKILL TRAINING
COUNSELING MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCE EDUCATIONAL OP SUPPORT
ART RECREATION AND OTHER YOUTH --
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES THAT THESE
YOUTH NEED WITHIN THESE PROGRAMS
PROBATION DEPARTMENT WILL NOT BE
AUTHORIZED TO MAINTAIN A FORMAL
OR INFORMAL CASELOAD OR CREATING
A MANDATE MANDATE A PROBATION A
CONDITION. FOR MINOR NOT ON
PROBATION BUT THESE PROGRAMS
WILL STILL BE ALLOWED THAT UP
WITH THAT PARTICIPANTS OF THE
YOUTH WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON
PROBATION WHO MAY ALSO BENEFIT
FROM THESE -- IN ORDER TO STRAY
AWAY FROM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE --
SYSTEM.
WELL I WOULD I DO NOT ARGUE THAT
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM MUST HAVE I A
BACKDROP UP WITH THOSE WHO ARE
AND WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES.
WE MUST ALSO CREATE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN -- THOSE WHO
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW AND COMMIT A
CRIME VERSES THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
THOSE WHO -- HOOPS THEY DON'T
VOLUNTEER PROBATION JUST BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN SHORT JUST BECAUSE
THEY MAY HAVE DISOBEYED A
TEACHER IN THE CLASSROOM JUST
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN LATE TO
CLASS -- WE MUST CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE LET ME
ALSO SAY CALIFORNIA JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS BEEN --
DRAMATICALLY I'M TRANSFORM OVER
THE LAST. FIFTEEN YEARS TO ITS
CREDIT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
PART OF THESE POSITIVE CHANGES
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR TO TO HELP
REDUCE -- POLICIES -- REFERRALS
TO JUVENILE HALL DIVERSION
PROGRAMS -- FROM COURTS AND
OTHER ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS CAMPS --
WE MUST KEP IN MIND THAT WE
WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS EARLY SO THAT
THEY WOULD NOT GET CAUGHT UP IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
EARLY AGE AND THE COMMON WAY OF
GETTING INDIVIDUALS CAUGHT UP IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS IN FACT --
BY CITING THEM FOR TRUANCY WITH
ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES ARE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION.
AND ALSO THE ACLU WHO WAS SELF
INTRODUCE.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ARE YOU MORE AND THOMAS I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AND A MEMBER
OF THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION.
WE ARE HONORED TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINE A
pPROBATION DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE TO PUT.
USE WHO HAVE NOT BEENTO COURT.
UNDER PROBATION SUPERVISION
INCLUDING REPORTING TO A
PROBATION OFFICER.
BEING PART OF PROBATION CASE
LOAD OR HAVING SO FOLLOW
CONDITIONS.
N. IS SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS A
VOLUNTARY PROBATION.
BUT IN OUR EXPERIENCES IT IS NOT
VOLUNTARY.
IN LA COUNTY WE ORGANIZE IN THIS
PRACTICE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THOUSANDS OF
YOUTH IN LA COUNTY ALONG
REPORTING TO A PROBATION OFFICER.
81% FOR SCHOOL ATTENDED
ATTENDANCE OR LOW GRADES FEDERAL
SPENDING MONEY ON TUTORING OR
COUNSELING.
USER FORTY TWO A PROBATION
OFFICER IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
YOU'D ON VOLUNTARY PROVISION
HAVE THE SEARCH REGULARLY AND
REQUIRED TO DRUGS IS.
I WANT TO VENICE HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES I'VE NEVER BEEN
ARRESTED AND I WASN'T ON
PROBATION.
BUT THE SCHOOL PROBATION OFFICER
USED TO STOP ME ON A DAILY BASIS.
HE WORE SU IN DARK SUNGLASSES
AND WALKED AROUND WITH THE
CLIPBOARD.
HE ONLY CALLED ME BY MY LAST
NAME.
HE WAS SAY.
MARTIN YOUR ON PROBATION YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO COME SEE ME.
I WAS SAY NO I'M NOT ON
PROBATION.
BUT HE WOULD SAY YOUR ON MY
ROSTER.
IT MADE ME FEEL LIKE A BAD KEY.
AND I THINK IT MAY OTHER PEOPLE
IN MY SCHOOL ALSO SEE ME THOUGH
IT.
I STILL DON'T KNOW HOW I GOT ON
THE LOOSE WITH THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT.
I DID ME SUPPORT.
MY MOM WAS RAISING ME AND MY
LITTLE BROTHER BARS SELF.
AND SHE GOT VERY SICK A PUT A
LOT OF PRESSURE ON ME TO DO MORE
HOME IS STILL CONCENTRATE ON
SCHOOL.
I STARTED GETTING ANGRY AND
FRUSTRATED MORE.
BUT THE SCHOOL PROBATION OFFICER
NEVER OFFERED ME ANY COUNSELING
OR HELP WITH SCHOOL WORK.
WHEN I GOT INTO A FIGHT AT
SCHOOL?
AGAIN NO ONE EVER ASKS ME WHERE
MAYBE SO ANGRY OR SAT ME DOWN
WITH THE OTHER STUDENTS TO WORK
THINGS OUT.
I WAS EXPELLED AND I WASN'T
REFERRED TO ANOTHER SCHOOL.
WHICH I FOUND OUT LATER IS
AGAINST THE LAW.
I WAS OUT OF SCHOOL FOR MONTHS.
I WILL LEAVE EVERY DAY FROM HOME
JUST TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE I WAS
IN SCHOOL.
BUT I WAS REALLY IN THE STREETS
ARE THEY WOMAN WANTS AND ALWAYS
KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
EVENTUALLY I WROTE IN ANOTHER
SCHOOL BUT THERE WHEN A TEACHER
MOTORISTS COMMON IN CLASS.
I LOST MY TEMPER INTO A CHAIR.
I WAS ARRESTED AND TAKEN TO
JUVENILE.
PROBATION TELL ME THIS IS WHERE
I WOULD BE FOR A LONG TIME.
I WAS TOLD I WOULDN'T BE HOME
FOR CHRISTMAS.
IT WAS A VERY HUMILIATING
EXPERIENCE.
I WAS PUT ON PROBATION FOR THREE
YEARS DURING THE ENTIRE TIME I
WAS ON PROBATION I NEVER HAS
SUPPORT.
RE ENROLLING IN SCHOOL.
I WAS TOLD TO DO ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES FOR HIGH RISK
HIGH NEEDS YOUTH.
BUT MY MOTHER COULDN'T AFFORD
THE FEES.
SO BASICALLY ALL I GOT DURING
THOSE THREE YEARS WHOSE DRUG
TESTS HE SHOULD USE WHO HAVE
COMMITTED NO CRIME BE LIKE A
CRIMINAL IN THE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES.
IF I HAD GOTTEN COUNSELING OR
CHILDREN INSTEAD OF SO CALLED
VOLUNTARY PROBATION SUPERVISION
MAYBE I WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL OR REST THE
MAYBE I WOULD HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD.
MAYBE I WILL BE IN COLLEGE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF YOU THAT
MY SAME STORY AND OUR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES WHEN YOU CENTERS
AND JOBS FOR YOU.
WE NEED COLLEGE PREPARATION
INSTEAD.
WE WHEN WE ARE PUT ON PROBATION
SEARCHED AND QUESTIONED WE ARE
GETTING PRISON PREPARATION.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB NINE
OWN.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF AB.
NINE OH ONE THE ISSUES AB NINE A
ONE ADDRESSES CAME TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE ACLU IT'S THE
RESULT OF OUR WORK IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT IN
RIVERSIDE PLACED OVER THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN ON PROBATION
CONTRACTS FOR NORMAL YOUTHFUL
BEHAVIOR.
BASED ON THE BROAD AUTHORITY
GRANTED UNDER WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION.
SIX FIFTY FOUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OFTEN REFERRED TO PROBATION FOR
VIOLATIONS OF WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION SIX OH
ONE WHICH MAKES IT AN OFFENSE
FOR JUVENILE TO BE A TRUE AND OR
TO PERSISTENTLY OR HABITUALLY
REFUSE TO OBEY THE REASONABLE
AND PROPER ORDERS OF SCHOOL
SORTIES.
REASONS GIVEN FOR PLACING USE ON
PROBATION IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
HAVE INCLUDED PRE DELINQUENT
SCHOOL MISBEHAVIOR.
INCORRIGIBLE EDDIE DEFIANCE AND
EVEN POOR GRADES.
IN ONE CASE A STUDENT WAS PLACED
ON SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR
PROBATION FOR BEHAVIOR RELATED
TO PRE FROM THE DEATH OF A BABY
SISTER.
ENFORCEMENT FALLS PROPORTION DID
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON STUDENTS
OF COLOR.
ONCE REFERRED TO USE AND THEIR
PARENTS ARE OFTEN TOLD THAT IF
THEY DON'T AGREE TO PROBATION
THEIR CASES COULD BE REFERRED TO
THE DA ALTHOUGH IN MOST OF THESE
CASES THERE IS NO OFFENSE FOR
WHICH A PETITION.
WOULD BE FILED.
UNDER SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR
INFORMAL PROBATION PROGRAMS CAN
OPERATE WITH NONE OF THE
SAFEGUARDS OF THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS SUCH AS ACCESS TO
APPOINTED COUNSEL OR ADEQUATE
KNOWS NOTICE OF CHARGES OR THE
UNDERLYING FACTS OR ANY KIND OF
IMPARTIAL DECISION MAKER.
YET YOUNG PEOPLE AND UP ON
PROBATION CONDITIONS THAT ARE
OFTEN MORE PUNITIVE THAN A JUDGE
WOULD ASSIGN AS AS WE'VE JUST
HEARD THIS IS NOT WHAT THE YOUTH
NEED TO ADDRESS THE KINDS OF
PROBLEMS. FOR WHICH THEY ARE
BEING PUT ON THESE PROGRAMS.
YOUTH AGREE -- TO TERMS
INCLUDING BROAD SEARCHES OF
THEIR PERSONS AND HOMES AS WELL
AS RANDOM DRUG TESTING WE KNOW
THAT THIS KIND OF SURVEILLANCE
BASED PROGRAM DOES NOT WORK WITH
YOUTH TO PREVENT FUTURE
MISBEHAVIOR.
STUDENTS ACCUSED OF SCHOOL
MISBEHAVIOR OR LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES SHOULD BE REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATE SERVES SERVICE
PROVIDERS NOT TO PROBATION.
EIGHTY NINE A ONE WILL LIMIT THE
USE OF VOLUNTARY PROBATION TO
THOSE CASES WHERE IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO ENSURE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN SUPPORT OF OUTCOMES
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ROLEX SORRY BUT NO PROBLEM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
DOLPHY ON THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
WITH THE DEATH WOULD BURNS
INSTITUTE WE ARE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT BASED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WORKING TO REDUCE
RACIAL NOTHING DISPARITIES IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE'RE HONORED TO CO SPONSOR
EIGHTY NINE A ONE AND ARE HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
EIGHTY NINE A ONE MAKES
IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS TO THE
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE THAT
PROTECTS CHILDREN WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ACCUSED OF CRIMES FROM THE
HARMS OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OF THE HARMS OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM FALL DESPERATELY ON YOUTH
OF COLOR.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BLACK YOUTH
WERE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE REFERRED TO PROBATION LATINO
YOUTH ONE AND A HALF TIMES MORE
LIKELY AND NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH
TWICE AS LIKELY.
IMPORTANTLY THIS JUSTICE SYSTEM
CONTACT WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT
FROM THE COURT IS NOT BENIGN.
RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
SUPERVISION OF YOU TO OUR LOW
RISK DOES MORE HARM THAN GOOD
BOTH FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR
THE YOUTH AND ACTUALLY INCREASES
THE CHANCE THAT YOU WILL BECOME
MORE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WILL BE MORE LIKELY TO DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL.
SORRY IS STORY CERTAINLY
ILLUSTRATES THIS WELL AND
SERIOUS STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
THOUSANDS OF YOUTH IN LA IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ALONE WERE
SUBJECT TO THESE HARMS OF THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
FERNANDO GIRALDO THE CHIEF OF
PROBATION FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
WITH MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE AS A PROBATION
OFFICER HOPE TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE HIS SUPPORT BUT HE WAS
UNABLE.
TO HE DID SUBMIT A LETTER OF
SUPPORT AND IN THAT LETTER HE
SAYS.
EVEN WHEN PROBATION OFFICERS
HAVE THE BEST OF INTENTIONS THIS
IS A MISUSE OF PROBATION.
THAT CAN UNINTENTIONALLY NOT
WIDEN USE INTO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM RATHER THAN PREVENT THEM
FROM COMING INTO THE SYSTEM.
BASED ON MY XPERIA EXPERIENCE I
BELIEVE THAT DIVERTING YOU FROM
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN INTO
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES
SHOULD BE USED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT.
AND THAT CONTACT WITH THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM SHOULD BE LIMITED.
AND WITH THAT I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW WE GET TO WITNESSES AT THE
MIKE -- CARES WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE IT ON WITH THE
WIDENING GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
IRVING OUR IS YOU JUST COALITION
BUSINESS OF COALITION IS WOULD
HAVE HELPED ME GREATLY ABOUT IT
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
A LONG TIME AGO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING QUE WHEN DEAN PROUD
CO SPONSORS -- WITH THE LINES
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THE ROBOT TO DO JUST COALITION
OF PRO PRO COLD MONTHS TO THE
BILL THANK YOU.
MARGOT WINDOW OF WESTERN CENTER
ALONG PARTY IN SUPPORT. THREE
WONDER MENDOZA NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW AND CO FOUNDER OF
GOT US IN SOUTH SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- THIS BILL DEFINITELY
WAS -- SUPPORT LATINO COMMUNITY
LATINO YOUTH LIKE MYSELF FOR IN
THE STREETS WERE ALSO
INCARCERATED -- ABSOLUTELY I'VE
HEARD IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
WORKING AS A CASE MANAGER AS YOU
CAN WHICH WORKING AS A MENTOR
FROM PARENTS THAT.
OFTEN TIMES THEY THEY WOULD BE
WONDER HOW COME THERE YOU THEIR
CHILD WHO'S NOT ON PROBATION
CAN'T RECEIVE THE SERVICES.
AND I HAVE OFTEN THOUGHT ABOUT
EVEN.
HAVING THEIR CHILDREN GET IN
TROUBLE TO RECEIVE SERVICES FOR
HIS DEPRESSING IS SAD SITUATION
SOWE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT AB NOT
A ONE FRANCESCA SHE GOING
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN
SUPPORT.
DARIA THE READ THE DAY WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOING BACK IS FEEL A BIGGER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
KAT CARRILLO SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT.
HELEN ROSS THOUSAND CC WHY IN
SUPPORT.
CAN WE GO WITH YOU JUST
COALITION ON RECALL SPONSORS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
REYES AYE FULLER NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW I WAS ON PROBATION
MY ENTIRE ADOLESCENCE AGE
THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN ABSOLUTELY
EXPERIENCE THE HARMS THAT HAVE
BEEN -- SHARED BY THE FOLKS
TESTIFYING TODAY OF PROBATION --
AND THE LATER CONSEQUENCES
INCLUDING DROPPING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND ADULT PERSPIRATION
PROBATION IS ABSOLUTELY A
HARMFUL TO YOUNG PEOPLE AND THIS
BILL IT WOULD PREVENT.
WOULD KEEP JUST THE DO THE VERY
LEAST TO KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T EVEN COMMITTED A CRIME
OR BEEN ACCUSED OF A CRIME.
IN SYSTEM IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ALEJANDRA GUTIERREZ COMMUNITY
MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE SOME SORELY TO MAKE
ROOM AT THE TABLE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
GREAT AHEAD HE GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS.
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO START OFF BY SAYING THAT
WE SHARE IN ALL OF THE SENTIMENT
THAT WE HAVE HEARD.
IN OUR GOAL OF KEEPING YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BOTH AS MINORS AS WELL AS AS
YOUNG ADULTS -- WE HAVE BEEN
ALSO WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON'S OFFICE ON
CERTAIN AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE.
TO BRING UP TODAY THAT WE THINK
ARE VITAL SPECIFICALLY WITH
REGARDS TO THE ASPECTS
SURROUNDING TRUANCY CHRONIC
TRUANCY IN HAVE VISUAL TRUANCY
IN TEENAGERS -- OUR OFFICE.
HASBEEN WORKING IN THE FIELD OF
COMBATING CHRONIC TRUANCY FOR
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS AND I
HAVE BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
WORKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OUR COUNTY THIS
WHOLE TIME.
AS WELL AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STATE INCLUDING
AROUND THE NATION IN COMBATING
TRUANCY.
WE'RE KEENLY AWARE.
OF THE TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES OF
YOUNG PEOPLE STARTING IN
KINDERGARTEN ALL THE WAY THROUGH
HIGH SCHOOL WHO MISSED SO MUCH
SCHOOL THAT THEIR CHANCES OF
GRADUATING BECOME.
NOLAN VOID WE KNOW THAT THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY
EVENTUALLY TO ENTER THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM BOTH AS VICTIMS
OF CRIME AS WELL AT TIMES AS
THOSE WHO COMMIT CRIMES.
WE ALSO ARE VERY WELL AWARE THAT
THERE ARE MYRIAD FACTORS
UNDERLYING -- SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM.
I HAVE RARELY MET A FAMILY WHO
JUST AS WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
EDUCATION OF OUR CHILD OR A
CHILD HE SAYS.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT MY OWN FUTURE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE IS SCHOOL
ANXIETY.
UNTREATED MEDICAL ISSUES
SUBSTANCE ABUSE BULLYING
TRANSPORTATION PROBLEMS ISSUES
OF HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY.
AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH.
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
AS DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
PROBATION ARE ALLOWED TO WORK
ALONGSIDE OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HEALTH CARE
ORGANIZATIONS.
SUCH AS ASTHMA START AND COUNTY
HEALTH CARE TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS.
WE KNOW THAT EARLY INTERVENTION
ALWAYS IS KEY AND BEST SCHOOL
STATE INTERVENTION SCHOOL
DISTRICT INTERVENTION.
IS THE BEST IN.
COMBATING TRUANCY AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF TRUANCY AND
COMBATING TRUANCY AS A PYRAMID
WITH THE MOST INTENSIVESERVICES.
FRONT LOADED OUT THE SCHOOL AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WE KNOW THAT
IS THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND TO HAVE THE CHILDREN
NEVER COME BEFORE A COURT.
OR A DA OR PROBATION DEPARTMENT
HOWEVER.
IT IS A TRAGIC AND SAD REALITY
THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS AND OUR
FAMILIES THAT DESPITE ALL OF THE
BEST EFFORTS OF THE SCHOOLS AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DO NOT TURN AROUND THE
ATTENDANCE ISSUE THERE MAY BE
MEETING AFTER MEETING AN
INTERVENTION AFTER INTERVENTION
AND SLOWLY THAT PYRAMID REACHES
A PEAK WHERE THE CASE CAN BE
REFERRED. TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT -- AND WE WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING ISSUES AND
HOPEFULLY.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS YOUNG PERSON
NEVER ENTERS THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM -- CERTAIN
AMENDMENTS TO THE STATUTE
HOWEVER THIS THIS BILL ARE VITAL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PLAY THE ROLE THAT WE NEED TO
PLAY IN THE LIVES OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
FIRST OFF AND I AND AS I SAID WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS DISCUSSING THIS IN
DEPTH -- PART OF THE BILL THROWS
INTO QUESTION AMBIGUITY WHETHER
OR OF MEDIATION PROGRAM WELL THE
BILL STILL DOES ALLOW IT WHETHER
THAT COULD BE -- NOW CONSIDERED
PRETTY EARLY VOLUNTARY ON THE
SIDE OF BOTH THE FAMILY AND THE
STUDENT AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO CLEAR UP THAT AMBIGUITY
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE MEDIATION.
PROGRAMS WHEN THEY ARE NECESSARY
AND THEY ARE NECESSARY A TIME OR
STILL MANDATORY LIKEWISE -- WE
ALWAYS TELL EVERY STUDENT THAT
WE WORK WITH THAT OUR GOAL IS TO
ENSURE HERE SHE IS BACK IN
SCHOOL AND THRIVING.
BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHERE WE DO
NEED TO BRING A STUDENT BEFORE
JUVENILE COURT SETTING AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WOULD BE
WELL AMENDED TO ENSURE THAT ONLY
CHILDREN WHO ARE.
CHRONICALLY TRUANT AS WE DEFINED
IN PENAL CODE SECTION TWO
SEVENTY POINT ONE A FEW YEARS
AGO AND THAT THE JUVENILE COURT
SETTING HAS A DEDICATED AND
FULLY ENRICHED TRUANCY COURT.
COULD.
HOW THIS CASES BROUGHT BEFORE
THEM BUT WE DO FEEL THAT IN A
VERY CHEMICAL OF THAT PYRAMID --
WE DO VERY GOOD WORK.
AND WE REALLY DO CHANGE ABOUT --
THE ATTENDANCE PATTERNS AND THE
UNDERLYING FACTORS THAT CREATED
THE TRUANCY IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND WE WOULD -- WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY THAT.
THIS CERTAIN AMENDMENTS THAT WE
ARE OFFERING WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THAT VITAL WORK THANK
YOU.
NEXT WITNESS THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA -- HERE
IN OPPOSITION TODAY I DO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON --
IN HIS OFFICE AN THE SPONSORS
FOR CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND
AND DO YOU WANT TO NOTE THAT
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND
AND WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT --
BUT WE CAME TO THE TABLE I THINK
EARLY ON WITH A VERY MUCH THE
SAME SPIRIT AND GOAL WITHIN THIS
BILL WHICH IS -- TO PROVIDE
INTERVENTION AND DIVERSION
SERVICES IN A VERY ROBUST MANNER
THAT KEEPS YOU THOUGHT OF THE
SYSTEMS WE TO SHARE -- THE
CONCERN IN AND FEEL LIKE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO HAVE
ABOUT -- LOOKING OUT REFERRALS --
FROM OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
INTERVENTIONS ARE ARE RIGHT FOR
THE FOR THE YOUTH AND THE
BEHAVIOR AND SO WE WE COME TO A
PLACE I THINK OF OF COMMON
GROUND ON THAT -- WHERE WE HAVE
CONCERNS THOUGH OR OF REMAINING
IN THE BILL -- ARE A FEW
PROVISIONS SPECIFIC TO THE
MANNER IN WHICH PROBATION
SPECIFICALLY A DIVERSION AN
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS CAN BE
OFFERED -- WE ARE OPEN TO WOULD
HAVE PROVIDED LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD -- PROVIDE CLARITY ON
THOSE SECTIONS WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WITH CONTINUE DISCUSSION
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD ON
THAT ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE CAN BE
TAKEN TO ADDRESS SOME OF OUR OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS -- THERE ARE
A FEW PIECES IN THE BILL THAT
KIND OF FUNDAMENTALLY RECAST THE
MANNER IN WHICH PROBATION CAN
OFFER AND IT RE PRIORITIZES WHO
CAN OFFER SERVICES PRIOR TO
PROBATION.
THERE'S A CONCERN THAT THAT DOES
NOT REFLECT MANY OF THE
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS AND WE
CERTAINLY CAN SURE THAT WITH
THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT ARE ON EXISTING STATEWIDE
AT THAT ARE BOTH -- COORDINATED
BY PROBATION WITH CBO'S WITH --
PUBLIC HEALTH EDUCATION AND
OTHER TECH THAT OTHER ENTITIES
WE DON'T WANT -- THOSE TO BE
HARMED OR LOST -- BY NATURE OF
THIS BILL -- AND SO AGAIN WE WE
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WE TO
SHARE THE SPIRIT WE HAVE SOME
VERY SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
SOME OF THE REMAINING PIECES IN
THE BILL AND AND AGAIN
ULTIMATELY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AND TO ENGINES ARE DONE
IN THE RIGHT WAY.
WERE OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION
AND APPRECIATIVE OF IT -- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING MORE.
THANK YOU RIGHT THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN.
SHARE MEMBERS WORRY WARS.
LAURIE MORE SUNDRY HAPPEL BOOK
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION -- WE TO SHARE MANY
OF THE AMBITIONS -- WILL OF THIS
BILL -- BUT WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS -- THAT ASPECTS OF THE
BILL WILL -- INHIBIT THE IN
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE BY DA'S OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
JUVENILE CRIME IS DOWN IN ITS
DOWN DRAMATICALLY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA -- FIGHT CRIME INVEST
IN KIDS -- ROOM RELEASED A
LANDMARK STUDY SEVERAL YEARS AGO
THAT SAID HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUTS
OR SEVEN TIMES. SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO END UP IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SO OUR EFFORTS HAVE ALL BEEN
DESIGNED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY COULD TO IN INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL AS A
FORMER DISTRICT ATTORNEY I MADE
IT A NUMBER ONE PRIORITY -- TO
WORK WITH THE SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOL OF SCHOOLS AND THE THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AS THE SINGLE.
MOST SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION I
COULD MAKE AS PROSECUTOR WAS TO
GET AS MANY KIDS AS POSSIBLE
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL AND
GRADUATION FOR THE LONG TERM
SAFETY OF A COMMUNITY.
THAT IS THE ONE LASTING --
IMPACT THAT WE CAN MAKE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN PLACE
ACROSS -- COUNTIES LIKE ALAMEDA
AND MONTEREY -- SACRAMENTO OR
DOING THIS IMPORTANT WORK EACH
AND EVERY DAY AND ARE HAVING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT IN INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF KIDS WERE
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL --
AND WHILE WE WE SHARE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED IN THIS BILL WE
BELIEVE THE PROVISIONS OF IT --
WILL ACTUALLY **** OR EFFORTS --
TO CONTINUE TO CREATE THESE
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVEN SUCCESSFUL AND WE
ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT -- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL TAKE A GOOD
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN OFFERED THEY DO NOT IN ANY
WAY -- INHIBIT HIS PROGRAM FROM
THEM FROM CONTINUING HIS SOME OF
THE OBJECTIVES FROM BEING
IMPLEMENTED BUT THEY GIVE T.
A.'S THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
FASHION COLLABORATIVE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE PROVEN TO WORK.
I'D LIKE -- SEVENTY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THE
MIKE.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
SIZER ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
OFFICE WHEN I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON IS STAFF AND
SPONSORS WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
VERY PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS WITH
THEM -- WE'VE RAISED CONCERNS
THAT THE BILL -- CLEARLY
UNINTENTIONALLY WOULD ELIMINATE
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
THROUGH COUNTY.
IS USUALLY AT THE WITH PARTY HAD
THREE SUBSTANTIVE WITNESSES OUT
YOUR WE WE JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ME ON
WITH THE NEXT SPONSORS WITNESS.
THANK YU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS.
SIMPLY EMPLOYEE OPPOSE THAT'S
ALL WE NEED RIGHT NOW KEEP GOING.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS THANK
YOU.
KAREN L<c.cyan>G UNDER THE SOLANO</c>
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION.
CORSO'S ALONG THE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
MMHM SKEWS ME ANY OTHER
OPPONENTS OR TRAINERS.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S -- OPEN IT TO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS.
A SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY THAT TO NETTIE OUT
FOR THE TIME.
ALWAYS ALWAYS DRESSED FOR THE
OCCASION -- I APOLOGIZE SAID I
DIDN'T HEAR PART OF THIS BUT THE
QUESTION I'M ASKING MYSELF -- IS
ARE THESE PROGRAMS GOOD FOR OUR
KIDS TO THE HELP. TO THE HELP
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE.
AT RISK OR AGAINST AND WE WANT
TO CALL IT A PROMISE. TO BE --
AT TO TO FIND A BETTER PATH ARE
WE ARE WE DISCOVERING THAT THEY
THEY DO THESE PROGRAMS TO IN
FACT HELP.
OUR USE -- FOR IS THERE IT ARE
WE CONCERNED THAT THE STATUS OF
WORKING WITH PROBATION.
WHEN YOU'RE NOT ON PROBATION HAS
SUCH A A NEGATIVE CONNOTATION IN
A NEGATIVE ASPECT TO IT I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD?
WHICH IS KIND OF YOU KNOW GET
RIGHT TO THAT PARTICULAR
QUESTION SURE I JUST WISH THAT
YOU WERE HERE TO HEAR MISS
THOMAS.
HYDE I DO BELIEVE ME I DO TOO WE
SHOULD I WORK HERE -- AND SO
WITH HER TESTIMONY -- SHE WAS
NOT ON PROBATION.
THESE INDIVIDUALS YOU STUDENTS
ARE BOUGHT THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM TO THEIR PUSH PUSHED
INTO BUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
BEING TREATED LIKE MISS THOMAS
INDICATED -- A PROBATION OFFICER
ON CAMPUS DRESSED IN BLACK WITH
SUNGLASSES REAL QUICK -- CALL
HER BY HER LAST NAME AND SAID
YOU'RE ON MY LIST WHERE SHE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
SHE DID SHE DID NOTHING BUT SHE
WAS TREATED LIKE SHE DID
SOMETHING LIKE SHE BROKE THE LAW
AND THIS IS DRAMATIC FOR THOSE
AND THOSE STUDENTS.
I MEAN HOW I MEAN YOU'RE BEING
TREATED AS IF YOU COMMITTED A
CRIME AND HAS NOT COMMITTED ANY
CRIME WHATSOEVER WOULD YOU BEING
TREATED THAT WAY AND THAT IT
THAT.
WEARS OF THE PSYCHE -- IT
CREATES ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS -- THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
THEM TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AS
YOUNG PEOPLE SO -- YEAH THE THE
OBVIOUSLY THE FELONY TO LOW
SENSITIVITY TRAINING BUT I'M
WONDERING IF THE PROGRAM ITSELF
WHICH YOU YOU SAID IS THERE
THEY'RE FORCED INTO A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM WHICH TO ME.
DEFINITION OF VOLUNTARY -- BUT
DO THESE PROGRAMS AND TWO THEY
HAVE VALUE TO THEM WHEN THEY ARE.
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THIS
DIRE OF THESE YOUTH OR IS THERE
A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS -- THAT
THAT EXISTS BECAUSE THE GOAL IS
TO HELP THESE KIDS I MEAN ONE
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER SO.
ARE A TO TO CITE ONE JERK IF
YOU'LL PARDON MY EXPRESSION DOES
THAT RUIN THE WHOLE CONCEPT.
NO AND LET ME SIMPLY SAY WITH
RESPECT TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE COMMUNITY TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THOSE KIDS WHO HAVE
NOT COMMITTED CRIMES THOSE KEY
IN THOSE KIDS WHO I IN FACT
COULD BE -- CAN IT'S FOR
PROBATION THOSE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WORK WITH SCHOOLS
WORK THE PARENTS AND TRY TO GET
A ROOT AS A MATTER -- TO MAKING
SURE THEY DON'T WIND UP IN THE
JUSTICE AND WE TALKING ABOUT
AGAIN CHILDREN STUDENTS WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO WIND UP IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHATSOEVER AND SO
WITH THIS CONCEPT WITH THIS BILL.
IT CREATES OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BOOTS ON THE
STREETS BOOTS ON THE GROUND TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE SCHOOLS
TO WORK WITH THOSE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THE ACLU OR I THINK
OKAY I'M AND I APPRECIATE THANK
YOU I'M CENTER MORE LIKE SENATOR
JACKSON.
I MEAN SCAR SENATOR MITCHELL
[inaudible]
THE THE CINNAMON.
GIPSON -- JUST A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS WE ARE.
IS A DARI MARTIN OR DARI THOMAS.
SORRY ZARIA DARIA DARIA SORRY.
I'M SORRY I'M MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LAST NAMES I APOLOGIZE.
ZARIF.
MARTIN THOMAS -- MARTIN DASH
THOMAS.
OKAY GREAT THANKS I I DID I JUST
HAD MARK -- I'M CURIOUS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD BE A
PILOT PROGRAM IN A COUNTY THAT
[inaudible]
HAS THE THE A AND THE PROBATION
CHIEF.
WILLING TO TO TRY IT I IT THIS
THIS SEEMS LIKE SUCH A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING.
TO CHANGE THE PARADIGM AND I'M
I'M WONDERING IF IT SHOULD BE
TESTED SOMEWHERE.
IN A IN A COUNTY OR TWO BEFORE
THE ENTIRE.
SYSTEM IS IS IS CHANGE I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF IF THAT WAS SOMETHING
YOU'D CONSIDERED.
SURE LAWS AS THE ALREADY DOES
THIS WORK.
AND SO THEY ALREADY HAVE A THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THIS COMMITTEE SB FOUR THREE
NINE LAST YEAR WAS A PART OF OUR
EQUITY AND JUSTICE PACKAGE --
THAT TALKED ABOUT -- THE CULTURE
IN WHICH WE FIND OURSELVES FOR
WE'RE CONTINUING TO CRIMINALIZE
CHILDREN.
OUR AND TO HEAR THE UNIFORM OF
THE PROBATION OFFICER IN A
PROBATION HAS HAS MORE IN THE
CULTURE PROBATION HAS CHANGED.
MANY PROBATION OFFICES -- NOW --
ALL CAN CARRY WEAPONS AND THAT'S
THAT THAT THAT'S THAT'S A
EVOLUTION OF PROBATION DIDN'T
USED TO BE THAT WAY PROBATION
USED TO BE A VERY DIFFERENT.
KIND OF SYSTEM -- AND SO.
IT IS TRAGIC THAT SOMEONE ON
CAMPUS -- WHO WAS PROFILED ARE
IDENTIFIED BY SOMEONE TO PUT HER
ON A LIST?
WHERE SHE WOULD THEN BE
SUBJECTED TO THE THE NEW POLICE
ORIENTED PROBATION STYLE --
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE I IT RUNS
COUNTER TO THE NOTION OF AS
BEFORE THREE NINE IT SAYS THAT
IT KNOWLEDGE THE CURRENT
RESEARCH THAT SAYS THE YOUNGER
CHILDREN A CHILD IN COUNTY
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THE MORE.
LIKELY THEY WILL STAY IN IT --
AND IT'S MY HOPE WITH THAT
PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION THAT WERE
BEGINNING TO CREATE A CULTURE
SHIFT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND HOW
THEY EXPERIENCE.
THE GOVERNOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO MOVE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE OUT OF
CORRECTIONS INTO.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IS A
NOTHER.
CULTURE SHIFT SIGNAL -- AND SO.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THOSE
THINGS FOR MY COLLEAGUES AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- KIND OF
WHAT IS VERSUS WHAT I TO BE ON
AND THE CULTURE THE DIRECTION WE
ARE HOPING TO GO IN THE STATE.
AND SUPPORTING NOT ONLY JUVENILE
OFFENDERS.
BUT THOSE WHO.
ARE PERHAPS AT RISK ARE THOSE
WHO ARE PERCEIVED BY THE ADULTS
IN THEIR WORLD TO NEED SOME KIND
OF SUPPORT INTERACTION.
AND WE NEED TO CREATE SYSTEMS IN
WHICH THAT SUPPORT COMES FROM
PLACES OTHER THE AND PROBATION
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ON THE FIRST ONE TO ADMIT THAT
THERE IS A ROLE FOR PROBATION
WELL I MEAN I PERSONALLY AGREE
WITH THE DIRECTION THE PROBATION
HAS GONE IN RECENT YEARS.
I GET THAT THERE IS A ROLE FOR
PROBATION BUT THERE'S ALSO A
ROLE FOR SUPPORT OUTSIDE OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE MAY HAVE
BEEN MORE APPROPRIATE -- WITH
THAT I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
CENTER MORE LUCK.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE I'M I'M
GOING THROUGH THE MATERIALS AND
I'M NOT PLANNING ON LA COUNTY IS
I DON'T SEE THEM OPPOSING I
DON'T SEE THEM SUPPORTING.
DO WE HAVE ANY.
RESULTS FOR A STUDY OF HOW IT'S
WORKING AND BUZZ ANGELES COUNTY --
I DO NOT I DON'T KNOW IF -- ACR
NEW ORDERS DAUGHTER JUSTICE
[inaudible]
HAVE ANYTHING.
SERVING SPECIFIC TO THAT
QUESTION.
OFTEN SOMEONE FROM YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION WHO WORKED ON THAT
THAT ISSUE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
[inaudible]
IF.
JUST QUICKLY BECAUSE OF WHAT WE
FOUND IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ON IT WE WORKED WITH THE CHIEF
THERE THERE'S TWO CHIEF THERE
THERE'S A CHIEF IN CHARGE OF
ADULT SERVICES AND A CHIEF IN
CHARGE OF YOU SERVICES WITH A
SHE FOR PROBATION OVER BOTH OF
THEM.
AND WE WORK WITH SHEILA MITCHELL
TO END THE PRACTICE IN LA COUNTY.
AND IN LA COUNTY CHIEF MITCHELL
AND OTHER PROVISIONS SUPERVISORS
OR MANAGERS FELT THAT IT WAS AN
INAPPROPRIATE ROLE FOR PROBATION
TO PLAY.
AND HOW LONG HAS THAT BEEN GOING
ON IT WAS ADDED IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAVE
EVIDENCE ALTHOUGH IT WAS INDEED
ENDED INTO THE IN THE SPRING OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE BECAUSE OF STATE LAW
REQUIRING.
THE CHANGED TO MAKE IT A
PERMANENT CHANGE WE NEED TO GO
TO A LOT OF MAKE A PERMIT CHANGE
NOT ONLY FOR OUR COUNTY.
BUT FOR COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT
WAS GOING ON THERE'S SOME
EVIDENCE THAT IT MAY HAVE BEEN
GOING ON FOR TWENTY YEARS.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS REAL CONCERN FOR LA COUNTY
IN THE REST THE STATE.
IS THAT THERE IS AN CLEAR
SUPERVISION OR OVERSIGHT OR
COMMUNITY KNOWLEDGE OF THESE
PROGRAMS IT WAS ALSO USING JJ
CPA MONEY THAT WAS ATTENDED FOR
COMMUNITY.
BASED PREVENTION SERVICES -- AND
SO IT WAS THROUGH AN AUDIT AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THAT THE
PROGRAM WAS EVEN THE IDENTIFIED
AS EXISTING -- SO NO ONE IS
TOTALLY SURE HOW LONG WAS GOING
ON BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN.
FOR A MORE THAN A DECADE
POSSIBLY AS MANY AS EIGHTEEN OR
TWENTY YEARS IN DIFFERENT FORMS
[inaudible]
HI.
RIGHT RIGHT CHAU TOOK SO MISS
SANCHEZ MAYBE YOU COULD HELP ME
OUT.
LA COUNTY IS 25% OF THE
POPULATION OF THE STATE AND SO
THEY ARE MEMBER OF COURSE OF
YOUR ASSOCIATION.
CAN YOU HELP ME OUT WITH.
WHY WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED IF IT
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN?
WORKING LA COUNTY.
SO SPEAK UP A LITTLE BIT MORE
GLOBALLY STATEWIDE THERE'S
EXTENSIVE PROGRAMS -- STATEWIDE
THAT ARE UNDER KIND OF THAT THAT --
CODE SECTION FIVE PERTAINING TO
THE EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION TYPE PROGRAMS -- I
THINK PART OF THE CHALLENGE OF
WHAT IS NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
BILL IS THE DIFFERENCES AND
COUNTY RESOURCES DYNAMICS THAT
THAT NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
RESOURCE THE SAME WAY AND SO WE
WANT TO OF COURSE MAKE SURE --
THAT PROGRAMS -- PROGRAM
DELIVERIES DESIGNED IN A WAY IN
WHICH AND SOMETIMES IT IS --
PROBATION WORKING IN
COORDINATION ITH -- COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OTHER TIMES
IT'S WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
EDUCATION SOMETIMES IT'S
PROBATION OFFERING THE DRUG
SERVICES A PROVISIONS BEEN
TRAINED EXTENSIVELY IN TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE -- AND MANY OF THE
APPROACHES THAT I THINK WE ALL
TALK ABOUT AND WANT TO SEE
HAPPEN AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THOSE -- THOSE TYPES OF
RECKONING RECOGNITIONS I THINK
ARE BUILT ON INTO THIS BILL AND
SO I AM AS I MENTIONED WE HAD
COME KIND OF TO THE TABLE EARLY
ON AND WORKED WITH THE
SPONSORING THE AUTHOR ON SOME.
CLEAR FINE LANGUAGE AROUND --
PARTICULAR CODE SECTIONS THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE TO THAT WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR OPEN
TO THOSE ADDITIONAL CHANGES --
BECAUSE WE AGAIN I THINK WANNA
WORK WITHIN THE SPIRIT OF THE
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT ON THE
INTERVENTIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
IN THE WAY THAT WE ALL WANT TO
SEE THEM HAPPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY -- WE WILL NOT BE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THAT CAN BILL
HAS TO GO TO EDUCATION AND WE
DID NOT HAVE THE MINUTES TO
RECOMMEND BUT CERTAINLY IF THE
AUTHOR.
IN -- IS.
LOOKING AT ANY THAT IS THE PLACE
TO DO THAT.
I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND
I FEEL THAT -- WELL THERE MAY BE
SOME VERY GOOD PROGRAMS EITHER
WITHIN OUR DI DA OR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS.
IN GENERAL AS OF BOTH THE AUTHOR
AND SENATOR MITCHELL EXPRESSED.
I DON'T THINK THAT.
EITHER PROBATION WERE THE THIS
IS AN THE PROBLEM OF STUDENTS
NOT GOING TO SCHOOL.
IF THEY'VE NOT COMMITTED A CRIME
SHOULD NOT BE DEALT WITH.
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE ARENA.
AND BEGIN WITH APPRECIATION THAT
THERE ARE.
THESE EFFORTS -- AND IF I LOOK
AT FOR EXAMPLE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE KNOW THAT.
THE ISSUES AROUND AS STUDENT
BEING TRUANT OFTEN OCCUR VERY
VERY EARLY THEY KERR FROM
KINDERGARTEN FIRST GRADE.
SO THERE WAS SOME RESEARCH DONE
BECAUSE OAKLAND HAD A VERY HIGH
TRUANCY RATE IN KINDERGARTEN AND
FIRST GRADE.
AND THE CHECKED AND WHAT A
DEFINED -- UST DOES NOT PROVIDE
A SERVICE.
AND THE PARENTS OF THESE
CHILDREN EITHER HAD SUCH WORK
SCHEDULES THAT THEY WERE UNABLE
THEMSELVES TO GET THEIR CHILD'S
SCHOOL.
WHERE THEY HAD -- DISABILITIES
OR OTHER ISSUES AND SO IT WAS
BASICALLY PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO GET.
THEIR STUDENT TO SCHOOL.
AND OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT DIDN'T
PROVIDE ANY RESOURCES TO GET THE
KIDS TO SCHOOL.
SO THESE SOME OF THESE THINGS
ARE REALLY THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS IN A IN OTHER WAYS.
AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING THE BILL --
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE TO GO [inaudible]
TO AND THE WE'LL SEE HOW THE
THINK WE HAVE A MOTION SIR
CORRECT DID YOU MOVE IT SENATOR
MITCHELL.
OKAY GREAT THREE OF MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST --
CONVERSATION ON THIS MATTER --
JUST LET ME SAY TO MISS THOMAS --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I THINK WAS VERY
COMPELLING -- THAT'S REASON WHY
WE HAVE THIS BILL HERE TODAY AND
CONTINUE TO BE -- A VOICE FOR
THE VOICELESS IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA -- THIS IS A BILL THAT I
THINK THAT IT WILL BENEFIT OUR
STUDENTS MOVING FORWARD -- WE
SHOULD NOT BE TRAUMATIZING OUR
YOUTH.
SIMPLE AS THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
TRAUMATIZING YOU AND ALSO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE CAUGHT UP
IN THE SYSTEM IT'S IT'S I THINK.
WHAT YOU SEE TAKING PLACE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE IS ADISPOSITION TO WE WANT RESTORE
OF JUSTICE WE WANT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE -- TO GET IT
RIGHT AND HAVE ALL THE RESOURCE
AND THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IS
THAT VEHICLE THOSE IN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS CAN GO INTO
THEHOME CAN GO INTO COMMUNITY
AND PROVIDE THE KIND OF SUPPORT
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GET ON THE RIGHT TRACK
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
FORTY MOTION IS -- DO YOU PASSED
THE SENATE EDUCATION LET'S TO
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER BY INNER AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE [inaudible]
NO WIENER. FOR THE BILL'S ON
CALL.
SHE ATE THE ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY -- WE WILL NOW GO TO
ITEMS CAN AB.
NINE OH SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
APOLOGIES OTHER MEMBERS THAT
HAVE BEEN WAITING WE DO FILE
ORDER IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON DID ARRIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON IF YOU
COULD COME UP.
THANK YOU.
KEEP THIS MOVING [inaudible]
EXCELLENT [inaudible]
PERCY.
THANK YOU AND I DO HAVE MY
WITNESSES COMING UP.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR TIME AND ATTENTION ON THE
BILL.
AB NINE ZERO SEVEN SIX TO ADD
CLARITY TO THE LAW REGARDING
CRIMINAL THREATS.
WHITE SUPREME IS PROPAGANDA.
AND SCHOOL SHOOTING INCIDENTS
HAVE REACHED AN ALL TIME HIGH IN
OUR COUNTRY.
AND MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY FEEL
MORE FREER THAN EVER BEFORE.
OUR NEWSPAPERS AND NEWS FEEDS
ARE FILLED WITH TERRIBLE
HEADLINES OF CRIMES BEING
COMMITTED AGAINST TARGETED
GROUPS OF PEOPLE.
OVER FIFTY MUSLIMS MURDERED IN A
MOSQUE IN NEW ZEALAND. ELEVEN
JEWISH WORSHIPPERS MURDERED IN A
SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH
PENNSYLVANIA.
A PREDOMINANTLY BLACK CHURCH IN
KENTUCKY TARA IN KENTUCKY
TARGETED BY A GUNMAN SCHOOL
CHILDREN MURDERED AT SANDY HOOK
AND AT PARKLAND JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
IN CASES WHEN AN ENTIRE SCHOOL
OR PLACE OF WORSHIP IS
THREATENED IT'S CLEARLY
UNDERSTOOD TO BE THAT THE PEOPLE
ARE IN DANGER AND NOT THE
PROPERTY IN DANGER.
BUT THE LAW IS LESS CLEAR WHEN A
STUDENT SEES A POST ON SOCIAL
MEDIA THAT ANOTHER STUDENT WANTS
TO KILL AT LEAST THIRTY STUDENTS
ON THE LAST DAY OF SCHOOL THE
FEAR THEY FEEL IS VERY REAL.
THE EXAMPLE IS A REAL ONE THAT
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT AND
PLEASANTVILLE.
DESPITE THAT COMMUNICATED
THREATS INTERVENTION BY THE FBI
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
MULTIPLE GUNS BEING SEIZED FROM
THE STUDENTS HOME AND MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUALS AFRAID FOR THEIR
SAFETY.
PROSECUTORS WERE STILL UNABLE TO
PURSUE A CRIMINAL THREAT CHARGE
BECAUSE OF HOW THE LAW IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
AFTER A THREAT WAS MADE AGAINST
THE SCHOOL IN THE JOHNS WHAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT
THAT WAS A MASSIVE ATTENDANCE
FLUCTUATION.
DAILY ATTENDANCE WAS REDUCED
FROM FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TWO
STUDENTS TO ONLY SEVENTY AND
REMAIN LOW FOR TWO OR THREE DAYS
FOLLOWING THE THREAT.
DRASTICALLY IMPACTING THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT THE SCHOOL
RECEIVED VIA E..
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT THESE THREATS
ARE HURTING STUDENTS HURTING
SCHOOLS AND HURTING OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THERE SHOULD BE
UNIFORM AGREEMENT ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THOSE WHO PURPOSEFULLY.
BECAUSE FEAR IN OUR COMMUNITIES
CURRENT STATUTE FAILS TO
ENCOMPASS WELL WE WERE ALL
CONSIDERED TO BE A CRIME DUE TO
THE LAWS AND BIG AMBIGUITY.
THE INTENT IS TO ENSURE ALL
THREATS ARE TREATED WITH THE
GRAVITY THEY DEMAND MY WITNESS
IS LARRY MORSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION.
GO AHEAD MISTER MOORE'S THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
BLURRY MORE SOMEBODY HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO BE
A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
AS WE ALL KNOW FAR TOO WELL IN
RECENT YEARS ARE RISK POOLS AND
PLACES OF WORSHIP.
HAVE BECOME THE SCENES OF
HORRIFIC ACTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
OFTEN INVOLVING SUBSTANTIAL LOSS
OF LIFE AND INJURIES.
NOT SURPRISINGLY WE HAVE ALSO
SEEN A CORRESPONDING AND
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF THREATS OF SUCH ACTS OF
VIOLENCE OFTEN THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WHEN A THREAT IS MADE TO COMMIT
MASS MURDER AT A SCHOOL OR HOUSE
OF WORSHIP?
IT OFTEN CREATES PURE
PANDEMONIUM BECAUSE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED SO MANY OF THESE
TRAGIC SHOOTINGS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IN CHURCHES SYNAGOGUES
AND MOSQUES THERE IS A
HEIGHTENED ANXIETY WHEN EVER
SUCH A NEW THREAT IS MADE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHICH NOW MAKES
ACTIVE SHOOTER SCENARIOS ON
<c.green>AMPUSES A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF</c>
THEIR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TRAINING FOR OFFICERS IS CALLED
INTO IMMEDIATE ACTION.
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ARE FORCED
TO CLOSE CAMPUSES AND ISSUE
ALERTS.
TERROR STRICKEN PARENTS GRIPPED
WITH FEAR JUMP IN THEIR CARS AND
SPEED OVER TO THEIR CHILDREN'S
SCHOOLS PRAYING THAT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN PLACES LIKE PARKLAND
FLORIDA.
AND ELSEWHERE IS NOT HAPPENING
NOW AT THEIR CHILD'S SCHOOL.
UNDER EXISTING LAW SUCH THREATS
TO COMMIT ACTS OF VIOLENCE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE PLACES OF WORSHIP.
HAVE BEEN SHOEHORNED INTO PENAL
CODE SECTION.
FOUR TWENTY TWO WHILE THE
ANALYSIS NOTES THAT SOME CASES
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
PROSECUTED UNDER -- PENAL CODE
SECTION FOUR TWENTY TWO THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE CITING APPELLATE
DECISIONS.
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS SOME
AMBIGUITY IN THE APPLICATION OF
PC FOR TWENTY TWO TO THESE CASES.
THE AMBIGUITY STEMS FROM SECTION
HE A PENAL CODE FOR TWENTY TWO
WHICH SAYS QUOTE.
BUT THE THREAT ACTUALLY BECAUSE
THE PERSON THREATEN TO BE IN
SUSTAIN FEAR FOR HIS OR HER OWN
SAFETY OR FOR HIS OR HER
IMMEDIATE FAMILY SAFETY.
IN MOST INSTANCES OF FOUR TWENTY
TWO PROSECUTION FLOWS FROM A
PERSON DIRECTLY CALLING ANOTHER.
ON THE PHONE FOR EXAMPLE AND
THREATENING TO COME OVER AND
SHOOT THEM.
SUCH A THREAT MAY VERY WELL CALL
BECAUSE THAT PERSON WHO RECEIVED
THE CALL TO BE IN SUSTAIN FEAR
OF HIS OR HER OWN SAFETY.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT LANGUAGE
IN THE CONTEXT OF THREATS TO
SCHOOL CAMPUSES OR HOUSES OF
WORSHIP IS THAT OF SOMEONE POST
ONLINE OR COMMUNICATES TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
THAT THEY'RE PLANNING TO COMMIT
MASS MURDER AT A SCHOOL OR HOUSE
OF WORSHIP.
THE PERSON THAT RECEIVES THAT
COMMUNICATION MAY NOT BE IN
SUSTAIN FEAR FOR HIS LIFE.
OR THE LIVES OF FAMILY MEMBERS
IN MOST SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENTS AT LEAST ONE OTHER
PERSON WAS AWARE OF THE SHOOTERS
PLANTS ALTHOUGH THAT PERSON MAY
NOT.
AND LIKELY WAS NOT INTENDED AS A
TARGET OF THE THREAT.
SUCH VAGUE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
STATUTORY CONSTRUCTION.
IS IN ADEQUATE TO THE GRAVITY OF
THE KINDS OF THREATS AB NINE OH
SEVEN ADDRESSES OR LAW SHOULD BE
QUICK CLEAR AND UNEQUIVOCAL IN
SPECIFYING WHAT CONDUCT IS A
LEGAL NOT DRAFTED SO AN ARTFULLY
THAT THEY ARE RELIANT ON THE
INTERPRETATION.
OF APPELLATE COURTS.
AB NINE OH SEVEN WOULD END THE
AB ACUITY OF WHETHER PC SECTION
FOR TWENTY TWO IS LEGALLY
SUFFICIENT TO CHARGE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE THESE
RECKLESS IRRESPONSIBLE LIFE
ENDANGERING THREATS.
THAT STATES WITH CLARITY THE
ELEMENTS NECESSARY TO CHARGE THE
CRIME OF THREATENING A SCHOOL OR
PLACE OF WORSHIP.
IT ALSO GIVES PROSECUTORS THE
ABILITY TO EVALUATE THE
SERIOUSNESS AN ATTENDANT
CIRCUMSTANCES OF SUCH A THREAT
AND DECIDE WHETHER THIS CONDUCT
AMOUNTED TO A MISDEMEANOR OR A
FELONY.
AB NINE OH SEVEN IS A REFLECTION
OF THE SAD REALITY OF THE TIMES
IN WHICH WE LIVE.
A TIME IN WHICH OUR SCHOOLS AND
HOUSES OF WORSHIP ONE
SANCTUARIES OF SAFETY AND
SECURITY ARE NOW POTENTIAL
KILLING FIELDS.
WE NEED THE UNEQUIVOCAL CLARITY
THAT AB NINE OF SEVEN OFFERS TO
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT WHILE WE
CHERISH AND FIGHT FOR STREET
FREE SPEECH THOSE WHO STRIKE
TERROR INTO INNOCENT PEOPLE BY
CONVEYING THREATS OF VIOLENCE TO
OUR CHILDREN AND THOSE WHO
WORSHIP.
WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN
CLEAR AND UNMISTAKABLE LANGUAGE
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVAL --
LET'S HEAR FROM THE NEXT WITNESS
AT THE TABLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CLIFFORD
HERE IN BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE J. PACK
IN SUPPORT.
OF AB NINE OH SEVEN
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE SEEN IN A
RECORD HIGH AA OF SCHOOL THAN
VIOLENCE INCIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE SEEN.
A SURGE OF ANTI SEMITIC.
ACTS ON CAMPUSES IN A PLACES OF
WORSHIP WE HAVE SEEN A SURGE A
WHITE SUPREMACIST PROPAGANDA --
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND ON THE
INTERNET -- VIOLENCE AGAINST
PLACES OF WORSHIP AND SCHOOLS OF
GRABBED NATIONAL HEADLINES WE'VE
SEEN RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
SAN DIEGO -- FAIRLY RECENTLY
IT'S ANOTHER TRAGIC EXAMPLE --
THIS BILL IS NEEDED AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CARING IT THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE MIKE.
MAURITANIAN BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
SO OFTEN IN SUPPORT.
CORY SOCIAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS OKAY LET'S
SEE FROM OUR WITNESSES OR HEAR
FROM OUR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AND I THINK THERE'S ROOM AT THE
TABLE WE DON'T HAVE TO MOVE
ANYONE YET [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA -- WHAT WE OF
COURSE SHARE THE GOAL OF
STOPPING THREATS TO SCHOOLS AND
HOUSES OF WORSHIP UNFORTUNATELY
AB NINE OH SEVEN WILL DO NOTHING
TO LESSEN THE NUMBER OF THOSE
THREATS?
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS OF AND
AS DISCUSSED -- IN THE TESTIMONY
THE THREATS COVERED UNDER THIS
BILL CAN ALREADY BE PROSECUTED
UNDER EXISTING LAW WE WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE D. A.'S THAT -- UNTIL
IT DECISION IN IN THEIR FAVOR
SHOWS THE NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
ACTION AYE I THINK THAT THE
COURTS HAVE SPOKEN AND AND IT'S
CLEAR HOW THE LAW APPLIES AND
AND THERE'S NO NEED FOR THIS
BILL -- AT ANY RATE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SO OVERCOME BY ANGER THAT
THEY MAKE THESE KINDS OF THREATS
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE
CONSEQUENCES WILL NOT STOP
BECAUSE THE BILL HAS BEEN PASSED.
BY EIGHTY NINE OH SEVEN IS
UNNECESSARY AND WE CHERNOBYL.
THERE ARE TWO OF US WE HAVE TO
GO DOWN VOTE IN ENERGY.
SO APOLOGIES ARE WOULD CONTINUE
THE TESTIMONY BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE ONE COMMENT.
THAT -- AND MAYBE WE CAN --
PAUSE JUST BRIEFLY WHY WE GO
VOTE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
MOTIVATION FOR THE BILL.
AND I WONDERED IF WE WOULDN'T
CONSIDER.
BECAUSE IT RIGHT NOW THIS WOULD
MAKE IT A WAFFLER -- SO THERE'S
DISCRETION WHICH IS GREAT BUT I
WONDER IF WE MIGHT CONSIDER
HAVING FOR MINORS BE A
MISDEMEANOR.
AND I WOULD EXPLAIN MY LOGIC --
LATER BUT I NEED TO RUN DOWN AND
VOTE.
AND WE COULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION.
PROCEED OKAY THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE DO LIVE IN
EXTREMELY PAINFUL TIMES WITH
WHITE SUPREMACISTS ATTACKING
CHURCHES AND SYNAGOGUES AND
MOSQUES.
AND ANGRY OFTEN MENTALLY ILL
YOUNG PEOPLE.
SHOOTING IN SCHOOLS.
AS THE MOTHER OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHILDREN THE SPOUSE OF
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN AS WELL
AS A PERSON OF DEEP FAITH.
AND THE DEEPLY CONCERNED CITIZEN
I FEEL THE DESPERATE DESIRE TO
DO SOMETHING TO STOP THIS
HORRIBLE ATTACKS.
WE ALL WANT TO DO SOMETHING TO
STOP THIS HORRIBLE ATTACKS
HOWEVER AB NINE OH SEVEN IS NOT
THE SOLUTION.
AB NINE OH SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
CRIMINAL THREATS AND CREATE A
NEW CRIME OF CRIMINAL THREATS IN
THE CONTEXT OF A SCHOOL A PLACE
OF RELIGIOUS WORSHIP.
THE CURRENT STATUTE REGARDING
CRIMINAL THREATS IS ONE OF GREAT
CONCERN FOR PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AS A FELONY IT IS A SERIOUS
FELONY AND IS IS A STRIKE AS IN
THREE STRIKES.
THE CURRENT STATUTE IS OFTEN
MISUSED TO PENALIZE CONDUCT THAT
DOES NOT TRULY BELONG IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
OUR CLIENTS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS WHO OFTEN SUFFER FROM
CRIPPLING PARANOIA AND DELUSIONS.
THE FEAR THESE CLIENTS
EXPERIENCE CAN LEAD THEM TO SAY
THINGS THAT ARE EASILY
MISINTERPRETED OR SIMPLY A
PRODUCT OF THEIR ILLNESS.
WE HAVE A A DEEP THIS
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND BELIEVE THAT WHAT.
THE AUTHOR SEEKS -- TO DO IS
ALREADY COVERED BY THE CURRENT
LAW AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS
TESTIFID.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
ROGER IS A MARINE CORPS VET AND
SUFFERS FROM PTSD AND BIPOLAR
DEPRESSION WITHOUT HIS MEDS HE
LIVES IN FLORIDA BUT WAS HERE
FOR A MARINE CORPS REUNION.
HE DIDN'T BRING ENOUGH MEDS AND
AS A RESULT OF AN EPISODE OF
HEARING VOICES AND SMELLING DEAD
BODIES THAT REQUIRED HIM TO BE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT AND
HOSPITALIZED.
HOWEVER THE DOCTOR TOLD HIM THAT
IS SYMPTOMS DIDN'T MEET THE
CRITERIA AND THAT HE WOULD NOT
BE ADMITTED.
AND HE WOULD NOT BE GIVEN
MEDICATION.
THE VETERAN COMPLAIN TO THE
DISCHARGE PLANNER AND ASKED HER
WHAT THE CRITERIA WAS AND SHE
TOLD HIM A DANGER TO HIMSELF OR
OTHERS.
HE TOLD HER HE WAS THINKING
ABOUT GETTING A GUN AND SHOOTING
HIMSELF OR THE STAFF.
HE WAS.
THEN CHARGED WITH A FELONY FOR
TWENTY TWO CRIMINAL THREATS.
BRIAN WAS IN HIS FIFTIES AND
MENTALLY ILL HE WAS OFF HIS
MEDICATION AND TOLD A FRIEND HE
WAS GOING TO BLOW THE BUILDING
UP.
HIS FRIEND CALLED THE DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH ASKING FOR HELP
WAS TRANSFERRED TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE POLICE ARRIVED
AND PROMPTLY ARRESTED HIM FOR A
FELONY.
FOR TWENTY TWO WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED IN EARLIER TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE TERROR OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS DRIVING TO THE SCHOOLS
OR THE PLACES OF WORSHIP -- IS
VERY MOVING HOWEVER THAT IS
COVERED IN SUBSECTION EAT AGAIN
I STATE THAT THE LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS FOR THESE PROSECUTIONS.
FURTHER EXPANDING THIS ALREADY
EXPANSIVE DOVE DEFINITION WILL
WE FAIR ONLY IN SNARE EVEN MORE
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE ARE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS BILL BUT
EXPANSION OF PENAL CODE SECTION
FOR TWENTY TWO IS NOT THE ANSWER
AND IT WILL END UP CREATING MORE
HARM.
THAN IT PROPOSES TO PREVENT.
WE HAVE A BIRD IN THE OTHER FOR
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS. THIRTY
JACKSON YES A MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE BILL'S STILL ALLOWS
FOR THIS TO BE A WAFFLER.
SO THAT DEPENDING UPON THE
SEVERITY OF THE BEHAVIOR.
THE COURT WILL HAVE THE RIGHT.
TO ADJUSTED EITHER IS A FELONY
OR MISDEMEANOR IS THAT CORRECT
THAT IS -- THAT IS CORRECT AND
BEFORE A CHAIR SKINNER -- LEFT
SHE HAD MENTIONED SOMETHING
ABOUT -- MISDEMEANOR FOR MINORS
RIGHT AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE VERY MUCH -- WILLING TO
ACCOMMODATE [inaudible]
YEAH I'M.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT -- YOU KNOW
THIS BEHAVIORS ARE ALWAYS
LEARNED.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT
SOME OF THE ACTS THAT ARE
COMMITTED HAVE SUCH SIGNIFICANCE
TO THE VICTIMS WHO ARE THE
RECIPIENTS OF THAT BEHAVIOR.
WHETHER IT'S IN HIGH SCHOOL
THINKING MINORS IN HIGH SCHOOL --
HI I DO LIKE THE IDEA OF GIVING
THE THE COURT DISCRETION BUT
CERTAINLY.
I THINK THE BILL IS.
THE AS CONCEIVED THE ISSUE HERE
IS AN IMPORTANT ONE AND SO I
I'LL MOVE THE BILL -- AND IF YOU
IF YOU CONSIDER -- THE OPTION OF
REDUCING IT TO A MISDEMEANOR --
CERTAINLY.
THAT'S THAT SEEMS FINE BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT SOME OF THIS
BEHAVIOR JUST REALLY -- KNOCKS
YOUNGSTERS OFF THEIR PENS A FEW
WILL HAVING BEEN THE RECIPIENT
OF ACTS OF ANTI SEMITISM AS A
CHILD IN MY OWN SCHOOL AND SOME
OF YOU KNOW.
SCHOOLS AND AND PLAYGROUNDS AND
ALL.
I CAN STILL REMEMBER THOSE
EVENTS AND THEY HAPPENED A LONG
TIME AGO.
SO I I I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
TREAT THIS CAVALIERLY -- I DO
THINK SOME OF THIS BEHAVIOR
SADLY IS MALICIOUS MEAN SPIRITED
AND INTENTIONAL.
SO I THINK -- GIVING GIVEN THE
COURTS SAID DISCRETION IS IS
STILL A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
SENATOR JACKSON EGISTO ONCE
AGAIN TO REITERATE -- THAT AS
SENATOR CHAIR AND CHAIR SKINNER
HAD MENTIONED ABOUT -- REDUCING
IT FOR MINORS TO MISDEMEANOR
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
THIS BOTH THE SPONSOR AND I I AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL WOULD BE
WILLING TO ACCOMMODATE.
AS WE MOVE THIS BILL IF THIS
BILL WAS TO MOVE FORWARD.
RIGHT APOLOGIES FOR MY HAVING TO
RUN OUT.
AND APOLOGIES -- FOR NOT HAVING --
I DON'T LIKE TO SURPRISE AUTHORS
WITHIN TEN MINUTES -- SO I WANT
TO EXPRESS MY APOLOGIES FOR THAT
BUT IN.
IN.
LISTEN TESTIMONY IN RE READING
IT THIS MORNING.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THE THE HORRIBLE
RISE IN THESE [inaudible]
IN.
THESE TYPE OF THREATS AND DAD TO
WOOD THE DATA WOULD SHOW.
THAT IT'S REALLY INCREASE SINCE
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION --
AND THE AMOUNT OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND OTHER SOURCES THAT CAN
INFLAME OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. TO DO
STUPID THINGS.
IN TWO AS OUR AS MISTER MORRIS
FROM THE DA ASSOCIATION DESCRIBE
THE THE THE D. REALLY ON THE
STRESS THE DESTRUCTION.
THE REALLY HORRENDOUS A FAX OF
THESE THREATS EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT MADE GOOD ON AND YET.
WHEN IT'S IMMATURE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN EFFECT BEING MANIPULATED?
BY THIS -- BY WHAT'S PRESENT NOW
SO MUCH MORE DOMINANT IN EVEN BY
LEADERS OF OUR COUNTRY.
IT S. SEEM TO ME THAT -- WHILE
WE WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO STOP IT.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO BE
IN A SITUATION OF CREATING A
FELONY FOR A MINOR -- CERTAINLY
ANYONE WHO'S AN ADULT WHO.
BEHAVES THIS WAY IT SEEMS THE
WAFFLER AS AND WHEN I REFLECTED
ON IT WAS VERY APPROPRIATE -- SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS AND AGAIN MY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT -- HAVING.
BEEN ABLE TO DISCUSS IN ADVANCE
BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT MY ON FEELINGS
ABOUT IT REALLY GOT CEMENTED
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE BENEFITS
OF OUR HEARINGS ACTUALLY.
SO ON THE SAME TIME I APOLOGIZE
I ALSO THINK IT'S ALWAYS
APPROPRIATE FOR ALL OF US TO
RESERVE THE RIGHT. TO BE ABLE TO
IN THESE HEARINGS IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS -- SO. FIVE WITH
YOUR WILLINGNESS WE WILL --
AMENDED IN I THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE WILL
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE WORDING IS.
SATISFACTORY.
ON INDUCTION WAITING ACT CLEAR
FIVE CORRECT STAFF OKAY.
SO IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTERS
QUESTION.
YES YES YES.
PLEASE TAKE IN IT YES SO IS
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTION OR DO
WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION I THINK
WE DO SENATOR JACKSON I THINK
MATED SAT CORRECT RIGHT SO WE
HAVE MOTION AS AMENDED
[inaudible]
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
OUT OF JAIL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR INSIGHT AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL DO ROLL CALL.
ASSIST TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
BY YOUR AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON FIVE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
AYE MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
RIGHT THE BILL IS ON CALL AND I
BELIEVE THAT WAS YOUR LAST ONE
TODAY -- THE CASE SO.
WE WILL NOW GO TO MISUSE IN THE
ROOM I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY WOULD BE NEXT.
AND THEN AS YOU COME UP TO THE
DíAS I WANT ANNOUNCED THAT --
WE WILL STOP AT ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE DUE -- TO CAUCUS.
WE DO HAVE A ROOM FOR IF THE WE
ARE NOT COMPLETED OUR BILLS WE
THREE ONE NINE ONE THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO RETURN TO OF COURSE I
WILL MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
AGAIN AT THE POINT THAT WE
RCESSED.
BUT I WANTED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
NOW.
DONE JUST IN CASE.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO WITH ITEM
FOURTEEN AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE HE'S CLEARLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M I'M
HERE TO PRESENT THE FIRST BILL
AB.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE F. MEASURE
RELATED TO SHERIFF OVERSIGHT
BOARDS -- THIS NOTE FROM THE GET
GO AND THERE'S SOME CONFUSION
HERE THIS DOESN'T MANDATE THESE
ENTITIES ARE STILL VOLUNTARY.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT JUST
CLARIFIES -- THEIR EXISTENCE AND
AVAILABILITY AND FRANKLY
CODIFIES A PRIOR COURT DECISION
LATEST SOME CONFUSION OVER THESE
ENTITIES -- THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN THE SHERIFF IS UNIQUE THEY'RE
BOTH INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CHANGE THAT
OTHER IS -- OVERSIGHT IN CERTAIN
COUNTIES BUT THERE IT IS A LOT
OF CONFUSION OVER THEIR
FUNCTIONS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE KNOW THAT
CITY POLICE DEPARTMENTS HAVE LAW
IN CITIES HAVE LONG ESTABLISHED
OVERSIGHT BODIES.
FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CREATE POSITIVE CHANGE IN CITIES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO LA IN
SACRAMENTO.
THIS CANNOT ALWAYS BE THE SAME
FOR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE HAD A WELL
PUBLICIZED CONFLICT BETWEEN OUR
SHARE.
AND OVERSIGHT ENTITY WERE
LITERALLY ARE SERRA LOCK THE
DOORS AND DIDN'T ALLOW THE
INDEPENDENT -- INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO TO DO HIS JOB ANYMORE.
WE'VE SEEN A FURTHER CONFUSION
IN LOS ANGELES AND BAY AREA AND
IT ALL GOES BACK TO THE
UNDERLYING.
STRUCTURE THESE AND CONFUSION AS
FAR AS THEIR EXISTENCE AND
WHETHER OR NOT.
THE COUNTY COUNCIL'S TRULY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO AND CALIFORNIA THIS IS
A BIG ISSUE BECAUSE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ARE MANY TIMES THE
LOCAL POLICE.
I HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN IN LA
COUNTY MANY TIMES THE SHERIFF IS
ESSENTIALLY THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
WE KNOW THAT IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES RECALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE HAD TOO MUCH
DISTRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
A TRANSPARENCY WITH OVERSIGHT IS
A GOOD THING A SUNSHINE IS A
GOOD THING AND THE BEST
DISINFECTANT.
AND THIS BILL WILL HELP --
FURTHER THAT GOAL AND SIMPLY
CLARIFIED THAT SURE OVERSIGHT
BOARDS I HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DO THEIR WORK -- AND CAN BE
ROBUST NGUYEN ISSUED BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR BY THE
PEOPLE OF THAT COUNTY.
AND CLARIFY THE CAN DO THINGS
LIKE ISSUING SUBPOENAS AND
GATHER INFORMATION TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT OF
LOCAL SHERIFF DEPARTMENTS.
WITH ME TODAY ARE LOCAL LAW
PROFESSOR FROM LOYAL SCHOOL OF
LAW.
AND DAY -- PUBLIC DEFENDER FROM
SOLANO COUNTY WITH THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION.
SB RIVAL THANK YOUTHANK YOU
LET'S HAVE OUR WITNESSES IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS FOR SILOED CHANNEL
I'M A PROFESSOR PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES.
AND MOST PERTINENT FOR THIS
DISCUSSION I'M THE VICE CHAIR.
OF THE LOS ANGELES SHARE
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT I'M
HERE IN MY INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY
TO DISCUSS WHY IT IS SO VITAL TO
ENSURE THE COUNTIES CAN ONE
ESTABLISH.
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT COMMISSIONS
AND TO VEST THOSE BODIES WITH
THE POWER TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS
WHEN THE NEED ARISES.
THESE TWO PROVISIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO INSURING TRANSFERRED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
TWO SHARES WHO ARE ELECTED ONCE
EVERY FOUR YEARS OFTEN IN VERY
LOW TURNOUT ELECTIONS IN THERE
FOR OPERATE DAY TODAY -- WITH
VERY LITTLE OVERSIGHT FROM THE
PUBLIC WHICH HAS PRODUCED A
OFTEN A CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
RESULTS IN TERMS OF PUBLIC TRUST
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHICH IS
HOME TO ONE OF THE LARGEST
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS IN THE
COUNTRY ARE CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
BODY HAS STEPPED IN TO FILL AN
IMPORTANT THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF
BRIDGE BUILDING BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
COMMUNITY COME A COMMUNITY
MEMBERS COME TO US WITH
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS WE FOLLOW
UP WE INVESTIGATE WE ASK
QUESTIONS ON THEIR BEHALF WE
ALSO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS.
ARE COMMISSION TAKES ON PRESSING
MATTERS OF PUBLIC CONCERN
INVOLVING THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AS IT RELATES TO
DEPUTY DISCIPLINE OF COOPERATION
WITH FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES.
A SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES OF
VICTIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PRISON RAPE
ELIMINATION ACT JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
WHILE WE OFTEN WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AT TIMES OUR WORK IS
BEEN IMPEDED BY REFUSAL TO
PROVIDE TIMELY AND COMPLETE
INFORMATION OR TO MAKE SURE THAT
RELEVANT DECISION MAKERS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMISSION. FOR EXAMPLE FOR
MONTHS THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
REFUSED TO PROVIDE THE
COMMISSION WITH INFORMATION
ABOUT THE OPERATION OF DEPUTY
GANGS OR CLIQUES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT -- AND EFFORTS TO
ROOT THEM OUT.
WHEN WE WERE REVISING RECOMMEND
IT WOULD DEVISING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMMIGRATION
IN OUR COUNTY JAILS THIS YEAR'S
DEPARTMENT REFUSED TO PROVIDE US
WITH A LIST OF RECENTLY REVISED
QUALIFYING MISDEMEANORS THAT
COULD RESULT IN?
AN ICE DETAINER.
JUST RECENTLY THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL LEARNED OF A
TROUBLING PATTERN OF THE
ACTIVATIONS OF DISCIPLINE
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
ALLEGATIONS AS SERIOUS AS AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THIS YEAR'S DEPARTMENT HAS YET
TO PROVIDE A FULL EXPLANATION OF
THE BASIS FOR THESE THE
ACTIVATIONS OR THE POLICY THAT
UNDER UNDERLIES THESE ACTIONS.
I COULD GO ON BUT I WAS TOLD I
ONLY HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT EACH OF
THESE INSTANCES SUBPOENA POWER
WOULD HAVE HELPED OUR COMMISSION
TO ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER WHICH INCREASES PUBLIC
TRUST IN PUBLIC SAFETY. TO BE
CLEAR I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
SUBPOENA POWER IS A PANACEA I
BELIEVE THAT MOST COMMISSIONS
WOULD USE IT SPARINGLY AND ONLY
WHEN NECESSARY.
HOWEVER IT'S AVAILABILITY WILL
ENCOURAGE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
WITH OVERSIGHT PANEL TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION TOOK CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT BODIES WHICH IS OF
BENEFIT TO EVERYONE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB --
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU IN
BEFORE YOU TAKE THE NEXT WITNESS.
THE COMMITTEE OF COURSE
APPRECIATES BREVITY BUT I DO NOT
HAVE A TWO MINUTE RULE -- BUT WE
DO APPRECIATE BREVITY GO AHEAD
NEXT WITNESS AND WE HAVE A
MOTION.
LESLIE CALDWELL -- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION TO SUPPORT READ THIS
BILL -- HI.
I AM GOING TO SPEAK A LITTLE
MORE BROAD STROKES THAN MY
COLLEAGUE -- BUT I HAVE SIMILAR
COMMENTS TO MAKE.
IF THE ARGUMENT FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
AND I WILL START WITH THIS IS
THAT THE COUNTY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS ALREADY HAVE THE
POWER TO CREATE THESE.
I'M SORRY.
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES
THEN THERE'S NO REASON FOR THEM
TO OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION.
AS WE KNOW REGARDING -- THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST SOME ARE GOOD
AND SOME ARE NOT.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY THE
COMMUNITY MUST BE ALLOWED TO
POLICE THE POLICE.
THE ONLY WAY A DEPUTY OR POLICE
OFFICER COMPLACENT AREA AND KEEP
THE CITIZENS SAFE IS IF THE
COMMUNITY LETS THEM [inaudible]
TRUSTS THEM.
AND PERHAPS EVEN WORKS WITH THEM.
WE'RE IN A NEW TIME WHERE THE
WORD OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NO
LONGER TAKEN AS GOSPEL BY THE
PUBLIC.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR ACCESS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
THIS BILL JUST IT JUST GIVES THE
POWER TO CREATE CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES NOT A
DIRECTIVE.
AND AS WE KNOW FROM OTHER ISSUES
EVERY COUNTY WILL SET UP
SOMETHING SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
FROM OTHER COUNTIES THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT AS TO HOW THE
COMMITTEE IS TO WORK.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT IN THE AREAS
WHERE THERE IS CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT THE SKY HAS NOT FALLEN.
IN FACT IN SAN FRANCISCO THE
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THE
SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN ASKED BY THE
SHERIFF TO TAKE OVER CERTAIN
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC.
INTERNAL AFFAIRS INVESTIGATIONS.
IF A COMMITTEE CAN LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT PLACES THAT THINGS CAN
GO WRONG IN THE FIELD IN THE
JAIL.
IN TRANSPORT.
THEN THIS COULD ACTUALLY REDUCE
LIABILITY FOR COUNTY GOVERNMENTS.
THERE ARE JAILS IN THE STATE
THAT HAVE DEPLORABLE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH CONDITIONS SOME
OF HAD TO BE SUED AND EVEN THEN
A THIRTIES DRAG THEIR FEET IN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES.
A COMMITTEE COULD PERHAPS LOOK
INTO THESE PROBLEMS AND SUGGEST
CORRECTIONS WHICH WOULD THEN
AVOID EXTREMELY COSTLY
LITIGATION.
WE BELIEVE THE KEY TO THE
OBJECTIONS BY THE OPPOSITION IS
ACTUALLY THE POWER OF SUBPOENA.
I UST NOTE THAT STILL MOST
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED OF TESTING
FOR TESTIFYING AGAINST THE
POLICE OR DEPUTY SHERIFF'S.
I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH
AN EXAMPLE OF WHY IT IS CRITICAL
THAT THE CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES ALSO HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER.
A YOUNG MAN WAS STOPPED BY AN
OFFICER AND SEARCHED ON HIM WAS
FOUND A GLASS PIPE.
MATH PIPE CRACK PIPE SORT OF
GLASS PIPE THE OFFICER TOOK THE
PIPE SMASHED IT ON THE GROUND
PICKED UP THE GLASS AND GROUND
IT INTO THIS YOUNG MAN'S FACE.
SOME HOW THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
GOT WORD OF THE COMPLAINT BUT
THIS YOUNG MAN WAS TERRIFIED TO
COME IN HE WAS NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THIS PERSON WHO
HAD DONE THIS TO HIM THIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
HOWEVER ALONG WITH THE POWER OF
SUBPOENA THAT THAT PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE HAD FORTUNATELY IN
SOME JOURNAL PROMISES A
PROTECTION AS THE YOUNG MAN CAME
AND WENT FROM THE HEARING.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WAS
IN FACT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THIS ACTION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST AT THE MIKE.
CAT CARRILLO SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE SEAL YOU IN SUPPORT OF
THIS NEEDED BILL.
RESIDENTS HALLS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHERS.
OKAY WE CAN NEVER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU WANT TO COME
TO THE TABLE I THINK THERE'S
ROOM SO I DON'T THINK I NEED TO
MOVE ANYONE.
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS COREY
CELLS ALONG BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- AS WAS ALLUDED TO BY
PRIOR SPEAKERS -- COUNTIES HAVE
ALREADY CREATED DIFFERENT MODELS
OF CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT.
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR SPECIFIC
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORIZATION.
IN THAT REGARD WE BELIEVE THE
BILL IS UNNECESSARY.
THERE'S ANY QUESTION OR
CONFUSION OR CLARITY ABOUT --
SUBPOENA POWER -- IT'S CURRENTLY
HELD BY SOME OF THESE OVERSIGHT
BODIES -- THERE IS CASE LAW THAT
INDICATES CERTAINLY IN CHARTER
LAW COUNTIES AS YOUR ANALYSIS --
VERY LOCALLY POINTS OUT THAT
THIS IS -- HAS BEEN GRANTED IN%
MAY BE GRANTED WITHOUT THAT
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY.
ADDITIONALLY THE COUNTY COUNCIL
AS WELL AS THE CIVIL GRAND JURY
HAS SUBPOENA POWER IF THERE IS
SOME QUESTION ABOUT A DOCUMENT
OR PERSON -- BEING COMPELLED TO
TESTIFY OR DOCUMENT THAT IS
SOUGHT -- WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT --
INFORMATION IS BEING SOUGHT THAT
ISN'T BEING DELIVERED AT THIS
POINT -- AND IS THE ANALYSIS
NOTES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
SUPERVISION OVER SHERIFF'S -- IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTION ABOUT
OVERSIGHT OR ACCOUNTABILITY
ADDITIONALLY THE BORDER STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS CIVIL
GRAND JURIES PROTECTION ADVOCACY
AGENCIES INSPECTED OVERSEE
SHERIFF OPERATIONS.
OF COURSE THIS IS ALL IN
ADDITION TO THE OVERSIGHT -- BUT
IS PROVIDED BY VOTERS WHO
ELECTED SHERIFFS EVERY FOUR
YEARS WE CERTAINLY HAVE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT --
CIVILIANS ISSUING SUBPOENAS AND
AN EXTRA JUDICIAL PROCESS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WITH US FOR A
NO VOTE THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MEASURE.
I I'VE BEEN KIND OF QUIET THIS
MORNING ON MOST OF THE BILLS BUT
THIS ONE IS REALLY PIQUED MY
INTEREST THAT.
THE SOON MCCARTY WHEN I WAS
FIRST APPOINTED TO BE TREASURER
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE -- AS A
RESULT OF REPLACING THE
DISGRACED TREASURER WHO PUT
ISN'T A CHAPTER NINE BANKRUPTCY
I I HAD OVERSIGHT.
AND I HAD BOUGHT IT'S I HAD NOT
ONE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE I TO AND
I HAD MORE THAN TWO OR THREE AND
A LOT IT'S GOING THROUGH MY
DEPARTMENT AS AS A QUOTE UNQUOTE
COUNTY WIDE ELECTED.
AND I DIDN'T SEEM TO MIND.
OF COURSE I WAS PROBABLY THE
MOST AUDIT.
TREASURER'S OFFICE IN THE NATION
BECAUSE OF THE BANKRUPTCY BUT
TIME.
AFTER I BECAME SUPERVISOR -- I
CERTAINLY HAD DIFFICULTIES WITH
MY SHARE.
AND I HAD DIFFICULTIES WITH THE
CULTURE IN THE JAIL.
I HAD -- THIRTY PLUS LAWSUITS
COMING OUT OF THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT -- I FELT THAT THE
GRAND JURY WAS LAMP -- IT DID
REPORT SAYING AT THE HEAD THEIR
REQUIRED TO DO AN ANNUAL REPORT
OF THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE IN.
AND THEY SAID EVERYTHING WAS
FINE EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS A
DEATH IN THE JAIL THAT WAS WELL
PUBLICIZED -- SAYING THAT THE
SUPERVISORS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONTROL THE SHERIFF THROUGH THE
BUDGET.
THAT'S BOGUS.
AS YOU JUST CANNOT CUT PUBLIC
SAFETY -- IN THE BUDGET SO I AM
I AM TOTALLY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
CONCEPT.
I'M I'M NOT SURE IF I I'M
EXCITED ABOUT HOW THE BILL IS
WRITTEN [inaudible]
I'M.
SO WITH THAT -- I'M JUST
WONDERING IF OVERSIGHT BOARD
THAT ACTUALLY REALLY BEEN
EFFECTIVE -- YOU USE A AN
OVERSIGHT BOARD IN USE AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
IT WHICH SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE
CLOSER TO WHAT I WHAT I WE
IMPLEMENTED AN ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH WAS AN OFFICE OF
INDEPENDENT REVIEW AND WE
MODELED AFTER.
MICHAEL URGING NOT GO OUT OF THE
LA COUNTY -- AND SO WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE PROFESSOR A
FEW QUESTIONS I WROTE DOWN
PRISCILLA OCEAN IT'S WHATEVER I
HEARD WHAT WAS WHAT IS IS IT AND
MY CLOTHES.
IT'S CHEN -- SHOP -- CHEN LIKE
OCEAN POTION THANK YOU OKAY.
I AM.
TRYING TO HEAR THE ACTS LIKE LOW
JACK ON THE QUESTION
[inaudible]
SO.
LA COUNTY IS JUST HAD AN
INCREDIBLE.
HISTORY HERE I MEAN MICHAEL CHIU
NOT GO WAS SORT OF THE GOLD
STANDARD AND THEN YOU HAD UNDER
SURE OF TANAKA.
THEY JUST DID ALL KINDS OF SAID
UNFORTUNATE THINGS AND NOW
YOU'VE GOT A FORMER SHERIFF WITH
ALZHEIMER'S GOING TO PRISON
RIGHT IS IS TERRIBLE.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST IS THAT I
WANT GOING ALL THE LET ME BUT
BUT WHEN DID.
THIS CITIZENS OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
GET FORMED A WE WERE FORMED IN
THE AFTERMATH OF A SERIES OF
SCANDALS INCLUDING THE ONES THAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING -- AFTER A
HUNDRED AND SO PAGE REPORT WAS
ISSUED BY A COMMISSION ON JAIL
VIOLENCE IT RECOMMENDED THE
FORMATION OF A CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT PANEL AS WELL AS
ACTIVISM FROM.
VARIOUS COMMUNITY GROUPS WE WERE
FORMED I BELIEVE.
WE BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN SO
WE'VE BEEN.
OPERATING FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS
WITHOUT A SUBPOENA POWER SO WE
ARE ALTHOUGH WE ARE CALLED IN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE I THINK THAT
IS AN OVERSTATEMENT WE ARE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND SO THE THE SHOULD NOT GO
MODEL -- WAS.
WAS ADOPTED BY BY THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND IT WAS HIRED IN IN
BED IT WAS SORT OF LIKE YOU HAD
SOMEONE INSIDE THE DEPARTMENT
THEY COULD.
EARNING GARNER THE TRUST OF OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY REPRESENTATIVES.
BUT CAN ALSO ASSIST IN
[inaudible]
RECOMMENDING -- I DON'T KNOW FOR
PUNISHMENT IS THE RIGHT TERM BUT
BUT CONSEQUENCES TO CERTAIN
ACTIONS AND AND AND THEREFORE
FROM THERE JUMP TO HOW DO WE
IMPROVE OUR POLICIES PROCEDURES.
AND OVERSIGHT SO THAT WE DON'T
SEE A REPEAT IS THAT BEING DONE
BY THIS OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IN
LA SO WE WE HAVE A OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHICH IS I
THINK SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE
REFERENCE AND WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH -- THE O. I. G.'S
SO WE MADE FORWARD REQUESTS IN
THE ALL WHITE SHE MAY USE THEIR
AUTHORITY TO UNDERTAKE
INVESTIGATIONS FOR EXAMPLE OF
FOR EXAMPLE DISPROPORTIONATE
STOPS OF LATINO MOTORISTS --
ALONG THAT I FIVE CORRIDOR AND
THEN FROM THERE WE MIGHT TAKE
ACTION AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
WAR -- THE IG FOR EXAMPLE DID
INVESTIGATION OF COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND ICE AND BASED ON AN
INVESTIGATION THE CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION TOOK ACTION
AND MADE A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
WE HAVE A COMPLEMENTARY.
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE O. I. G. --
BUT THAT ALL EXIST OUTSIDE OF
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT --
UNDER OUR FORMER SHERIFF JIM
MCDONALD THERE WERE AT
CONSTITUTIONAL ADVISORS -- THAT
IS A COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY --
POSITION THAT EXISTED WITHIN THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WHEN OUR
NEW SHERIFF WAS ELECTED.
SHERIFF IN A WAIVER -- THOSE
ADVISERS WERE -- BREED DIMINISH
THEM I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
THE STATUS SAID THAT THE TWO
THAT WERE THAT IT THAT SERVE THE
FORMER SHERIFF WERE DISMISSED --
AND SO THE STATUS OF THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL ADVISERS IS
SOMEWHAT UP IN THE AIR AT THIS
POINT. FOR WAS IT BUDGETARY
BECAUSE THIS NO IT WAS NOT
BUDGETARY.
BECAUSE FOR THE KIND OF
MARKETING WE HAD ESTABLISHED THE
DEPARTMENT IS ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND A YEAR.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SUPPORT STAFF
AS WELL AND AN ASSISTANT SO YOU
JUST MIGHT HAVE A SOMEONE WHO'S
THE A I G. U. R. O. I. G.'S
GIVES ME WHICH I BUT BUT YOU
STILL NEED.
SUPPORT STAFF BUT WHAT WHAT IS
THE SUPPORT STAFF AT THAT YOU'RE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE HAS A SO WE
HAVE AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR --
AND WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
FULL TIME STAFF MEMBERS.
A PUBLIC AFFAIRS OFFICIAL WE
HAVE -- STAFF THAT ASSISTANCE
WITH RESEARCH AND INVESTIGATION.
I WOULD LIKE US TO HAVE A
BROADER STAFF IN A BIGGER BUDGET --
TO DO MORE INVESTIGATION TO DO
MORE OF A SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT
OF THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT BUT
YOU KNOW AGAIN WE'RE IN OUR IN A
SORT OF NASCENT STAGES IN TERMS
OF OUR DEVELOPMENT MY HOPE OVER
TIME THAT THAT THAT WILL EVOLVE.
AS TO THE WILL HAVE A STRONGER
HAND IN OVERSIGHT -- WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THE SOONER CARTY HAD A MODEL
WHERE THE WHERE THE FIVE
SUPERVISORS AND THE SHERIFF
TOGETHER.
I INTERVIEW IN RICK AND HIRED.
THE EITHER THE Y. G. FOR WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY THAT
SELECT THE MEMBERS OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE SO T'S A
TEAM EFFORT.
AND NOT A CONFRONTATIONAL --
EFFORT WE DID THAT WHEN OUR NEW
SHERIFF ARRIVED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE INCLUDED HER
IN OUR INTERVIEW PROCESS OF THE
CANDIDATES SO.
SO AT ALL WE WERE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER BECAUSE PUBLIC SAFETY
IS IS OBVIOUSLY THE THE THE TOP
PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US -- SO I
WITH THAT MR CELLS YELLOW -- WHO?
FORGIVE ME FOR MY ISTORY I'VE
HAD SOME INCIDENTS WERE THIS
GETS.
CAN I GET KIND OF WORKED OUT BUT
BUT WHEN Y..
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE WHY YOU
WOULD HAVE OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD DO IT IN A
COLLABORATIVE FASHION SO THAT IT.
BRINGS ABOUT MORE TRUST IN MORE
IMPROVEMENT. FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS COUNTY WIDE AND FOR
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M.
HELP ME OUT JUST.
THROUGH THE CHAIR -- ART I'M NOT
SURE THAT -- THE MODEL THAT IS
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS BILL --
WILL RESULT IN A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH I MEAN IT IT IT CLEARLY
WILL BREED TENSION -- BETWEEN
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
SHERIFF ESPECIALLY IN COUNTIES
WHERE THEY HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED
ISSUES SIMILAR TO THOSE THAT YOU
HAVE MENTIONED WHERE.
THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS OR YOU
KNOW IF IF DOCUMENTS REQUESTED
NOT PROVIDED OR IF THERE ARE YOU
KNOW QUESTIONABLE PRACTICES THAT.
SOMEBODY DEEMS TO REQUIRE
FURTHER INVESTIGATION OR
OVERSIGHT -- IN IT SO I THINK
THAT'S REALLY THE CHALLENGES
THAT THIS IS CREATING AN
ADVERSARIAL -- SET UP AGAIN BY
PUTTING IT IN STATURE BY SORT OF
LAYING OUT THE MODEL UNDER WHICH
IT HAS TO EXIST -- YOU YOU'RE
NOT TAKING AWAY THE FLEXIBILITY
BUT YOU'RE CREATING THIS
PRESSURE ON A BOARD BECAUSE AND
AS A FORMER BOARD MEMBER A
SUSPECT YOU KNOW THAT NGUYEN
WHEN YOU WHEN THE WHEN THE
BORDERS -- POSSESSIVE OF CERTAIN
STATUTORY AUTHORITIES YOU'LL ONE
LIKELY ARE UNDOUBTEDLY HAVE
CONSTITUENTS WHO -- ASK YOU TO
EXERCISE THEM AND SO THIS THIS
NOTION THAT -- THERE IS
CONFUSION ABOUT AVAILABILITY OR
THAT WE WE NEED THIS TO SORT OF
PROMOTED WE THINK IT'S GOING TO
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO PROMOTED
IN AN ADVERSARIAL WAY TO SAY.
YOU NEED TO DO MORE OVERSIGHT OF
THE SHERIFF OVERSIGHT OF THE
SHERIFF DOES NOT EXIST WHICH WE
JUST.
DISAGREE THAT THERE'S NOT
OVERSIGHT I MEAN I'M AYE AYE
MAIMED SEVERAL AGENCIESIS YOU
YOU HAD AUDITS AND SHERIFFS HAVE
AUDITS AND HEALTH INSPECTIONS
AND COUNTY AUDITS AND AND AND
WE'RE NOT.
CALLING THOSE INTO QUESTION OR
DISPUTING BUT AT SOME POINT YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT IN THIS LEVEL OF MICRO
MANAGEMENT AND DOES THAT BEGIN
TO STIFLE GOVERNANCE BY ELECTED
OFFICIALS [inaudible]
ENTER.
ON BRIDGES SEE IF THE SENATOR
ASK QUESTIONS OKAY AND THEN OF
COURSE ABSOLUTELY AND THEN OF
COURSE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU MAY RESPOND TO ALL
OF THEM AND THEN JUST TO THE
PROFESSOR AGAIN -- YOU KNOW I
I'VE BEEN ORANGE COUNTY SO I GET
TO READ THE LA TIMES TO GET TO
WATCH ALL THE FUN THAT'S
HAPPENING IN LA.
WELL WE WE USE YOUR MODEL -- FOR
WITH MEMBER IN THIS REGION OCT
ALWAYS IS I STILL THINK IS THE
GOLD STANDARD BUT COULD YOU
COMMENT ON THE ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP AND AND I KNOW THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN A NEW.
YOU KNOW A NEW SHERIFF AND AND I
DON'T KNOW HIM VERY WELL.
MCDONNELL I I KNEW BECAUSE HE
WAS AT THE AT THE LONG BEACH
POLICE CHIEF.
I'LL SPEAK -- TO THE SHERIFF
THAT I HAVE THE MOST EXPERIENCE
WITH WITH WAS SAID TO MCDONNELL --
WHEN SHARED MCDONNELL -- TOOK
OFFICE HE WAS ACTUALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CREATION OF
OUR CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT BODY SO
THE IDEA THAT -- LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND YOU KNOW BOARD SUPERVISORS
WOULD NECESSARILY BE AT AT ODDS
OVER THE CREATION OF THE
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT BODIES I
THINK IS BELIED BY OUR
EXPERIENCE -- MOREOVER -- WIND
WE HAD.
ISSUES RELATED TO FOR EXAMPLE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH --
TEAMS MET TEAMS WHICH ARE --
TEAMS OF SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES AND
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIAN SECOND.
BE DISPATCHED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
ACUTE MENTAL HEALTH CRISES WE
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN
TO GO TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO SEEK FUNDING.
WE WERE COLLABORATIVE WITH THE
BORDERS BUT THAT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TO PUT FORTH A SERIES
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FAMILIES WHO
LOST LOVED ONES EITHER IN THIS
IN THE JAILS OR WHO'VE BEEN
KILLED BY A SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES.
I CAN OF THE WITH OUR
IMMIGRATION WHEN WE WERE
INITIALLY FORMING OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT PROVIDED AS A SERIES
OF LUMINOUS INFORMATION ABOUT --
THEIR PRACTICES INITIALLY AND
THEN ONCE WE STARTED TO SEE THAT
WE WEREN'T GETTING THE FULL
SCOPE -- ONCE SO WHY SHE WAS
INVESTIGATING WE STARTED TO ASK
WAR WAR AT A QUESTIONS THAT WERE
A LITTLE BIT MORE ADVERSARIAL
BUT THAT'S ONLY WHEN THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WAS IN.
PROVIDING COMPLETE TRANSPARENT
INFORMATION -- WHEN WE WERE
STARTING TO DO MORE
INVESTIGATION AROUND CREE AND
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS WE
WEREN'T GETTING COMPLETE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION SO WE HAD TO
PRESS THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT --
IN THE EVENTUALLY STARTED TO
GIVE US MORE INFORMATION -- WITH
THIS NEW SHERIFF WERE
EXPERIENCING -- I'M GONNA TRY TO
PUT THIS -- GENTLY WE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A LEVEL OF NON
COOPERATION THAT WE DID NOT
EXPERIENCE WITH THE PRIOR
SHERIFF -- IN SO WE ARE GETTING
STONE WALLED IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ARENAS THAT ARE VERY
CRITICAL -- RELATED -- TO
RELATED TO DISCIPLINE RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION RELATED TO A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT CRITICAL AREAS --
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S OF ANY ONE
SIZE FITS ALL IN TERMS OF THIS
IS EVER SERIAL OR IT ISN'T I
THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT -- AND AS I
SAID I THINK -- THE EXPERIENCE
OF SAYS CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONS THAT HAVE SUBPOENA
POWERS IS AT THE USER'S VERY
JUDICIOUSLY THEY USE IT AS A
LAST RESORT THEY WOULD RATHER
WORK.
I'M COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO GET THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE ASKING FOR I
THINK THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
PREFER THAT AND SO I DON'T THINK
IT IS THE CASE THAT -- YOU KNOW
WELL AS A CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONS WOULD YOU SUBPOENA
POWERS -- AT THE FIRST INSTANCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CERTAINLY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
YOU MAY HAVE SOME RESPONSES YEAH
THOSE ARE.
GOOD QUESTIONS BY CENTER MORE
LOCK IN AND JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY A FEW THINGS I THINK YOU
GOT MOST OF THE ANSWERS HERE --
THERE THERE ISN'T ONE MODEL THAT
OUR BILL IS PROPOSING AND AND
DOES AS YOU NOTE IN ORANGE
COUNTY THE HAVE INSPECTOR
GENERAL POSITION WHICH IS.
APPOINTED BY THE BOARD OF SOUPS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE SHARE
THAT SAME MODEL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
A SOME COUNTIES THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CREATE OVERSIGHT
ENTITY AND APPOINT PEOPLE.
IN SOME ENTITIES THE VOTERS HAD
CREATED ONE ON THEIR OWN.
BUT OUR BILL SAYS IS THAT IF
ANYONE TO HAVE ANY THESE MODELS
OR THE COULD HAVE NOT THE
GOVERNMENT OF THIS BUT IF THEY
HAVE.
THE MALL YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ORANGE COUNTY OR IN SACRAMENTO
IN LA OR WHEREVER.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
HAVE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT THAT
WANTS THAT WON'T STOP THEM.
FROM TRYING TO GET INFORMATION
WE'VE HAD COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF
ALL OF THESE MODELS CREATED IN
GOOD FAITH.
WANTING TO HAVE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT OVER ENTITY OF
GOVERNMENT KNOWING THAT SURE SIR
INDEPENDENT ELECTED YOU NOT
TRYING.
TO TAKE AWAY THEIR JOB BUT THERE
IS A ROLL OF OVERSIGHT AND
GOVERNMENT.
ALLOWING THEM TO DO THEIR JOB TO
GATHER INFORMATION AND THEY HAVE
BEEN -- STOPPED -- IN IN A FEW
THESE INCIDENTS SO AGAIN.
THIS IS A LOCAL CONTROL MEASURE
ENTITIES COULD AND COUNTIES
COULD SAY NO WE DON'T WANT ANY
OF THIS OR THEY CAN CHOOSE.
THE MODEL THAT YOU TALK ABOUT OR
THE MALL WITH LA TALKS ABOUT.
THIRD JUST WANT TO CLARIFY SOME
OTHER WORDS THE BILL DOESN'T
REQUIRE.
SAVE US A GROUP OF VOTERS WANTED
TO PUT -- EITHER A INSPECTOR
GENERAL OR AN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION DON'T HAVE TO DO BOTH.
THEY COULD DO ONE OR THE OTHER
OR BOTH IT'S THE CHEST BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO JUST ALLOWS FOR
IT VERSUS MANDATING IT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- HARI LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS ON THE
DíAS -- I APPRECIATE.
THE BILL I THINK THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE
OURSELVES THROUGH STATUTE HAVE
EXPANDED THE ROLE OF THE SHERIFF
AND I COUNTY JAILS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE
GIVEN GIVEN FAR MORE PEOPLE ARE
NOW IN CUSTODY AND SUPERVISION.
AND WHILE AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT -- SOME SHARE OF
DEPARTMENTS MIGHT NOT WELCOME
SUCH OVERSIGHT I THINK THAT THE
F. THE ABILITY TO FIND TO ALLOW.
ENTITIES TO HELP THIS TIME.
ABILITY TO DO IT IS IMPORTANT IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE IT IT JUST
ALLOWS THE ABILITY SO I THINK
IT'S A A GOOD PHONE I'M WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
AND THE MOTION IS. TO PASS SO IT
DOESN'T GO TO A PERHAPS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ASKING RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SORRY EXCELLENT LET SAID HAVE A
ROLL CALL SKINNER HI THERE I'M
MORE LACKEY.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU.
AROUND THAT WIENER.
HI I'M THE ROLE STAY OPEN -- X.
WE HAVE SOME MISSING MEMBERS
BEEN MISTER RECORD YOU HAVEN'T
SECOND BILL -- AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN ITEM.
SIXTEEN CAN YOU ADAM ON OR NOT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WHAT
?
ALRIGHT GO AHEAD THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MY SECOND BILL
HERE IS TWELVE NINETY SEVEN IT'S
A NARROW BILL RELATED -- TO CCW
PERMITS IT'S FRANKLY ALMOST A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ISSUE NOT LIKE
SAFETY ISSUE BUT WE'RE HERE
TODAY -- THIS IDEA AND
BACKGROUND FOR IT CAME ABOUT A
RECENT AUDIT BY OUR STATE
AUDITOR RELATED TO A CCW PERMITS.
AND THE FEES IN THE STRUCTURE
AND THE OVERSIGHT -- I WANT TO
AGAIN START OUT BY TALKING ABOUT
TO WHAT THIS BILL -- A DOES NOT
DO IT DOESN'T CHANGE WHO CAN
APPLY FOR CCW AND IT'S THE CW'S
THE KANSEN CONCEALED WEAPON
PERMIT OF COURSE.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR WHO CAN OBTAIN
ONE IT DOESN'T CHANGE WHO CAN
ISSUE ONE OR DOESN'T MAKE ANY
OTHER.
SUBSTITUENTS THE CCW Là.
IT ONLY REQUIRES THAT FEES
CHARGED BY SURE FOR POLICE
DEPARTMENT ADEQUATELY COVER THE
COST OF SUCH PERMITS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE FACED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY --
YEAR AFTER YEAR WERE FACING A
DEFICIT OF NEARLY HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE OF INADEQUATE
FEES BECAUSE OF OUR CCW PERMITS --
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE ISSUED A
COUPLE -- HUNDRED A YEAR OUR OUR
PRIOR SHERIFF MCGINNIS AND OUT
THE RE ISSUING A NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND AND SO -- THE FEES
HAVEN'T KEPT UP TO THE ADEQUATE
COSTS AND THE TAXPAYERS ARE
SUBSIDIZING THIS AND SO THIS
COMES DOWN.
TO LIKE MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FEES YOU PAY WHEN YOU GET A
BUILDING PERMIT OR A MARRIAGE
LICENSE YOU KNOW THE FEE SHOULD
COVER THE TRUE COST OF THAT OF
THAT SERVICE -- IT'S NOT JUST
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THE STATE
AUDIT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REVIEWED THE POLICIES OF
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO AND LA.
AND FOUND THAT -- THE THE
ACCOUNTING FOR THESE PROGRAMS
WEREN'T WEREN'T CLEAR A NOR WAS
THERE -- PROPER OVERSIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT BAD ACTORS
WEREN'T HOLDING CCW SINCE SO IF
YOU HAVE ADEQUATE FEES.
AND YOU CAN MAKE SURE THAT
PLEASE DEPARTS INSURANCE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO PROPERLY
INVESTIGATE -- APPLICANTS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE IN THE
HANDS OF THE CORRECT PEOPLE.
AND THEN WILL A LASTLY YOU KNOW
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS MAY NOT
SOUND LIKE A TON OF MONEY HERE
BUT THAT'S THREE OR FOUR
OFFICERS THAT COULD BE.
A SERVING THE COMMUNITY AND
OTHER ENTITIES -- WITH THAT I
ASK YOUR AYE BUT THIS MORNING
AND I HAVE A REPRESENT HIM FROM
THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS.
OFFICE OF PATRICK KENNEDY AND
AMEND WILCOX FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE BRADY CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU WITNESSES GO AHEAD
[inaudible]
THEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
I'M HERE TO READ A STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR PATRICK CANDY -- DEAR
CHAIR SKINNER AND COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO HEAR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
ISSUE.
I'M FIRMLY SUPPORTIVE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN MY SUPPORT IS NOT BASED ON
MY FEELINGS ABOUT GUNS ARE
CONCEALED CARRY WEAPONS PERMITS
THEMSELVES BUT ON THE FISCAL
IMPACT THIS HAS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
DUE TO THE CURRENT DUE TO THE
FACT THAT THE CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES NO GUIDANCE ON HOW MUCH
TO CHARGE FOR AN APPLICATION FEE.
THOSE ISSUING CCW PERMITS ARE
ALLOWED TO CHARGE FEES THAT ARE
INSUFFICIENT FOR COVERING THE
COSTS OF ISSUING AND OVERSEEN
THESE PERMITS.
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY THIS COST
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY TO FUND THE LAST
FISCAL YEAR WE HAVE THIS DATA.
FOR AS I'M SURE YOU ARE WELL
AWARE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STILL RECOVERING FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION.
AND ARE STRUGGLING WITH A NUMBER
OF PRESSING ISSUES SUCH AS
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AN AGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT SHOULD BE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PRIORITY TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
THESE ISSUES RATHER THAN
SUBSIDIZE THOSE WHO WISH TO
OBTAIN A CCW PERMIT.
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN AMANDA
WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE -- BRADY CALIFORNIA IN
GENERAL AND THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY CHAPTER IN PARTICULAR.
FIND IT TROUBLING THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW THERE IS -- A CAP
ON WHAT SHERIFF'S.
OR POLICE CHIEFS IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE CAN CHARGE.
THE FEE THAT THEY CAN CHARGE FOR
ISSUING A CCW PERMANENT.
WE ARE VERY ALARMED THAT -- IN
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THE FEE DOES
NOT COVER THE COST.
THAT FUNDS ARE DIVERTED.
FROM OTHER LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO SUBSIDIZE THE
ISSUANCE ENFORCEMENT OF CCW
LICENSES.
INNOCENCE ENACTMENT OF PROPS TO
THIRTEEN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER TIME ADOPTED
A FEE FOR SERVICE -- RECEIVE
MODEL AND WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
BASIC SERVICES A FEES LOBBIED
FOR VIRTUALLY EVERY TRANSACTION
OR APPLICATION TO RECOVER THE
COSTS.
ARE CARRYING A LOADED HITTING
GUN IN PUBLIC IN OUR VIEW IS A
PRIVILEGE AND THIS IS SAME
STANDARD SHOULD APPLY TO SEE C.
W. LICENSE APPLICATION FEE.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT AFTER A
FEE IS ISSUED -- AS WE SAW IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THE COUNTY
SHERIFF -- HAD TO BE SINCE SOME
OF THESE LICENSES THAT PERHAPS
INAPPROPRIATELY WERE ISSUED --
THAT OVERSIGHT DOES REQUIRE
RESOURCES -- AND AGAIN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE COST OF
ISSUING AN OVERSEEING THE
PERMANENT -- IS COVERED BY --
THE PERMIT HOLDER RARE THEN
DIVERTING MONEY FROM COUNTY
FUNDS TO URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STE HURRY UP AND COME TO THE
MIKE IF YOU'RE COMING OKAY NO
ALL RIGHT SO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND I THINK THERE'S ROOM AT THE
TABLE SO YOU CAN STAY AT THE
TABLE THERE'S ROOM.
FOR WE HAVE A BIG HEARING ROOM
TODAY.
THAT'S HE SEEMS TO BE ALWAYS THE
CASE BUT SUPPOSED TO MAKE US
WANT TO GO FAST.
MATT RESERVE NEED.
I'M SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD IN READ
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
HERE.
IN OPPOSITION TODAY -- AS YOU'RE
AWARE WHEN IT COMES TO INSURANCE
OF CWC.
IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEIR
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS IT'S A
VERY INVOLVED PROCESS AND IT'S A
VERY EXPENSIVE.
ONE JUST BETWEEN -- THE
APPLICATION FEES THE ISSUANCE
FEES AND THE FINGERPRINTS YOU'RE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND THAT DOESN'T
EVEN INCLUDE -- THE TRAINING
WHICH IS IN THE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLAR RANGE -- ADDITIONALLY ARE
PERMITS ARE ONLY GOOD FOR TWO
YEARS AND THEY HAVE TO BE
RENEWED WHICH ALSO COMES AROUND --
YOU KNOW DID THAT'S ANOTHER
EXPENDITURE BY BY CITIZENS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF OUR NEIGHBORING STATES --
THAT ISSUE PERMITS THEIR THEIR
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THAT AND
THE PERMITS OR FOR SIGNIFICANTLY
LONGER DURATIONS.
AND I THINK THAT IF WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BUDGET HERE
IN THE MONETARY COSTS WILL WE
SHOULD REALLY BE LOOKING AT IS
EXTENDING THE DURATION.
OF CCW PERMITS TO FOR FIVE YEARS
LIKE MOST STATES AROUND THE%
COUNTRY.
CCW PERMITS IT'S NOT THAT YOU
GET ISSUE DEPARTMENT AND YOU
HAVE A GOOD DAY THESE.
A PERMIT HOLDERS ARE MONITORED
IN IN THE EVENT THAT THERE IS
ANY SORT OF VIOLATION.
THAT WOULD MAKE THEM INELIGIBLE
TO HOLD THAT PERMIT THE PERMIT
IS REVOKED.
SO WE COULD CUT OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN HALF
SIMPLY BY DOUBLING THE DURATION
OF THE PERMIT.
KNOW WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING IS
BY REMOVING THE CAP -- WE COULD
HAVE A AN INEQUITABLE SYSTEM
BEYOND.
THE THE FALL TO THE HOUSE RIGHT
NOW WITH THE WAY THESE PERMITS
CAN BE ISSUE BUT YOU COULD HAVE
CERTAIN CHAIRS THAT ARE CHARGING.
OR ISSUING AUTHORITIES CHARGING
EXORBITANT COSTS FOR THIS AND IT
WOULD -- PRICE PEOPLE OUT SO
TRULY THESE WOULD BE RESERVE FOR
THE ELITE OR THE FAVORED.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WE WANT
THAT THIS IS THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A DEMAND FOR IT A DEMAND
TO EXERCISE YOUR RIGHTS AND
DEFEND YOURSELF IN YOUR FAMILY --
AND SO I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY ABOUT GOING AND I
ABOUT CUTTING OUR COSTS I THINK
THAT THIS IS A LOCAL ISSUE IN AS
YOU NOTICE THERE'S NO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR ISSUING AUTHORITY
HERE.
SAYING THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
RECOVERING ENOUGH MONEY IN
ISSUING THESE PERMITS -- TODAY
SO I THINK THAT IF WE WANT TO
LOOK AT THOSE COSTS WOULD LOOK
AT EXTENDING THE DURATION RATHER
THAN PLACING MORE COSTS ON ON
THE PEOPLE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SEPARATIST
REPRESENTING ON WAS CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO TERRIBLE.
THE SHERIFF'S OF VERY RECENTLY
AS RECENTLY AS THIS MORNING.
AND AND THEY THEY POINTED OUT TO
ME THAT FIRST THERE ARE.
THE RUN THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
A PROFITABLE GOVERNMENT SERVICE
PROGRAM ALL SERVICES COST MONEY
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
THE AUTHORITIES THAT ARE
SPENDING THE MONEY.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THE GOALS THAT
THEIR ARE REQUIRED TO ACCOMPLISH
STATUTORILY -- AND SOMETIMES
THAT MEANS AS AS WE KNOWING AND
GOVERNMENT I SERVED UNDER TWO
GOVERNORS -- AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMERCE IN THE TRADE AND
COMMERCE AGENCY AND I SAW HOW IT
WAS -- IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
BE.
FLEXIBLE IN ORDER TO COVER.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THAT ARE
MANDATED -- SOMETIMES MANDATED
WITHOUT.
A RESOURCES TO TO TO CONDUCT
THOSE PROGRAMS -- BUT THE WE DID
IT AND AND I THINK THE CHEFS ARE
DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF THAT.
NOW THERE'S A MATTER OF SCALE
WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IT'S
INTERESTING THAT THEY AUDITED
THE SAN DIEGO LOS ANGELES IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THERE'S AN IN A MATTER OF SCALE
IN LOS ANGELES THE ISSUE
VIRTUALLY NO PERMITS.
THEY ARE EXT GREENLEE RARE.
ANY AMOUNT OF STAFF.
IT'S A SIGN TO THE C. W. PROGRAM
DOWN THERE IS GOING TO BE
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO GO WITH THE
ISSUE IS -- IN IN COMPARISON TO
TWO STAFF PEOPLE THAT THE
PROCESS THEM.
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
EXPENSIVE SAN DIEGO SAME THING
ONLY RECENTLY HAVE THEY BEGUN TO
ISSUE MORE AND MORE.
OF HIM PERMITS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THEY HAVE
ISSUED A LOT MORE PERMITS AND WE
KNOW THAT -- THE THE AUTHOR HAS
BEEN CRITICAL OF OF THE SHERIFF
AND HIS SPENDING PRACTICES AND
HOW HE'S -- THE USING THESE
PUBLIC RESOURCES WHEN IN FACT
LAST YEAR YOU KNOW HE WAS
CRITICIZED FOR FOR BEING FOR A
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER BUDGET
WITH THIS ISSUE THAT WE BROUGHT.
IN THIS THE SHERIFF ACTUALLY
RETURN SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
BACK TO THE COUNTY TO BE ABLE TO
SPEND ANYWAY THAT THEY WANTED SO
HE'S IN A PRETTY GOOD JOB I
THINK OF OF MAXIMIZING THE USE
OF ALL OF THE RESOURCES IN ORDER.
TO ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THE GOALS
THAT THE REQUIRED TO DO.
THIS.
BILL WILL.
BOYS GOING TO CREATE SOME ISSUES
AND FOR THESE REASONS AND AND
WHAT WAS STATED PREVIOUSLY OR IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER --
IN OPPOSITION GO AHEAD REMEMBER
CHAIR ROY GRIFFIS SPEAKING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION WHICH IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT COMMENTS FROM THE GUYS
SENATOR JACKSON'S INSIDE LIKE TO
ASK WHAT IS SHIPPED -- WHAT IS
THE CRITERIA THE BASIS FOR
ISSUANCE OF A CONCEALED?
WEAPONS KERRY THE FOLKS FROM
SACRAMENTO COULD YOU TELL US.
WHAT THE CRITERIA ARE WHAT IS
THE WORK THAT GOES INTO A
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE ISSUANCE
OF A PERMIT?
THERE'S A CLAIM THAT -- BY THE
PROPONENTS SAID -- CCW CARRIERS
ARE MONITORED WHAT WHAT IS THE
EFFORT WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT
YOU MAY RESPOND.
I'D HAVE TO GET MORE DETAILS ON
THAT I DO KNOW INITIALLY THERE'S
A FINGER PRINTING AND A
BACKGROUND CHECK AS FAR AS THE
ON GOING MONITORING -- I WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT I'M NOT
pKNOW THERE ARE WERE A FEW TIMES --
THERE WERE REPORTED IN THE NEWS
WORK INSTANCES WERE PERMITS OR
NOT REVOKED WHEN THEY PERHAPS
SHOULD HAVE SO I DO KNOW THAT IS
A KURD AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THE MIND TURNING IS QUITE WHERE
IT SHOULD BE BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE ENTIRE PROCESS LOOKS
LIKE. TO ME ASK ME ASK TO THE
CHAIR THE AUTHOR COULD YOU
EXPLAIN I MEAN WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF EFFORTS
WHEN SOMEONE GOES INTO SEEK A
CONCEALED CARRY.
PERMIT -- TO THE THEY GIVE YOU
THEIR LICENSE TEY WHAT ELSE DO
THEY HAVE TO DO HOW IS IT
DETERMINED BY A SHARE OF TO
ISSUE THESE PERMITS TYSON
THERE'S WORK THAT HAS TO GO INTO
IT.
OR NOT YEAH WELL IT VARIES BY
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND THAT'S
A BIG DEBATE OR NOT HAVING TODAY.
SOME COUNTIES LOS ANGELES.
SAN DIEGO YOLO RIGHT HERE YOU
HAVE TO SHOW GOOD CAUSE A REASON
TO HAVE A YEAR YOU HAVE THAT
THAT THE SPOUSE OR DOMESTIC
PARTNER WHO HAS THREATENED YOU
YOU'RE IN A JOB WHERE YOU.
HAVE HAD -- SOMEBODY -- FOR HAVE
HAVE FEAR IN YOUR LIFE AND THERE
IS THERE IS THAT -- QUANTIFIABLE
JUSTIFIABLE REASON OTHER
COUNTIES LIKE YOU'RE IN
SACRAMENTO REAL COUNTIES IT'S
IT'S YOU SHALL IF YOU SHOW UP
AND HAVE A DRIVER'S LICENSE IN A
CHECK BOOK AND DON'T HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD AT THE MOMENT.
THEY WILL ISSUE A A A A PERMIT
TO GET THE LICENSE AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE'RE DEBATING ABOUT
TODAY I THINK THAT'S A WORTHY
DEBATE NO NO AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE REAL COST OF ISSUING A
PERMIT THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT IS THE REAL COST?
SO IN STATURE WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS IS THERE IS A CAP OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS I UNDERSTAND
LAST THERE'S OTHER FEES THEY
CHARGE THAT THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS SO -- I DON'T HAVE.
THE EXACT AMOUNT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S SEVERAL
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN IN IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THOSE FEES THE
GOVERNMENT FEES OR OTHER FEES
THAT YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR YOUR
YOUR TRAINING ON YOUR OWN ENDS
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT BUT
JUST THE COUNTY COSTS.
AND BUT WE FOUND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IS THAT WHEN YOU.
SPREAD ALL THOSE OUT IT DOESN'T
ADEQUATELY COVER THE TRUE COST
OF THAT SERVICE.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE COST
REALLY WOULD VARY BY COUNTY I
MEAN THERE'S A STATE STANDARD IN
TERMS OF THE THE TRAINING THAT'S
REQUIRED EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND
CHECK.
LIVING IN THE JURISDICTION IN
WHICH YOU'RE APPLYING FOR THE
PERMIT BUT THEN IT'S REALLY UP
TO THE LOCAL LAW FOR CERTAIN THE
SHERIFF.
TERMLY -- TO DETERMINE THAT
THERE IS GOOD CAUSE AND THAT THE
PERSONS OF GOOD MORAL CHARACTER
AND SOME SHERIFFS AS WAS STATED.
BOB DON'T SEEM TO TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND ISSUE A PERMIT TO
ANYBODY AND OTHERS TO AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY THE VOTERS --
BASED ON THAT POLICY WHAT I FIND
ALARMING IN SACRAMENTO IS THE
COUNTY SHERIFF SAID HE ISSUES
AND QUICKLY AND THEN HE TAKES
HIM BACK IT DOESN'T HEAT
HESITATE TO REVOKE ON THE REVOKE
SOME BECAUSE THE PERSON'S
COMMITTED A CRIME.
AFTER SOMETHING IS HAPPENING
AFTER PERHAPS SOMEONE HAS BEEN
HARMED THAT'S THAT'S VERY
ALARMING -- AGAIN THAT'S A
SEPARATE POLICY ABOUT THE
STANDARDS AND AND SHALL ISSUE
VERSUS OUR MAY ISSUE THAT --
ACCOUNT THAT A SHERIFF CHOOSES
TO FOLLOW BUT THE VERY LEAST
THERE SHOULD BE ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR THEM -- TO DO THAT OVERSIGHT.
BOB REVOKE IT IF NEEDED AND AS
YOU HEARD THAT IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY -- THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
BASED ON THE FEAR THAT WAS
CHARGED IN THE COUNTY THAN ADAM
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE.
CENTER JACKSON GIVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS NO I I I I GET A SENSE
OF NOT CAN I GET WE DON'T HAVE A
PRECISE ANSWER BUT I CAN GIVE
YOU AN ANSWER MIXXENTM IS ME
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR HE'D ASKED.
FOR THE COUNTY TO RESPOND IN
TERMS OF THAT SO I THINK THAT'S
ADEQUATE A I AM I'M A CCW
INSTRUCTOR AND VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS AND I CAN TELL
YOU WHAT YOU'LL BERMAN PROCESS
IS IN THE COST I THINK WHAT'S
BEEN DETERMINED BY THE ANSWER IS
THAT THERE'S NOT.
PER SE A FIXED COST AND THAT IT
IS DEPENDENT ON WHAT THE HOW THE
LATE WHAT -- RULE THE COUNTY
CHOOSES TO TAKE GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY THAT THE STATUTE BUT
THE RIVER SLASH.
EVERY COUNTY HAS WILL CERTAINLY
THERE ARE FIXED COSTSYES BUT
THERE CAN BE BROADER BUT I THINK
WE'VE SAID ENOUGH AND CENTER
JACKSON DO HAVE ENOUGH AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE COUNTY
HAS TO PAY BECAUSE WHAT WERE
TRYING TO DO IS FIGURE OUT.
HOW MUCH WE'RE THE THE ACTUAL
COST IS SO IF WE WERE IF WE WERE
HERE IN THE STATE WE'RE GOING TO
BE?
DOING THIS THEN THEY WOULD HAVE
TO BE SOME INDICATION FROM
WHATEVER DEPARTMENT WAS BEING
ASKED TO IMPLEMENT WHATEVER THE
ORDER WAS WHAT THEY ANTICIPATE
THE COST WOULD BE AND WHAT THOSE
COSTS.
ARE RELATED TO THAT LED TO A DO
WE NEED MORE PERSONNEL.
YEAH I DO.
IN OF POLICIES THAT YOU DIDN'T
HAVE THIS INFORMATION BUT IN THE
AUDITOR'S OWN REPORT -- IN THIS
IS SPECIFIC TO A COST OF A
COUNTY.
ACCORD THE SACRAMENTO CCW
LICENSING PROGRAM HAS HAD A
DEFICIT IN EACH OF THE LAST
THREE FISCAL YEARS SO THERE
EXPENDITURES EXCEEDED THEIR
REVENUES AND THEIR REVENUE SERVE
COURSE.
THIS THIS -- PERMIT COST IN OF
FOR THREE YEARS FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU ARE NUTS IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT I APPRECIATE
THAT I'M NOT SO MUCH INTEREST IN
WHAT IT COSTS INDIVIDUAL GETTING
THE LICENSE BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW.
IS THIS IS THE COUNTIES GETTING.
REQUIRING THAT THIS BEING A NET
ZERO IF YOU WILL -- NOBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT THE MAKING MONEY
OFF OF THIS BUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS COVERING THE
COST TO THE TAXPAYER DOESN'T.
HAVE TO COVER THE COST -- IF IF.
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO HAVE A
CONCEALED KERRY THAT IS A
PRIVILEGE AYE.
I WILL CHARACTERIZE WHAT I THINK
OF IT BUT IT IS A YA IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO HAVE A COST TO THE
COUNTY AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT COST IS -- BECAUSE
I I AGREE THAT IF THERE HAS BEEN
A DEFICIT THAT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
NOT SEEING THE AMOUNT THAT
SHOULD BE.
COVERED BUT I WONDER WHAT THE
COUNTY.
OF SACRAMENTO WOULD CLAIM ITS
COSTS ARE PER PERMIT ISSUANCE
AND THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT AND WHAT AND WHAT
THAT'S BASED UPON.
YEAH IF I ROUTE I AM SURE HE
MORE SKIS ME ROUTE THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE IF YOU
HAVE A SPECIFICS OTHER THAN WHAT
WE KNOW FROM.
THAT YOU'RE.
COSTS OF EXCEEDED YOUR REVENUE
IF YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC -- TO
WHETHER THERE IS A PRE
DETERMINED COST PER ISSUANCE --
I DON'T HAVE THE PRE TERM COST
PER ISSUANCE BUT LIKE I CAN ON
MY BILL WORK IT OUT.
BUT NOT THAT QUICKLY BUT I DO
HAVE THE TOTAL STAFFING COSTS --
THAT WE HAD AND THE AMOUNT THAT
WE SUBSIDIZED AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN A TOTAL STAFFING COSTS
WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
THE DEFICIT THAT THE TAXPAYERS
PAID WERE.
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND THANK THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COSTS CENTER MOORLACH
THANK YOU MANAGER OF BEING A
FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR KNOWING
THAT.
COSTS A TOTAL COMPENSATION OF A
DEPUTY SHERIFF -- A PLUS THE
OVERHEAD TRYING TO ALLOCATE WHAT
DO YOU CHARGE PER CCW -- HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS A BARGAIN.
SO MISTER A PRESS YOU WERE GOING
TO GIVE AN ANSWER MAY MAY I ASK
FOR YOU JUST TO FINISH THAT
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
ARM YOU MAY ASK MISTER
PREDECESSOR QUESTION DO YOU HAVE
A SPECIFIC QUESTION TO ASK HIM
JUST FINISH.
YOU SAID YOU HAD AN ANALYSIS AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO COME
EVEN CLOSE TYLER'S.
PER PER MINUTE RATE.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY THE CHAIR
YES THE WHEN THEY PROCESS IN IT
WHEN EVERY SHARE FOR EVERY CHIEF
OF POLICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ISSUES PERMITS.
THEY HAVE THE SAME COSTS. FOR
THE FOLLOWING THINGS NUMBER ONE
THEY HAVE TO CHECK.
THE ALL OF THE FIREARMS THAT ARE
LISTED ON PEOPLE CCW TO CHECK
THAT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THERE'S A COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THAT THEIR
CHARGE AND THAT COST.
BERRIES A LITTLE BIT THEN THEY
ARE EACH OF THESE AGENCIES ARE
CHARGED PER PER MINUTE -- FOR
THE ACTUAL BACKGROUND CHECK THAT
IS CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DOESN'T CONDUCT THESE VERY
QUICKLY YOU CAN HIRE PEOPLE AND
HAVE THEM ON BOARD AND THEN YOU
PAY I'M OFF UNTIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE COMPLETES
ITS.
ITS ITS BACKGROUND CHECK AND
THEN SUBMITTED FOR THE THE THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE. TO TO THE
PROCESS OF TYPING UP.
THE THE PERMIT TAKING THE
PHOTOGRAPH IT THAT'S WHAT THEY
DO -- AND AND HAVING THE
APPOINTMENT FOR THE PERSON TO
COME IN AND TEN AND RECEIVE THAT
THING SO THERE ARE DEFINITELY
FIX COSTS THAT ARE THE SAME FOR
EVERYBODY AND IT IS NOWHERE NEAR
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND IT'S THE COST OF A OF AN X.
ENHANCE BACKGROUND CHECK.
A COST FOR THE INVESTIGATION OF
ALL OF THE FIREARMS THAT ARE
LISTED THE PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE --
BE ABLE TO CARRY THEIR CHECKED
TO SEE THEIR STOLEN.
THE CHECK TO SEE IF THEY'RE
REGISTERED TO THE PERSON WHO'S
YOUR QUESTION THE SIX W..
AND THAT INFORMATION IS THEN
SHARED WITH THE WITH THE SHERIFF
FOR THE CHIEF OF POLICE AND
WHICH POINT THEY DECIDE WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING -- TO PROCEED WITH
ISSUE IN THAT THAT LICENSE --
THE COST IS IS THOSE ARE THE
FIXED COST OF THE ACTUAL PROCESS
OF DELIVERING A CCW -- TO TO A
OF CUT NAPA CAN'T IT WHICH
TOTALS.
AB AND REYES AND WHICH TOTALS --
IT DOES VERY DEPENDING THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE A DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS BUT IT'S HALF OF THE
HUNDRED DOLLARS -- THE YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE. TO TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A STAFF TIME IN
THE OVERHEAD WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THE WHAT THE WHAT THE
THE SHERIFF IS.
KILLED BY THE BY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE FOR PROCESSING THE
PERMIT THE OTHER EXPENSES YET
MAYBE REMEMBER.
YOUR GOOD SAMPLE -- THE SERMON
PARTY -- I JUST A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS WHEN I I GULAR
FRUSTRATED WHEN THERE'S A CAP.
INSIDE STATE CODE LIMITING WHAT
COUNTIES CAN CHARGE OR MAYBE
IT'S TOO HIGH MAY WAS TOO LOW.
I'VE SEEN IT BOTH WAYS -- SO I
YOU KNOW THIS GOES BACK TO PENAL
CODE TWENTY SIX ONE NINETY B..
AND IT'S AT LEAST FROM MY
RESEARCH FROM THE MATERIAL I
HAVEN'T SO AT LEAST OVER TEN
YEARS.
OLD SO YOU'RE WILLING HAVE AN
INFLATION FACTOR HERE -- SO.
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY YOU WANT
TO REMOVE THE CAP AS OPPOSED TO
MAYBE JUST RAISING THE CAP AND
DOING IT MAYBE OVER A GRADUATED.
PHASED IN PERIOD OF TIME.
I GUESS IT BOILS DOWN TO THE
FACT THAT SOME COUNTIES LIKE
SACRAMENTO WHERE THERE'S OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE.
THE ISSUE THEY HAVE TEN THOUSAND
PERMITS SOME COUNTY LIKE LA
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE THEY ISSUE
A COUPLE HUNDRED SO IT ADDED
IT'S IT'S BASED UPON.
YOU KNOW THEIR WORKLOAD AND
ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
AND I GUESS WE COULD PUT A CALL
IN THERE PUT INDEX TO IT BUT I
THINK THE BIGGER QUESTION IS
THAT -- SHOULD BE BASED UPON
YOUR YOUR COUNTY AND HAVE A TRUE
RECOVERY MODEL.
AS IS THE EARLIER BY WITNESS
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN THAT BECAME
THE BASIS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FOR WRONG OR RIGHT.
THAT IT'S IT'S A COST RECOVERY
FOR THE SERVICES AND AS THE AND
ARE A WITNESS TESTIFIED -- THESE
THINGS DO COST MONEY AND IT'S
NOT DIRT THERE IT'S A COUPLE
HUNDRED DOLLARS LITERALLY AND IF
THEY CAN IF IN IT IF INCREASE
FOR TRUE COST BASED UPON THE
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE.
IT WOULDN'T QUITE DOUBLES SO
IT'S NOT GONNA BE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR SOMEONE TO GET A CCW
PERMIT WOULD BE.
INCREMENTALLY MORE BUT IF IT
TAKES THAT THE BIGGER QUESTIONS
WHO SHOULD PAY THE DIFFERENCE
SHOULD BE THE PERSON GETTING THE
PRIVILEGE OF THAT PERMIT. FOR
THE GENERAL TAXPAYER AND SO I
THINK THAT'S THE WITH THE BATES
ALL ABOUT HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
PERHAPS I'M.
WHY NOT HAVE AN INITIAL FEE?
AND THEN A VERY LOW RENEWAL FEE
WHERE NO WORK IS DONE OTHER THAN
YOU'RE JUST [inaudible]
RE UPPING.
LIKE A TWO TWO TWO STAGE PROGRAM
WHICH WAS ONE I DISAGREE WHEN I
DID WAS JUST TAKE MAKE THE
PERMIT NOT ONE YEAR BUT MAKE IT
FOR YOU KNOW MAKE IT FOR YEARS.
AND THEN YOU'D YOU'D HAVE ONE
SHOT EVERY FOUR YEARS.
BUT HOW ABOUT THE FIRST INITIAL
APPROVAL IS ONE FEE AND THEN.
JUST SITTING IN A RENEWAL
ANNUALLY THAT SHOULD BE A LOT
LESS CORRECT YOU CAN RESPOND
SURE THAT THE THE RENEWAL THING
EVERY FOUR YEARS I THINK IT'S A
TERRIBLE IDEA LET ME TELL YOU
WHY THERE IS AN INDIVIDUAL.
ACROSS THE STREET THE CAPITAL
WHO HAD AN ARSENAL OF FIREARMS
AND HUNDREDS OF ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
AND SOMEHOW THE HOUSEKEEPING AND
SERVANT AT SERVICE INDIVIDUAL
WALKED IN AND DISCOVERED ALL
THIS AND CALLED HER MANAGER.
AND THEY CALL THE SACK WHEN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT IT COULDN'T
FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON
THEY THEY FOUND THE GUY WHO IS
HAVING -- SOME TYPE OF MENTAL
BREAKDOWN. TWENTY MILES SOUTH OF
HERE THEY CONTACTED HIM AND GOT
HIM SOMEHOW CAJOLED INTO CERTAIN
AREA WITH HIS FAMILY.
AND HE SAID THAT HE WANTED TO
CREATE HARM TO GOVERNMENT HE WAS
ESSENTIALLY GONNA HAVE AN
ASSAULT RIGHT ACROSS FROM THE
CAPITOL WHICH IS IS RIPPED OUT
THE HEADLINES.
AND SO.
THESE THINGS OUGHT TO BE RENEWED
ON A ANNUAL BASIS AND THEY HAVE
TO HAVE FRANKLY I THINK HAVING A
PROPER A FEE STRUCTURE TO DO
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T GET HIM IN THE
FIRST PLACE BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE PROBABLY LIKE OUR
WITNESSES THAT ARE.
LAWFUL CCW HOLDERS WHO PROBABLY
HAVE NO PROBLEM HAVING -- A
WEAPON BUT OTHER INDIVIDUALS WE
GOT WE GOT TO DO MORE --
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S SAFE.
DOES THIS PERSON A CCW HOLDERS
YES HE WAS OKAY LAST QUESTION
MADAM CHAIR RIGHT ARM.
WHY YOUR YOUR BILL MAKES THIS A
REQUIREMENT WHY NOT OPTIONAL
BECAUSE ASSURE OCCURS HAS?
AS A BUDGET AND CAN.
IN A SENSE FOR THE BUDGET
SUBSIDIZE SOME OF THESE COSTS
THAT IS THAT'S A CHOICE AT THAT
DEPARTMENT IT HAS -- SO I'M I'M
WONDERING WHY YOU'RE MAKING IT A
REQUIREMENT.
WELL IT'S IT'S A CHOICE NOT JUST
OF THE SHARE THAT'S A CHOICE OF
THE CITIZENRY SO YOU'RE IN
SCRAMENTO WE HAVE.
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE WHO DO NOT.
ABBAS CCW LICENSE ANY CHOOSE NOT
TO DO SO THERE ARE THE RIGHTS OF
THE TEN THOUSAND THE HABS HAVE
SOME THAT'S THE CURRENT LAW.
BUT BUT WHY SHOULD WE BE
SUBSIDIZING.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
EARNED BY WILL JUST NOTE ON THAT
THAT IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT ONE
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WAS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO MANDATE.
THIS BAG IN FACT -- TO DO WHAT --
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DOING IN
THIS BILL.
NOW OF COURSE THAT IS JUST A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE AUDITOR
BUT IT WAS IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS.
ALL RIGHT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
MAY CLOSE.
I THANK YOU I I APPRECIATE THE
THE ROBUST DEBATE I I DID WANT
TO NOTE THAT I WAS HERE THREE
YEARS AGO.
WITH THE SAME BILL IN IT WAS
VETOED AND ARE THEN GOVERNOR
ASKED A QUESTION.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS A ONE OFF
JUST HERE AT SAT COUNTY.
SO I I YOU KNOW TOOK THE VIEW AT
HAND AND SAID OKAY FAIR QUESTION
SO NEXT YEAR I WENT AND ASK FOR
STATE AUDITOR TO EVALUATE.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A PROBLEM
JUST IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY OR
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SO SHE DID A A ROBUST AUDITS
LOOKED AT SEVERAL COUNTIES AND
CAME BACK WITH THE CONCLUSIONS
WHICH I'M HERE WITH TODAY.
SO THIS IS BASED UPON A SOUND
RESEARCH STATEWIDE AND OUR LOCAL
EXAMPLE AND ASK THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
HI I THINK WE ALREADY HAD A
MOTION.
OKAY -- THEN.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WILL TAKE A ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
SKINNER HI.
I'M MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NOW BRADFORD FIVE
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL I'M AROUND [inaudible]
WIENER.
ALRIGHT WE'LL KEEP AN ON CALL
AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A RECESS
SO WE WON'T OPEN THE ROLE FOR
THOSE TIMES.
BILLS THAT ARE STILL IN CALL
TILL AFTER.
WE RECONVENE WE WILL RECONVENE
IN ROOM THREE ONE NINE ONE AT
ONE THIRTY AND AT THAT POINT THE
FIRST BILL WE HERE.
WE WILL HEAR.
IS ITEM THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY BECAUSE HE HAS AN
OBLIGATION.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THAT
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO
FILE ORDER AND THAT IS ROOM
THREE ONE NINE ONE ONE THIRTY
WITH THAT.
WE ARE RECESSED
IF YOUR AND WITNESSES ARE HERE.
OKAY THEN -- PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IS NOW.
COMING RETURNING FROM RECESS I
KNOW THAT I HAVE MEMBERS ON
THEIR WAY -- AND WE OF PROMISED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY THAT WE
WOULD START WITH YOUR BILL
[inaudible]
SO.
WHEN YOU GO AHEAD AND BEGIN?
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU.
AND I WANT TO SAY THIS IS A BILL
THAT DEALS WITH ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS.
BUT ANIMALS AREN'T THE ONLY
THINGS THAT MOVING CHANGE AND
MOVE ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE VERY ENVIRONMENT
WHICH WERE RENDON AYE NOTE -- TO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THINGS WERE HAPPENING
ON THE WEST.
I'M IN THE OCEAN ON THE WEST
COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SEEING MORE.
WHETHER IT'S A WHALE IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. SIXTY LINES ARE
THINGS APPROACHING THE COAST.
WHERE SHE'S SEEN SERVICE ANSWER
BRING PEOPLE IN CONTACT WITH
ANIMALS IN SETTINGS WE DON'T?
TYPICALLY EXPECT.
WE HAVE WE'VE HAD DROUGHT WHICH
BRINGS ANIMALS OUT AT NIGHT IN
IN THE MORNING SEARCHING FOR
WATER.
INTO URBANIZED AREAS I LIVE LONG
AMERICAN PARKWAY AND WE SEE.
GREATER INFLUX OF COYOTES OTHER
SORTS OF THINGS REPORTS OF
OUTLINES.
URBAN INTERFACE THE FIRES.
PEOPLE IN.
AND THEN WE'VE AUTHORIZED HAVING
PEOPLE IN THEIR BACKYARDS
DEGROOT.
RAISE CHICKENS OF DAYS WHICH
ALSO ATTRACT.
ANIMALS IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF CHANGE GOING
ON THAT END I THINK INFLUENCES
JUST THE NATURAL WORLD AROUND US
AND ANIMALS THAT SORT OF THING.
THIS BILL DEALS A CERTIFIED
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICERS.
ARMED [inaudible]
YET.
THEIR FUNCTION IS TO PROMOTE THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF ANIMALS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THE HUMANS AND
NO SAME COMMITTEES THAT'S THEIR
SPECIALTY.
AND THERE IS JUST A NEED FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROFESSIONAL DEAL
WITH ALL MANNER OF ANIMALS AND
ENTER INTO OUR COMMUNITY.
WELL SOME ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS HAVE SPECIALIZED
TRAINING THAT HAS NOT ACTUALLY
BEEN THE NORM IN CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE KIND OF FALL INTO THESE
ROLES.
ARM AND SO TRAINING STANDARDS
CAN VERY COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY
COUNTY BY COUNTY.
SO THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK TO WHICH ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICERS.
I MAY RECEIVE STATE RECOGNIZED
CERTIFICATION IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
SO IT'S NOT A HEAVY HANDED
APPROACH BUT IT DOES SORT OF
RAISED TO PROFESSIONAL BAR.
ON FOLKS WHO WANNA GAUGES TYPE
WORK.
IT WILL FOSTER GREATER
UNIFORMITY PROFESSIONALISM.
AND IT WILL HELP LOCAL AGENCIES
IDENTIFY PEOPLE THAT THEY WANT.
TO PUT IN THESE POSITIONS IN
ADVANCE.
LET'S PEOPLE SHOWCASE.
THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PROFESSIONALISM.
SO I HAVE YOUR TO TESTIFY IN RE.
PRESENT SKI LET'S SAVE CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION A LESSON TO BRIEFLY
ADDRESS THE CHAIR.
AND THERE [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PUBLIC
SAFETY MY NAME IS HANNAH
BURZYNSKI.
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWS
CAL ANIMALS.
OF ALL FROM THE RECENT MERGER OF
THE CALIFORNIA WILL CONTROL
DIRECTORS A FORTY YEAR OLD
ORGANIZATION.
AND STATE HUMANE ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
OLD.
EXCUSE ME OUR STATE WHY GROUP
REPRESENTS BOTH GOVERNMENTAL AND
NON PROFIT ANIMAL SERVICES
AGENCIES.
OUR ASSOCIATION IS A SPONSOR OF
AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE AS YOU
SOMEONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY SAID THE
TRAININGS VOLUNTEERING BILL IS
PATTERNED AFTER THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT NON MANDATORY
CERTIFICATION PREVIOUSLY PASSED
BY YOUR LEGISLATURE.
MARIN HUMANE SOCIETY CURRENTLY
HAS A BASIC ANIMAL CONTROL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACADEMY.
AND THAT'S BEEN SPONSORED BY THE
SANTA ROSA PUBLIC SAFETY CENTER
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS THERE'S
ANOTHER ACADEMY IN SAN DIEGO.
WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
PROFESSIONALISM PANEL CONTROL
OFFICERS IS LONG OVERDUE.
A WORD I HATE TO SPEAK BUT THE
DOG CATCHER DAYS ARE LONG GONE --
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICER STATEWIDE
INVESTIGATE A MULTITUDE OF
ANIMAL WARDENS VIOLATIONS AND
CRIMES AND LONG SIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HEY CIOS INVESTIGATE ANIMAL
FIGHTING RINGS.
PREPARE AND EXECUTE SEARCH
WARRANTS FOR ANIMAL ABUSE
INVESTIGATIONS AND SEES
DANGEROUS DOGS AS WELL AS ISSUE
CITATIONS.
CURRENTLY HUMANE OFFICERS ARE
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH EXTENSIVE
TRAINING SPONSORED BY COUNTING
MILES BUT ARE A CEOS AND NOT
CALIFORNIA IS THE LEADER IN
ANIMAL WELFARE.
AND I WAS SURPRISED WHEN I MOVED
HERE FROM THE EAST COAST ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS AGO TODAY CIOS
DIDN'T HAVE A PATH FOR TRAINING
AS OTHER SOUTHEASTERN STATES DID.
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICERS ARE
PROFESSIONALS PLEASE GIVE THEM A
PATH TO BE CERTIFIED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHERILUS
BUT ESPINOZA HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE RIGHT SEEING NINE I HAVE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR WHICH TO
ASK FOR A ANY.
YEAH NO NO WORRIES I JUST DON'T
THERE'S NO IN HORSESHOE -- IT.
QUESTION BUT I THINK OR MAKE A
MOTION -- BUT WE WILL GET THEM
AND MY RECOMMENDATION ON THE
BILL WAS -- SUPPORT TO AND IT
WOULD IN THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
YOU PASS TO BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
SO I'M GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE I REQUEST IN WRITING TO
GET AIR SUPPORT EXPLOSION OF
JUST WATCH THE HEARING TODAY.
SINCERELY BUT I KNOW YOU HAD
SEVERAL GOOD CONVERSATION.
IT'S ALL GOOD WELL I APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION.
AND I KNOW THAT THE STAFF OF MY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE EITHER IN
OTHER COMMITTEES OR STILL AM
SPRING FINISHING OUR CAUCUS
DISCUSSION.
ARE MONITORING SO THAT THEY CAN
UPDATE BUT THERE MEMBERS -- BUT
I'M SURE AS SOON AS I GET SOME
MEMBERS BACK IT WILL BE A MOTION
ON YOUR BILL.
OKAY THANK CHAIRMAN SPENDING SO
MUCH AND WILL GO TO YOU ALL TO
THE NEXT ITEM.
WHICH IS ITEM FOR A. B. SIX OH
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
.
GOODAFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB.
SIX OH SEVEN A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT TO REFORM TO WORK KERN
SENTENCING AND ADDITIONAL
PRACTICES. FOR CERTAIN NON
SERIOUS AND NON VIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
JUDGES.
TO EVALUATE ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE AND
APPLY THEIR DISCRETION IN
SENTENCING.
INSTEAD JUDGES ARE FORCED TO
SHARE AND IN CARS TO CHARGE AND
INCARCERATE PEOPLE.
WHO WOULD BE BETTER TREATED
UNSUPERVISED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES UNDER PROBATION?
SB SIX OR SEVEN ALLOWS JUDGES TO
USED TO THEIR DISCRETION TO
ORDER PROBATION SERVICES FOR
OFFENSES THAT CURRENTLY MANDATE
INCARCERATION IN COUNTY JAILS OR
STATE PRISONS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
SENTENCING STRUCTURE OR AFFECT
MAXIMUM SENTENCES.
UNDER AB SIX OH SEVEN JUDGES
WILL STILL CHOOSE TO CAN'T MAY
STILL CHOOSE TO SEND INDIVIDUALS
TO PRISON OR JAIL.
BUT ALLOWS A JUDGE TO WEIGH THE
FACTS AND USE OTHER AVENUES TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE.
BEIJING PROVIDE SERVICES SUCH AS
EFFECTIVE DRUG TREATMENTS THAT
MAY NOT.
COUNTY JAILS JUST LAST YEAR
CONGRESS PASSED AND THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE FIRST STEP
BACK.
INCLUDING AN EXPANSION OF COURT
DISCRETION FROM MANDATORY
MINIMUMS.
AND A REDUCTION IN SENTENCES FOR
DRUG OFFENSES AB SIX OF SEVEN IS
CONTINUING THE NATIONAL
DISCUSSION.
AROUND JUDICIAL INDEPENDENCE
OVER SENTENCING AND MASS
INCARCERATION I'LL LET MY
WITNESSES HERE IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU WHICHEVER. ONE OF YOU
WANT TO START GO AHEAD
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS HARLON GROSSMAN I'M A
RETIRED JUDGE FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
I RETIRED SEVEN YEARS AGO AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF JUDICIAL
SERVICE.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR NINE
YEARS BEFORE I BECAME A JUDGE.
MY RETIREMENT COINCIDED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ONE OH NINE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT.
SINCE RETIRING I'VE BEEN ACTIVE
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICY
ADVOCACY.
I'M PRESENT THE SAP.
KATE IN FAVOR OF AB SIX OR SEVEN
WHICH WOULD REPEAL THE PROBATION
AN ELIGIBILITY.
AND THE BARD A SUSPENSION OF
SENTENCES PROVISIONS FOR CERTAIN
CERTAIN ENUMERATED NON VIOLENT
DRUG OFFENSES.
THEREBY RESTORING JUDICIAL
DISCRETION TO IMPOSE APPROPRIATE
SENSES.
TAILORED TO THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH DEFENDANT
THAT COMES BEFORE THE COURT.
RESTRICTIONS ON JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN SENTENCING DO NOT
SERVE AS A DETERRENT TO CRIME.
RATHER THEY ONLY SERVE TO LIMIT
THE DISCRETION AND TIE THE HANDS
OF JUDGES.
INVOLVED IN THE ADJUDICATION
DISPOSITION AND RESOLUTION OF
THESE CASES.
IT MAKES LITTLE SENSE TO LIMIT
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN THE SUN
SEEN OF THESE MATTERS WHEN
JUDGES RETAIN AN EXERCISE THEIR
DISCRETION.
I'M MUCH WEIGHTIER ISSUES SUCH
AS WHETHER TO IMPOSE THE DEATH
PENALTY WHETHER TO STRIKE A
STRIKE CONVICTION.
WHETHER CASE SHOULD PROCEED IN
JUVENILE COURT RATHER THAN
CRIMINAL OR ADULT.
WHEN IT COMES TO SENTENCING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT HAVE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH?
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES ARE
NOT EFFECTIVE IN ANYWAY
INCLUDING AN INCLUDING NOT BEING
COST EFFECTIVE.
AN ACTING AB SIX OH SEVEN WILL
PERMIT MORE EFFECTIVE.
DEFENDANT BASED SENTENCING AND A
PERMIT MORE EFFICIENT USE OF
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RESOURCES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL
FORMER PUBLIC DEFENDER OF SOLANO
COUNTY AND I HAVE BEEN REALLY
FORTY YEARS -- IN THE PRACTICING
INDIGENT DEFENSE.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
FOR C. PDA.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW BUT NOT
REQUIRE THE COURT TO GIVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S CURRENTLY AN
ELIGIBLE UNDER THE LAW.
PROBATION.
THIS WOULD OFFER HOPE TO THOSE
SUFFERING FROM DRUG ADDICTION
WHILE PROTECTING THE COMMUNITY
AND SAVING MONEY.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE REPRESENTED
COUNTLESS CLIENTS WHO WERE DRUG
ADDICTED AND SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN SENTENCED TO PRISON WITHOUT
A CHANCE TO GET CLEAN AND SOBER.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A WOMAN
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CALL AMY.
WHEN AMY WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD
SHE HAD HER FIRST EXPERIENCES
WITH HEROIN INJECTION?
SHE HAD TO INJECT HER OWN MOTHER
WITH CARE WHEN HER MOTHER'S
VEINS OF COLLAPSE DUE TO HEROIN
INJECT ADDICTION.
AND AMY HAD TO INJECT HER MOTHER
IN THE GROWING.
I WANT YOU TO PAUSE AND CONSIDER
THINKING OF YOURSELF AT AGE
TWELVE OR YOUR CHILDREN.
AT AGE TWELVE SUFFERING SUCH A
TRAUMA.
AMY WHEN SHE CAME TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF FORTY YEARS OF AGE.
THREE OF DRUG ADDICTION AND DRUG
CONVICTIONS THE JUDGE AGREED
THAT SHE SHOULD BE IN
REHABILITATION.
AMY WAS MOTIVATED TO GO AND
TRULY WORK TO FREE YOURSELF OF
THE ADDICTION.
OF THE LAW IN ITS CURRENT STATE
DOESN'T ALLOW THIS.
AMY MUST GO TO PRISON.
PRISON COST THE TAXPAYERS ABOUT
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR NOW.
IF WE KEPT TO AMY'S OUT OF
PRISON WE COULD SEND A YOUNG
PERSON TO COLLEGE FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND A DEGREE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
NEXT WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK IS FOR THE CO
SPONSORED DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
HAPPY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FOR THE BILL I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL.
IT A KIND OF LOOKS LIKE A BILL I
CARRIED LAST YEAR WHICH WAS THE
MIGHT I AM OPTIMISTIC WOULD HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL JUST HIT A LOW --
WHAT A TIME LINE SNACKS SO
ANYWAY?
I'M SO I'M HOPING THAT THIS.
ONE THAT. TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THERE IS
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS THAT MANDATORY
MINIMUMS FOR DRUG OFFENSES NEED
TO BE REPEALED AND GREATLY
AMENDED.
NIGHT OF I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
SENATE AND I LOOK FORWARD -- TO
THIS BILL GET INTO THAT THE
FINISH LINE WITH YOUR SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST LEVEL.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT SO THE MOTION.
IS DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER HI.
HI MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
YOUR BILLS ON CALL OUR MEMBERS
TO COME BACK SO.
OKAY -- WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
BILL WHICH IS -- I BELIEVE MISS
RUTH.
SALAS YOU'VE GOT HERE I MEAN YOU
US STUCK IN.
ANYWAY.
PLEASE COME UP IT IS YOUR TURN.
YOU ARE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB.
TWELVE NINETY SIX THANK WELL
MADAM CHAIR.
I WILL BE RIGHT BACK AND GIVEN
THE GAVEL HONEST BRED FOR I WILL
BE RIGHT BACK [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
SHARE.
IF YOU WANT ME SHARE MY CALAMARI
WITH YOU AGAIN THEY'RE VERY NICE
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY SIX
WOULD ESTABLISH THE TAX RECOVERY
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY --
CRIME ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF COMBAT IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
EVERY DAY THE UNDERGROUND COMIC
TAKES A TOLL IN SOME THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY
WORKERS ARE OFTEN SUBJECT TO LOW
WAGES AND LACK BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS CONSUMERS
EXPOSED TO DANGEROUS PRODUCTS
THAT ARE.
BE HARMFUL TO THE HEALTH OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
BUSINESS IS AN ATTEMPT TO PLAY
BY THE RULES ARE UNDER CUT AND
PUT AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE AND LTIMATELY
TAXPAYERS ARE LEFT SUBSIDIZING
ILLEGAL EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES
THAT FAILED TO PROVIDE BASIC
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS.
AB TWENTY SIX WOULD STRENGTHEN
STATE EFFORTS TO COMBAT COMBAT
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY BY STAB
MACHINE A MULTI AGENCY
COLLABORATION LED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THROUGH
MULTI AGENCY APPROACH OUR STATE
AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO PULL
RESOURCES.
USE THE RESPECTIVE EXPERTISE TO
PROSECUTE THOSE THAT PREY ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS IN AVOID
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE INTACT.
I HAVE -- THE WITNESS WITH ME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
RIGHT AFTER YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MARIO DIBERNARDO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HEALTHCARE BUT SERRA WHO'S.
VERY PLATT PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THE BILL.
CODIFIES AND STRENGTHENS A MULTI
AGENCY COLLABORATION THAT IS
FOCUSED ON CRACKING DOWN ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY FROM A TAX
PERSPECTIVE.
AM RATHER THAN.
DOJ AND THE TAXING AGENCIES
WORKING IN THEIR OWN SILOS TO
CRACK DOWN ON UNDERGROUND
ECONOMIC CRIMES.
THEY WORK TOGETHER THE POOL
THEIR RESOURCES THEY ACT OUT
WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
TO FILE CRIMINAL COMPLAINTS
AGAINST AGREE JUST TELLING LEVEL
CRIMES.
THIS PROVIDES BENEFITS TO
BUSINESSES AS A CREATES -- EVIL
EVEN PLAYING FIELD OUR PROVIDES
PROTECTIONS TO LABOR -- WHO
EXPERIENCE ENVIRONMENT ARE I'M
SORRY -- EMPLOYMENT AND CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS THROUGH THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND PROVIDES
PROTECTION TO CONSUMERS.
WHERE ARE THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY HAS COUNTERFEIT PRODUCTS
ARE OFTEN HARMFUL?
AND IT BRINGS SIGNIFICANCE TAX
REVENUE BACK TO THE STATE
BECAUSE THIS ONE OF THE MOST
UNIQUE THINGS ABOUT THIS PROGRAM.
I FOCUSES ON THE TAX RECOVERY
SIDE.
AND IS A NAP REVENUE GENERATOR
FOR THE STATE -- IT'S BEEN
FORMALLY RECOGNIZED BY THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR NEWSOME NOW GOVERNOR
NEWSOME.
AND THE LITTLE WHO WERE CONNECT
COMMISSION HAS RECOMMENDED THE
OF THE PROGRAM AS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICROBES IN HERE I'M A I'M HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA STAFF -- FASHIONS
WE GET A LETTER IN ON TIME AND
WERE IN SUPPORT OF DOGS WHEN IT
I LIKE THE FACT THAT AN OF THE
SOMEONE POINT OUT THE INNER AND
CONNIE HURTS BUSINESSES IN THAT
THE STAFFING INDUSTRY IS IS
THERE'S MEMBERS OF THE STAFF THE
CALIFORNIA STAFF OFFICIALS WHO.
WHO OPERATE IN A IN A LEGITIMATE
LAW ABIDING MANNER THEY'RE
COMPETING AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
PEOPLE AGAINST PEOPLE AND I'M
LEVEL LET PLAYING FIELD AND ALL
ALL THAT DOES IS CHEAP THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WAGES AND CHEAP
THESE BUSINESSES OUT OF?
OUT OF BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THEN VOTE EVENTUALLY --
ULTIMATELY CHEAP THE EMPLOYEES
OUT OF OUT OF FAIR WAGES WORKERS
COMP PROTECTION ESPECIALLY
WORKERS COMP PROTECTIONS AND SO.
ANYTHING THAT MULTI
COLLABORATIVE AGENCIES CAN DO TO
COMBAT THIS -- TO ARE THE
COMPANIES IN OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATION REACH OUT TO THE
PART INSURANCE THEY REACH OUT TO
LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THEY
REACHED OUT TO THE AG YOU YOU
KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE BETTER
ENFORCEMENT AND PUSH IT THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS ON THIS THANKS.
THANK YOU TO ADDRESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE TONY HAD
AROUND WITH THE CITY COUNCIL
LABORS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SIR BRADFORD MIKE MONEY GONNA BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL WORKERS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
COUNCIL OF WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL ON CHEAP METAL WORKERS
IN THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
POPULAR DISTRICT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THREE NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO NOT BRING IT BACK.
TO COMMITTEE I ANNE ARCHER
WOMEN'S ROCK.
I WILL NOW MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE MOTION ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
LAST WHEN I'M OUT.
GREAT.
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
GOVERN FINANCE.
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER HI THERE I'M MORE LOCKED.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE [inaudible]
I WIENER.
WE'LL KEEP AN EYE CALL.
IN THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTING.
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO MS
FRIEDMAN.
THE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FORTINO.
SEVEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
CLOSE DRIVING AND STREET RACING
ARE HUGE ISSUE ACROSS THE STATE.
IN LOS ANGELES -- WHERE I AM
HONORED TO REPRESENT A LARGE
GROUP OF PEOPLE WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING DEATHS FROM STREET RACING
ON AN INCREASING AN ON GOING
BASIS?
AND RECKLESS DRIVING IS ONE OF
THE TOP CONCERNS OF MY DISTRICT --
PEOPLE TALK TO ME ABOUT WHAT
THEY SEE CONSTANTLY.
NOW WE KNOW THAT ANYBODY CAN
MAKE A MISTAKE ONCE.
BUT IF YOU ARE DRIVING WITH SUCH
AND WANTON DISREGARD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY AND WELL BEING THERE HAS
TO BE A REPORT -- RECKLESS
DRIVING TO REMIND ALL OF YOU I
AND ANYONE WATCHING IS NOT JUST
ROLLING A STOP SIGN IT'S NOT
MAKING A RIGHT TURN.
ON A RED TO QUICKLY RECKLESS
DRIVING IS A CRIMINAL OFFENSE TO
MISDEMEANOR.
AND IT IS DRIVING WITH SUCH AN
EGREGIOUS LACK OF RESPECT FOR
OTHER PEOPLE ON THE ROAD THAT
YOU WERE CREATING.
THE HAZARD.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT WAS
DEVELOPED WITH THE CONSULTATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO SAYS
THAT THE FINES THAT ARE ON THE
BOOKS AND THE PENALTIES ARE NOT
TO TURN PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING
MONEY?
STREET RACING.
WHAT DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO
FOLKS IS HAVING THEIR CAR TAKEN
AWAY FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME?
AND ALSO RIGHT NOW IN THE LAW
THERE'S NOTHING THAT REQUIRES
LEGAL MODIFICATIONS THAT ARE
MADE TO SEE STREET RACING
VEHICLES TO BE REMOVED PRIOR TO
THAT CAR BEING RELEASED FROM
IMPOUND.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT SAYS
THAT ON YOUR SECOND CONVICTION
FOR STREET RACING OR RECKLESS
DRIVING YOUR CAR WILL BE
IMPOUNDED FOR THIRTY DAYS NOW
THERE ARE A LOT OF OFF RAMPS?
IN THE CASE OF HARDSHIP IF THE
CASE THAT IT'S A A CHILD WHO
BORROWED THE CAR BUT THEY'RE NOT
THE PRIMARY USER IF YOU NEED THE
VEHICLE TO GET TO A JOB THERE'S
A LOT OF OFF RAMPS TO MAKE THIS
DURABLE AND NOT OVERLY.
PUNITIVE.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WHOSE LIVES ARE PUT AT
RISK AND SOMETIMES TAKEN BECAUSE
OF RECKLESS DRIVERS AND SERIAL
RECKLESS DRIVERS.
THEY ALSO HAVE A RIGHT TO SAFE
STREETS THEY ALSO HAVE A RIGHT
TO NOT BE MOWED DOWN IN A
CROSSWALK OR IN A SIDE IN THE
SIDEWALK.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN LOS
ANGELES HAS NOT BEEN WORKING
WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE IN THESE
TYPE OF EVENTS UNFORTUNATELY?
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL IS A
SENSIBLE AND BALANCED A SOLUTION.
I'M I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
ANYBODY HERE. TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THIS BOY.
ANYBODY HERE WHO IS THE WITNESS
NO WE HAVE NO WITNESSES BUT I
WILL SAY THAT I'M THIS BILL GOT
OUT I THINK.
PRETTY MUCH UNANIMOUSLY -- LAST
YEAR I IT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR -- AND WE WOULD RESPECT
OF RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONCE
AGAIN THAT YOU ON A SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
SORRY WITNESS GO AHEAD YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE FOR
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH REGARD TO IMPOUNDMENT THIS
BILL DOES ONE THING.
IT DENIES JUDGES THE OPPORTUNITY
TO USE THEIR DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH
OF TIME OF IMPOUNDMENT.
CURRENT LAW IN ALLOWS
IMPOUNDMENT OF THE VEHICLE USED
IN RECKLESS DRIVING OR IN A
SPEED CONTEST FOR A PERIOD OF UP
TO THIRTY DAYS.
AB FORTINO SEVEN NEEDLESSLY
REMOVES THE COURT'S DISCRETION
TO DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
PERIOD OF EMPOWERMENT AND WOULD
INSTEAD REQUIRE IMPOUNDMENT
BIRTH FULL THIRTY DAYS.
OR ANY SECOND OFFENSE OF
RECKLESS DRIVING OR STREET
RACING.
EMPOWERMENT OF THE VEHICLE
PARTICULARLY FOR A PERIOD AS
LONG AS THIRTY DAYS ALL TOO
OFTEN BECOMES A DE FACTO
FORFEITURE.
AS MANY DEFENDANTS ARE UNABLE TO
PAY THE LARGE STORAGE FEES
CHARGED WHEN A VEHICLE IS HELD
FOR THAT LONG.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
PUBLISHED A REPORT ENTITLED
TOWED INTO DEBT.
ON THE DEVASTATING EFFECT TO THE
VEHICLE PUT TOES AND IMPOUNDS
CAN HAVE ON INDIVIDUALS.
THAT REPORT FOUND THAT THE
AVERAGE STORAGE FEE IS FIFTY
THREE DOLLARS PER DAY.
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE AND TOWING
FEES THIS MEANS THE TOTAL COST
OF A THIRTY DAY IMPOUNDMENT WILL
BE ON AVERAGE ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE DOLLARS.
AN AMOUNT MANY DEFENDANTS SIMPLY
WON'T BE ABLE TO PAY. FOR MANY
OR MOST OF THOSE SUBJECT TO THE
MANDATORY THIRTY DAY IMPOUNDMENT
THE RESULT WILL BE THE LOSS OF
THEIR CAR.
LOSS OF THE OF THE VEHICLE
WEATHER FOR THIRTY DAYS OR AS
THE CASE MAY WELL BE PERMANENTLY.
CAN RESULT IN THE DEFENDANT
LOSING A JOB OR BEING UNABLE TO
FULFIL FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES.
WELL THE JUDGE ALLOWS THE IT
WHILE THE BILL ALLOWS THE JUDGE
SOME DISCRETION WHEN IMPOUNDMENT
WILL RESULT IN HARDSHIP FOR THE
FAMILY IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
JUDGE TO CONSIDER HARDSHIP TO
THE DEFENDANT ON OR WHETHER THE
DEFENDANT WILL BE ABLE.
TO WHAT BOARD TO GET THE CAR
BACK AFTER THIRTY DAY
IMPOUNDMENT.
JUDGES SHOULD RETAIN WRIST
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE PENALTY IN EACH CASE
INCLUDING WHETHER AND FOR HOW
LONG TO IMPOUND THE VEHICLE.
UP TO THIRTY DAYS.
THE RIGHT CHANNEL.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOTE.
I DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
REAL SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
RIGHT WE HAVE A COMMON SERVER --
CONCERNS QUESTIONS BY OUR GO
AHEAD SENATOR RIGHT YOU CAN
MANAGE YOUR AN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR -- I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THE CHALLENGES OF STREET
RACING IN AN EXHIBITION OF SPEED
AND AND WE TURN ON THE TV OPEN
UP THE NEWSPAPER ALMOST ON A
WEEKLY BASIS WHERE WE SEE
SOMEONE.
THAT WAS STRUCK BY A CAR I THINK
JUST LAST WEEK IN LOS ANGELES A
NINETY TWO YEAR OLD INDIVIDUAL.
WAS STRUCK AND KILLED BUT I
GUESS MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT
THE THE THE LAW ALREADY PERMITS
FOR THE EMPOWERMENT OF THE BILL
VEHICLES SO.
WEISS IS MAJOR NECESSARY THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR I'M
WE HAVE -- IT DONE RESEARCH AND
BILL THIS THAT PENALTY IS ALMOST
NEVER GIVEN.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING AND SAID AS
WERE CUT WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE
GUIDANCE THE JUDGES SAYING THAT
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE RESPONSE
AND IF THERE IS AN ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP.
IF THERE ARE HARD HARDSHIPS THEY
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO REDUCE
THE IN HOME IN ORDER TO WEIGH
THE COMPLETELY SO WE'RE STILL
GIVING THEM QUITE A LOT OF
DISCRETION.
AND AS MUCH AS I HATE TO
DISAGREE WITH MY FRIENDS OF THE
SEAL YOU BECAUSE I TEND TO BE ON
THEIR SIDE ALMOST ALL THE TIME.
I ALSO.
THINK THAT SOMEBODY WHO'S
COMMITTED THIS OF TWICE.
NEEDS SOME TYPE OF SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT BEING DONE NOW UNDER
THE LAW.
AND I BELIEVE ALSO THAT
PEDESTRIANS IN LOS ANGELES AND
CYCLISTS HAVE RIGHTS.
TO AND WE ARE AND DRIVING IS A
PRIVILEGE IT'S NOT A RIGHT.
AND IF YOU'RE DRIVING A CAR
RECKLESSLY TO THE EXTENT TO
WHERE IT'S A CRIMINAL.
CONVICTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOT JUST YOUR A SLOPPY DRIVER
BUT YOU'RE ACTUALLY ACTING IN A
CRIMINAL NATURE AND YOU DO IT
TWICE.
THE NOT PRIVILEGE SHOULD BE
REVOED FOR PURITY OF TIME I
THINK THAT THAT IS IS REASONABLE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU ARE YOU HAVE
TURNED.
THE VEHICLE INTO A WEAPON AT
THAT POINT.
SO I I THINK THAT YOU KNOW GIVEN
THAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
HASN'T BEEN WORKING AND IF YOU
DO KNOW THAT AS YOU JUST POINTED
OUT.
A SO IT'S STILL EARLY WE ARE
SEEING THESE TYPES OF DEATHS
INCREASE.
SO WE DIDN'T WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND WE I'VE
WORKED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THEY SAY LISTEN THIS WHEN
SOMEONE'S MAKING MONEY.
ST EXHIBITIONS WHAT BAKER ABOUT
IS LOSING THAT THAT SOURCE OF
EXTRA INCOME.
AND ALSO HAVING TO REMOVE THOSE
MODIFICATIONS SO I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD GIVE THIS A TRY BECAUSE
I'M AFRAID TO LET MY DAUGHTER
WALKED ON THE STREET RIGHT NOW
IN LOS ANGELES.
AND I GET THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE
I TO SEE A I SEE.
LEAVING THE HOUSE IN THE MORNING
WERE FOLKS HAVE DONE DONUTS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE INTERSECTION
AT TWO AM IN THE MORNING AND ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE -- A REAL
HAZARD TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
WHY NOT HAVE SOMEONE?
ARRESTED FOR THIRTY I RATHER SEE
HIM ARRESTED I THINK THAT'S MORE
OF A DETERRENT BECAUSE JUST
BECAUSE YOU AND POUND THE CAR
DOESN'T MEAN THEY WON'T GET
SOMEONE ELSE'S CAR AND AND STILL
DO THE SAME BAD BEHAVIOR.
IF THE ACLU WOULD AGREE TO THAT
YOU KNOW IN MY CONSIDER
REMINDING WELL I I I WOULD
RATHER SEE HIM ARRESTED FOR
THIRTY DAYS IF YOU'VE BEEN
CONVICTED TWICE.
EXHIBITION OF SPEED AND RECKLESS
DRIVING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE A MOTION NOW.
THIS ONE IS.
OKAY EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS
LAST TIME.
SESSION WHEN WE APPROVED IN AND
ARE THEN GOVERNOR HAD VETOED.
ONE THIS BILL ONCE BUT A SIMILAR
BILL THE PREVIOUS TIME SO
THERE'S TWO VETOES ON IT.
AND I FIND IT'S WHAT'S ALSO
RIGHT INTERESTING IS THAT WE'VE
JUST RECENTLY.
I'M PASSED OUT WHAT LEASE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
SOME I AM.
AT LEAST ONE BILL OF NOT MORE
THAN.
ONE AND I THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENT ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THAT WOULD.
I PUT LIMITS ON TOWING.
AND WE'RE RECOGNIZING THAT.
IT'S NOT IN ALL CASES BY ANY
MEANS BUT THAT.
YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE YOUR
BILL TOWED IF YOU'RE LOW INCOME.
THERE'S CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS
YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE YOU
KNOW A BILL OF VEHICLE IMPOUNDED.
OR TOWED [inaudible]
AND AND THEN.
THE THE IMPACT IS THAT MUCH MORE
SEVERE.
BECAUSE OF THE COST TO THE
INDIVIDUAL.
BECAUSE OF THEIR POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON THEIR ABILITY TO GO TO
WORK IN SUCH.
WERE.
THE CARS THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
SO THESE ARE TRICKY SO I I
UNDERSTAND YOUR OBJECTIVES.
AND I DID SUPPORT THE BILL LAST
YEAR -- AT VARIETY.
IT.
IT'S THE I'M NOT SURE IT'LL BE A
DETERRENT.
I'M IN FACT I'M PRETTY POSITIVE
IT'S NOT GONNA BE A DETERRENT
NOW.
WHETHER IT.
IT WOULD TEMPORARILY STOPPED.
IF THE FOR THOSE WHO GET
IMPOUNDED YEAH WOULD TEMPORARILY
STOP THEM FROM WHATEVER THEY'RE
ENGAGED IN.
WHETHER IT OVERALL STOP THE
DANGEROUS TO RECKLESS DRIVING SO
THESE ARE THE TRICKY THINGS AND
I I WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
IMPOSING A MEMBER RIGHT NOW BUT
I THINK.
IT'S WORTH CONSIDERING WHETHER
IT'S THE HIGHER NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS TO BE A REQUIRED
IMPOUNDMENT OF THIRTY DAYS AND I
THINK THERE'S SOME THINGS WORTH
CONSIDERING. TO BALANCE THE
OBJECTIVE YOU HAVE IN.
THE KNOWING WHO IS LIKELY.
TO BE IMPACTED BY IT.
BUT GO AHEAD ALL TO SAY THAT.
ONE OF THE REASONS DEVELOP THE
BILL THE WE DID WE WE DID
BECAUSE IN MY DISTRICT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING A LOT OF
THESE HIGH FINES ARE ACTUALLY
NOT LOW INCOME PEOPLE THEIR HIGH
INCOME PEOPLE.
THERE ARE THE CHILDREN OF HIGH
INCOME PEOPLE AND WHAT THE
POLICE WERE COMPLAINING ABOUT IS
THAT THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM PAYING
THE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THEY'RE GIVING
THE SAME FINE TO THE SAME YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE COMMITTING A LOT OF
THESE OFFENSES AND THERE ARE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
DISPOSABLE WELL?
THEY'RE ABLE TO PAY IT.
I'M SO IT'S SIR IT'S A AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO ARGUE THAT THERE
AREN'T DISPROPORTIONAL THESE OF
OF PENALTIES IN A LOT OF PLACES.
MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
ISSUE AND IN MY DISTRICT HAS
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF THE
OPPOSITE WE DEVELOP THIS BECAUSE
WE'VE.
THE MONETARY FINE WAS NOT REALLY
AFFECTING THIS GROUP OF A
POPULATION OF IS COMMITTING A
LOT OF THIS PARTICULAR CRIME BUT
THE TAKING THE CAR AWAY WAS A
VERY BIG DISINCENTIVE FOR THEM.
BECAUSE THAT CAR IS IS A STATUS
SYMBOL IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO THEM AND ALSO THE ABILITY
THAT FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME. TO
HAVE  LEGAL MODIFICATIONS HAVE
TO BE REMOVED BEFORE THE CAR
COMES BACK THAT DOESN'T EXIST
ANYWHERE NOW IN LAW.
SO IN TERMS OF THE STREET RACING
VEHICLES THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU'RE TAKING A VEHICLE
THAT'S BEEN TRICKED OUT TO GO
THREE HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR
WHATEVER THEY DO.
AND YOU'RE HAVING IT TURN BACK
INTO A CAR THAT'S JUST A NORMAL
CAR.
SO THIS I THINK THAT IT'S WORTH
TRYING THIS BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE TO WHOM THE FINE DOESN'T
MATTER AND BECAUSE THE BILL
STILL HAS THAT OUT FOR PEOPLE TO
WHERE IT'S A HARDSHIP.
ON I THINK THAT.
IN SOME WAYS I'D SAY THAT THIS
IS FLIPPING THAT AROUND AND
GETTING PEOPLE.
I'M IN A DIFFERENT WAY TO YOU
KNOW DO YOU HAVE THE PRESSURE
POINT OF MAYBE NOT ENGAGING IN
THIS BEHAVIOR IF THEY THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THE
VEHICLE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM
EVEN FOR A SMALL AMOUNT OF TIME
[inaudible]
SURE.
HE WON A CLOSE SOURCE THAT IS
YOUR CLOTHES.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW I
VOTED FOR THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE TOWING
BILL BECAUSE TO ME THAT THIS NO
IT'S PUNITIVE FOR SOMEONE WHO'S
JUST NOT PAYING THE BILL.
INCREASE THAT DEBT BUT AGAIN
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE TAKING
SOMETHING THAT WHICH IS A
PRIVILEGE WHICH IS DRIVING.
AND NOT JUST ONCE BUT TWICE NOW --
DRIVING IN A WAY THAT IS TURNING
THAT VEHICLE INTO A WEAPON AND
WE DO NEED TO USE ALL THOSE
TOOLS BECAUSE THE SAFETY OF
PEDESTRIANS AND CYCLISTS HAS TO
COME FIRST AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN
DOING THAT IN CURRENT LAW WE'RE
NOT MAKING IT.
WE'RE NOT BEING SERIOUS ENOUGH.
A TO MAKE IT.
OUT TO MAKE THAT PRIORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST WALKING DOWN
THE STREET AND BECAUSE IT'S THE
SECOND CONVICT I FEEL LIKE YOU
JUST NEED TO BE ABLE TO SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE.
SO SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THE
SENATORS IDEA OF INCARCERATING
TO FOLKS AND THIS YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT THE SAW.
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
DO FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
I'M LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
QUESTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
HI.
I'M MORE LIKE [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACK BEEN.
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
I WIENER.
ARE YOUR BILLS ON CALL
[inaudible]
GIVEN THE WE'LL SEE THOSE APPS
OF MEN MEMBERS AT SOME POINT.
OKAY.
I SEE THAT WE'VE GOT OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW HERE.
WE WELCOME YOU.
AND THIS IS ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN OR WHAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME PERCENT A. B.
FIFTEEN A ONE WHICH YOU SAW THIS
LAST YEAR AND RECEIVE BIPARTISAN
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AGAIN THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN SOLVE APPROPRIATE -- FIRE
ARM.
CIRCUMSTANCES IT USING FAR ARMS
IN CASES OF CONNECTIVE ITTY
UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY AND RESPECT
THE ASCARI VOTE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT ALSO IS REPRESENTED FROM
OUR OWN COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
DISCOUNT GREAT BEFORE OUR
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
SINCE YOU MENTIONED THAT A BILL
WOULD ALREADY GONE THROUGH THAT
WE ALL SUPPORTED.
COULD YOU JUST QUICKLY DESCRIBE
SINCE IT WE HAVE BEEN -- HAD
BILLS BEFORE IS THAT WE ALSO
HAVE TEAMED BEFORE DID I THINK
THERE IS A CHANGE.
IN THIS ONE COMPARED TO THE BILL
THAT WAS BEFORE US LAST YEAR.
YOU BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THAT YES --
THE BILL THAT WE HAVE A FORCE IS --
HELPING THE BEEN THE UTILIZATION
OF NINE BEEN THAT TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE AN
EXISTENCE -- BUT WE DO NOT HAVE
A STANDARD FOR YEARS YEAH
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO UTILIZED AND LO
THESE BALLISTICS IMAGES -- YOU
WHEN USED IN CASES OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY WE HAVE COUNTIES --
SIMILAR TO SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THAT HAVE UTILIZED THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAVE SOLVED
SIGNIFICANT A CRIMES BECAUSE OF
THIS.
AND SO THIS IS WHAT WE HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH -- THIS WAS -- THIS
WAS HELD IN THAT SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS TO THE FISCAL
COST -- BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE ON THIS EFFORT
AND ADDRESS THESE.
OUTSTANDING ISSUES A MOVING
FORWARD -- SO AGAIN THIS IS A
VERY THIS YEAR WE HAD CONRAD IS
THAT YOU WERE THAT THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES COULD
CONTRACT WITH OTHER.
OF COURSE YES ON BECAUSE OF THE
FISCAL COSTS DOWN ON THE MANDATE
SO WE WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY -- FOR LOCALITIES TO
A STILL UTILIZE THAT
TECHNOLOGIES BUT IN A MANNER
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THEM.
GREAT THAT'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS YEAR'S YES TO MAKE
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION OKAY.
SO YES PLEASE WITNESS PERCY.
MARIA SOME ACCOUNT FROM THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND IN MY
CURRENT ASSIGNMENT I OVERSEE OUR
COUNTIES CRIME STRATEGIES UNIT
IN ASSOCIATION WITH OUR LOCAL.
POLICE AGENCIES AND I RUN A
LARGE CRIME THAT INTELLIGENCE
CENTER REALLY THE BECAUSE OF OUR
COUNTIES EFFORT IS A REDUCTION
IN GUN VIOLENCE THAT IS EVIDENCE
BASED.
USING A PROVEN METHOD THAT IS A
NATIONAL DATABASE OF BALLISTIC
IMAGES.
THIS EVEN THE OPPONENTS TO THIS
BILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT COMPARES
EXPENDED SHELL CASINGS FROM
SHOOTINGS WORKS IT SOLVES
DRAMATIC CRIMES IN OUR
JURISDICTION WE MOVED TO A
UNIVERSAL USE OF THIS TOOL IT
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF NINE IN
LEEDS AND HAD.
GOT INCLUDING SOLVING NINE
MURDERS IN A SINGLE YEAR WHICH
FOR OUR JURISDICTION IS A LOT WE
ONLY ABOUT THIRTY MURDERS A YEAR.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
BUT SINCE I CAME HERE LAST YEAR
I THINK ONE OF THE CRITICISMS OF
THE BILL LAST YEAR -- WAS TO
REALLY TWO FOLD ONE WAS THE FACT
THAT IT'S A MANDATE AND THE
SECOND WAS THE FACT THAT IT'S
COSTLY -- IT IS OUR POSITION
THAT -- TO TO URBAN CENTERS WHO
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING DAILY TRAGEDY AND
BLOOD SHED AT THE HANDS OF GUNS
IT IS WELL WORTH THE EXPENDITURE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN AUGMENT
AND UNIVERSALLY SUBMIT THIS
EVIDENCE.
AND IS WELL WORTH THE COST I
THINK THAT WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BILL IS IT
PRINT BRINGS THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
OUR SMALL OR RURAL AREAS THAT
MAY NOT IMMEDIATELY HAVE ACCESS.
TO A LOCAL LAB SO REALLY --
BUTTRESSES THE ABILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO PROVIDE
THIS TO OUR NON URBAN CENTERS
BUT IN OUR LARGEST POPULATION
BASES THERE ARE ALREADY USING
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
ISSUES ARE NOT USING IT
UNIVERSALLY IS THE REASON IT'S A
MANDATE IS BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
MAKE THEM DO IT.
THEY WON'T.
AND SO SINCE I CAME HERE LAST
YEAR AND TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
BODY WE'VE HAD TWO MURDERS WHERE
IT LITERALLY ARMOR WEAPON WAS
SITTING ON TESTED ON A SHELF.
AND WE FOUND IT AND WE GOT IT
TESTED THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS DON'T HAVE
THE SAME URGENCY WITH A
RECOVERED WEAPON.
AS YOU DO IN YOUR MURDER
INVESTIGATION THAT'S WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR IT TO BE A MANDATORY
IS SOLVES CASES IT LITERALLY PUT
SHOOTERS WHO HAVE USED A GUN BY
DEFINITION MORE THAN ONCE BEHIND
BARS AND SOLVE THESE CASES.
IMPORTANTLY -- I THINK IT BRINGS
THIS TECHNOLOGY TO PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT OTHERWISE WOULDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO ITS WITH IT'S
WELL WORTH THE COST OR TO SAVE
THE LIVES.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SO IT SAM SEE IF
THERE'S WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK WE HAVE ENOUGH ROOM AT THE
TABLE YOU WANT TO COME OVER HERE
BECAUSE THE THERE'S A MIKE THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ISHA MUCH THERE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CRIME LAB DIRECTORS.
AS MENTIONED BEFORE AT THIS BILL
DID COME BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN
IN COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
I'LL WELL WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT -- THAT CHANGE IN CURRENT
BILL IS AN IMPROVEMENT UPON LAST
YEAR'S BILL THAT WAS HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
I'M STILL -- AND THIS IS I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS NOT THE
FISCAL COMMITTEE BUT STILL
HAVING TO CONTRACT WITH ANOTHER
JURISDICTION THAT HAS ACCESS TO
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
STILL COSTS MONEY AND THIS IS AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE SO -- BUT WE
OPPOSE ON BACKGROUND BUT ALSO --
ADDRESSING ON THAT -- PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL WE ARE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES GOVERNING
AND THE NATURE IN WHICH LONG
FORSMAN INVESTING INVESTIGATIONS
UNDER OUR UNDERTAKEN.
AND MANY TYPES OF EVIDENCE AND
INFORMATION ARE ROUTINELY
GATHERED IN THE COURSE OF AN
INVESTIGATION.
AND TRADE INVESTIGATOR SHOULD
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO PROCESS
THAT EVIDENCE IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE INDIVIDUAL SITUATION.
AND WITH THE BENEFIT OF
EXPERIENCE EXPERTISE AND
TRAINING THAT IS CORNERSTONE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSION I'M
SO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
SO I EVER.
QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
YOU OPEN THAT IT WAS PRIMARILY
THE COST BUT THEN YOU WENT ON TO
THAT THE REAL IT -- OF REAL.
ADDITIONAL IN SUBSTANTIVE
OBJECTION IS THAT.
BY INDICATING THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SHOULD
UTILIZE THIS TECHNOLOGY BUT I
THINK PRIMARILY WHAT I SEE IS
THE BENEFIT OF THE BILL.
UTILIZING THE NETWORK.
THAT YOU DEBT.
YOUR SHERIFF'S AND THEY CRAM
CRIME LABS OPPOSE.
HAVING A HAVING THE LEGISLATURE
SAY USE THIS NETWORK IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY.
RIGHT I MEAN WE WE WE DON'T WANT
TO TO OBVIOUSLY BE AGAIN IS NOT
A COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH IT
SHOULD NOT BE A MANDATE ALLEGES
AND I LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
TO BE TOLD HOW THEY ARE TO
INVESTIGATE A PARTICULAR CRIME
AND WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL DOES
THAT.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO
MANDATE TO US THAT WE OUGHT TO
DO THIS.
AND THERE'S THAT COST PER HEAD
ON NARAL WERE.
WE CAN DISCUSS RIGHT SO.
I'M.
I HADN'T REALLY.
MADE THIS ANALOGY LAST YEAR AND
BUT IN THE PRESENTATION TODAY.
BUT WELL THESE ARE NOT THE SAME.
ARE CASTING ARE REQUIRING.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
CAST.
THE EVIDENCE FROM THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
TEST THE THAT WHICH THEY GATHER.
AND GETTING IT INTO THE NATIONAL
DATABASE.
WAS GREATLY RESISTED FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND AND WE WERE IS THE
LEGISLATURE TOLL THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE WE DON'T KNOW BEST.
WE DON'T ALWAYS KNOW BEST TRUE
BUT THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
INDICATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOW TO DO THEIR INVESTIGATORY
JOBS AND YET EVERY.
BIT OF RESEARCH AND DATA AND AND
REAL LIFE.
EXPERIENCES SHOW THAT THOSE
AGENCIES THAT FULLY.
TEST ALL OF THEIR SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE.
HAVE A MUCH HIGHER.
ARREST RATE IN CONVICTION RATE.
ON SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SO IF THIS TECHNOLOGY GIVES US
[inaudible]
A CLOSER WHEN IT COMES.
TO GUN VIOLENCE INCIDENTS IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SHOULD WELCOME IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO COME
IN OR NOT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
A ANYWAY.
IS THERE A MOTION OR SHOULD WE
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO
CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO MADAM CHAIR YOU ELOQUENTLY
SUMMARIZE THE IMPORTANT
UTILIZATION OF THIS.
THIS TOOL THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
TO ALL OF US.
AT THE COST WILL DEAL WITH BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST AGAIN WE WILL NOT
REALIZE THE RESULTS IMMEDIATELY
BUT OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
OUT WITH THE INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US.
FAMILIES WILL FIND SOME CLARITY
AS TO HOW WE CAN ADDRESS MANY OF
THESE ISSUES MOVE BOARD AS THEY
ARE INTER CONNECTED.
US SO THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK BACK
[inaudible]
I'M.
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL ON THE
MOTION IT IS.
AB FIFTY NO ONE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ROLL CALL SKINNER
AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BUT I JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
ALL RIGHT SO THE BILLS ON CALL.
AND THE SHEET YOUR PRESENTATION
YOUR RE VISITED AS SOON AS WE
HAVE MEMBERS.
AND WELL LET'S GO TO OUR FINAL
BILL -- ITEM TWENTY AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SO.
OVER 99% OF VEHICLES SOLD IN THE
UNITED STATES CURRENTLY ARE
QUIPPED WITH THE EVENT DATA
RECORDERS.
THESE ARE DEVICES SIMILAR TO THE
BLACK BOX AN AIRCRAFT.
THAT RECORD A NARROW SET OF
PARAMETERS JUST BEFORE AND AFTER
AN ACCIDENT THINGS LIKE THE
POSITION OF THE STEERING WHEEL
THE POSITION OF THE OF THE
ACCELERATOR THE BRAKE PEDAL THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE AIR BAGS AND
THE SEAT BELTS.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THESE.
ITEMS ARE VERY USEFUL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN INVESTIGATING
AN ACCIDENT.
ARE.
THE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
EITHER REQUIRES A COURT ORDER IN
THE CASE OF A FELONY OR INFORMED
CONSENT ON THE A IN THE CASE OF
THE DRIVER HOWEVER LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS FACED WITH AN
OBSTACLE WHEN.
VEHICLES -- ACCIDENTS INCLUDE
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY OR DEATH
THERE'S NO ONE TO GIVE THAT
INFORMED CONSENT.
THIS BILL CREATES A VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED.
AVENUE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
GET ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
BY NARROWLY CRAFTED I MEAN.
A VERY LIMITED WINDOW OF
INFORMATION FIVE SECONDS BEFORE
TO ONE SECOND AFTER AN ACCIDENT.
A VERY NARROW LIMITED OF
PARAMETERS SO THIS ISN'T A
FISHING EXPEDITION TO GO BACK TO
THE HISTORY OF WHERE THE CAR IS
BOUND.
IT'S ONLY WITH THE COURT A COURT
ORDER AND THE PERMISSION OF THE
JUDGE SO THEY HAVE TO CONVINCE
THE COURT THAT THIS IS THE CASE.
NUMBER TODAY I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENT OFFERED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS THAT LIMITS THIS ONLY
TO MISDEMEANOR CASES AND END NOT
INFRACTIONS.
SO I JUST AND IS VERY NARROWLY
LIMITED SERVICE SORT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE GIVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE TOOLS THAT THEY
NEED. TO INVESTIGATE THE CAUSES
OF THESE ACCIDENTS WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
I LIKE.
BOTH TAKE MOTION NUMBER LET'S
SEE.
M. YOU HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
GREAT A TEAR FROM YOUR WHAT.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM SAN DIEGO COUNTY DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JOHN.
I'M HERE ON TODAY ON ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEP AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
FOR OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
I'VE BEEN A DEPUTY DA FOR TWENTY
ONE YEARS I'VE PROSECUTED MANY
VEHICULAR CRIMES INCLUDING
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD BE
A GREAT BENEFIT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
INDICATED AND AND ET OUR AS
OFTEN.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BLACK BOXES
IN THERE THEY'RE NOT THE SAME
BUT THEY WORK THE SAME OVERALL
IN THE CENTER OF PROVIDING
INVESTIGATORS.
WITH TECHNICAL INFORMATION AFTER
CRASH.
INVESTIGATORS CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT.
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO QUIT THEIR VEHICLES BUT MOST
OF THEM DO AN INCREDIBLY LARGE
NUMBER OF DO.
A LARGE NUMBER DO TODAY.
BUT THOSE MANUFACTURERS WHO DO
CHOOSE TO THEIR VEHICLES WITH
DDR ARE REQUIRED BY THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WHICH
STANDARDIZE THE ET ARE AND
STANDARDIZED.
B. E. R. CAPTURES THE TECHNICAL
DATA FOR THE FIVE SECONDS BEFORE
UP TO THE ONE SECOND AFTER THE
CRASH.
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING IF THERE IS
NO CRASH SEVERE ENOUGH TO RESULT
AN AIRBAG DEPLOYMENT OR NEAR
DEPLOYMENT THERE IS NO DATE.
YOU PLUG INTO AN EASY ARE
THERE'S NOTHING THAT.
A TRAINED EXPERT CAN UTILIZE
EQUIPMENT TO PLUG INTO THE
VEHICLE RETRIEVE THE EDR DATA
AND USE IT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE AND WITNESS
STATEMENTS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHY.
ET OURS ARE BY DESIGN ASSOCIATED
WITH VEHICLES AIRBAG SYSTEM AND
THE SEAT BELT PRE TENSIONER PRE
TENSIONERS.
OR SOMETHING USING OUT THERE
WITH SOME PEOPLE ABOUT WITH WHAT
ET OURS AND ET ARE ARE NOT.
ET OURS AS DEFINED.
ARE NOT.
INTO TELEMATICS INFOTAINMENT
EDIE OURS DO NOT HAVE VIDEO
CAMERAS.
AUDIO RECORDERS THEY DON'T TELL
ANYTHING ABOUT IT OFTEN CELL
PHONE USE IN A VEHICLE THINGS
LIKE THAT IT'S TECHNICAL DATA
INVOLVING RASHES.
AIR BAGS AND SEAT BELT PRE
TENSIONER. ONE FOUR MINUTES
PASSED BY LAW WITH CONDUCTING A
THOROUGH PROFESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHENEVER THERE'S A CRASH THEY
RESULT IN DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY TO THE CITIZENS
WHETHER IT'S THE DRIVER WHOSE
OWN FAULT ACOSTA BASH. FOR AN
ISN'T PERCENT.
ROADWAYS TO BE SHUT DOWN FOR
HOURS FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
AND ON LAW ENFORCEMENT GET THE
TRUTH AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
IN THE SERIOUS PRACTICE EDR DATA
IS THE NECESSARY THANKS FOR
LAUNCH.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IMAGINE
THIS SCENARIO WELL OF COURSE
BEEN ARRIVED ON THE SCENE THERE
ARE TWO CARS CRASH.
WHAT APPEARS TO HAVE HAPPENED
BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT SURE
THAT ONE VEHICLE TURN LEFT IN
FRONT OF AN ONCOMING BE A?
BUT THEY'RE NOT SURE THE DRIVER
ONE VEHICLE IS DEAD THE DRIVER
OF THE OTHER VEHICLE IS ON IN
THAT SITUATION LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD NEED AND WANT ET OUR DATA.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEY CANNOT
GET IT.
WITH AB SIXTEEN THIRTY AS
AMENDED THEY COULD SEE.
ORDER ME A SEARCH WARRANT TO GET
INFORMATION THAT IS VITALLY
NEEDED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD STILL NEED
TO BUY WITH HELP WHEN YOU SEE A
LOT.
AND ULTIMATELY A JUDGE WOULD BE
THE ONE THAT SIDE WITH THE
WARRANT SHOULD ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE OUR DATA FROM A FROM A
FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDPOINT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
IS NOT.
CONSIDERED PRIVATE WHEN THINGS
LIKE SPEED BREAKING AND THE
LIGHT AND VEHICLE MOVEMENT ARE
EXPOSED TO THE PUBLIC WHEN
SOMEONE DRIVES ON A ROAD THAT
PERCENT.
OVERSEAS YES.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AT HAND IT'S BREAKS A
REASONABLE BALANCE BETWEEN
STATUTORY PRIVACY CONSIDERATIONS.
AND HOW IMPORTANT INFORMATION IS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO
SOCIETY WHEN SOMEONE IS DEAD OR
SERIOUSLY BODILY INJURED IN A
RACK.
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S ROOM RIGHT THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF DHL YOU OF CALIFORNIA --
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING BE -- SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE INFRACTIONS
FROM THE BILL BUT WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED.
CALIFORNIA LAWN SEARCH WARRANTS
BOUNCES TO IMPORTANT INTERESTS
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BE
PROTECTED FROM UNREASONABLE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT SEARCHES
AND SEIZURES.
AND THE NEED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE ABLE TO INVESTIGATE CRIMES.
ONE WAY THAT OUR LAW DOES THIS
IS BY SETTING A GENERAL RULE
THAT A WARRANT CAN BE SOUGHT
WHEN THE EVIDENCE TO BE SEIZE.
IS EVIDENCE OF A FELONY THERE IS
NO GENERAL PROVISION ALLOWING
ISSUANCE OF A SEARCH WARRANT
WHERE THE THING TO BE SEIZED AS
EVIDENCE OF A LESSER CRIME.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
ALLOW THE ISSUANCE OF A WARRANT
FOR INFORMATION FROM A VEHICLE'S
RECORDING DEVICE THAT
CONSTITUTES EVIDENCE OF ANY.
MISDEMEANOR AS AMENDED INVOLVING
A MOTOR VEHICLE.
ADD CRASH RESULT.
DEATH OR BODILY INJURY.
BY ALLOWING THE INCH ISSUANCE OF
A WARRANT FOR INFORMATION
AVAILABLE FROM A VEHICLE
RECORDING DEVICE FOR NON FELONY
OFFENSE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT A. B.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT UPSETS THE
BALANCE BETWEEN THE INTERESTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND AND THE
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
AND PROTECTING THEIR PRIVACY I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THIS DOES
NOT APPLY ONLY WHERE -- THE
DRIVER IS THAT YOU KNOW DEAD OR
UNCONSCIOUS BUT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
ISSUANCE OF A SEARCH WARRANT TO
GET THAT INFORMATION OR THE
DRIVER SIMPLY DOES NOT WANT.
IT TO BE SHARED -- AND I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING BEING
NECESSARY TO AN INVESTIGATION
THIS IS INFORMATION THAT THAT
SIMPLY DIDN'T EXIST -- NOT THAT
VERY LONG AGO I AND YET
INVESTIGATIONS MOVE FORWARD TO
AND IN MANY CASES WERE PERFECTLY.
CAPABLE OF OF RESOLVING WHAT HAD
HAPPENED IN THE INCIDENT WE ASK
FOR YOUR NOVEL -- LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES
AN OPTICIAN.
RIGHT SEEING NONE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION OR ALL
RIGHT -- REMEMBER OBERNOLTE WHEN
IT CLOSED CERTAINLY I JUST.
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS A
LITTLE BUT IT'S SOMETHING I'M
VERY SENSITIVE TO THE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT IT'S
TALKED ABOUT A LOT.
I WAS ACTUALLY THE FLOOR MANAGER
FOR THAT BILL WHEN IT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY SEVERAL YEARS AGO SO
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I'M VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT.
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THIS IS
DOING SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR
WITH EDR DATA THAT WHAT WE DID
WITH THE KELLY CPA.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IT'S
SETTING A VERY NARROWLY TAILORED
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER WHICH
IT IS APPROPRIATE WITH THE
COURT'S PERMISSION TO GET ACCESS
TO THIS DATA.
I LIKE TO ASK YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAD A LEAD ONE THAT WAS KILLED
OR SERIOUSLY INJURED IN ACCIDENT.
WOULDN'T YOU WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE DATA THAT THEY NEEDED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WENT ON WE FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE REALLY WORKED TO
LIMIT THE CIRCUMSTANCES AGAIN.
STATUS FIVE SECONDS BEFORE TO
ONE SECOND AFTER AN ACCIDENT
IT'S ONLY CERTAIN PARAMETERS OF
THAT DATA IT'S ONLY IN CASES
INVOLVING SERIOUS BODILY INJURY
OR DEATH.
ONLY WITH.
A SEARCH WARRANT ISSUED BY A
COURT AND SIGNED BY A JUDGE.
DOWN ONLY IN CASES INVOLVING
SOMETHING AS SERIOUS AS A
MISDEMEANOR SO I'D APPRECIATE
DRIVE A I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERN OF THE
PRIVACY ISSUES [inaudible]
I'M.
THIS ONE IS A AGAIN ONE OF THOSE
WERE I AM SOMEWHAT TORN.
MOSTLY BECAUSE I'M.
ON THE ONE HAND.
I THINK IT IS USEFUL FOR US TO
HAVE BETTER INFORMATION AS TO
WHAT MAY HAVE LED. TO THE
INCIDENT.
HOWEVER.
IN ITS PROBE HAVEN'T NERO BUT IN
THE NARROWNESS.
THE INFORMATION IS LIMITED WE
MAY LEARN SPEED.
WE MAY LEARN WHETHER.
SUPPLIED OR NOT -- SO IT'S A I
NOT SURE HOW MUCH IT'LL ACT
COOLEY.
HELP US IN THE INVESTIGATION
[inaudible]
I'M.
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR
TO THE MEMO YEAH AUSTIN ALL
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT THIS IS ONE
OF THESE DOWN [inaudible]
BALANCING ACT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THIS WOULD BE AN AS AMENDED. TWO
PASSES AMENDED TO FLOOR OKAY
[inaudible]
BUT THE THANK.
YOU THAT WAS YOUR CLOTHES WAS
FOR OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
RIGHT LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MORALE.
HI WIENER.
ARE THE BILL'S ON CALL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE LET'S
REOPEN THE ROLE SO YOU CAN OUT
ON AND DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
STAY.
OKAY.
WE WILL START WILL GO FROM THE
TOP -- OKAY.
WE'LL START WITH AB.
ONE YES BUT ALL JUST INDICATE
WHERE TO START AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE ONE GO AHEAD WOULD JUST
HAVE TO SECRETARY.
READ WHAT THE STATUS OF IT IS
AND THEN WHO'S MISSING MOTION IS
STEVE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS.
TWO ZERO BRADFORD.
WHEN TO ENGAGE WITH BEFORE WE GO
FURTHER WANT YOU INDICATE WHERE
THAT WITH YOUR VOTE WHAT?
I'M HAVING YOU READ IT OKAY
[inaudible]
DINNER ABSTAINED.
REST TWO ZERO BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE'LL KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL AB --
ONE THIRTY FIVE WHAT'S NEXT AB
THREE HUNDRED MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT LOTUS THREE TO ZERO
SKINNER HI.
BRADFORD.
AFTER I JACKSON [inaudible]
WIENER.
THE BILL SALSA STAND CALL.
AB THREE TEN MOTIONS THE PAST
TWO DAYS DASH I'M SORRY.
MY GOD. EIGHTY SIX OH SEVEN
MOTION IS DO YOU ASKED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TWO ZERO PLEASE CAN I
RUNNING HIGH MORE LOCKED.
MOORLACH I JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORALE.
ROUND NOW WIENER.
NEXT ONE IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SKINNER I FORTY ZERO MITCHELL
WIENER.
SEN CALENDAR DOT MITCHELL ARE.
WILL STILL LEAVE IT ON HOW WE
WILL STILL LEAVE THAT BILL ARE
OPEN.
SO PROBABLY EVERYTHING WAS WELL
WE'LL SEE TO KEEP GOING.
AB.
SIX EIGHTY MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN HI
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
WIENER.
THE BILL STORE CALLED AB SEVEN A
ONE MOTIONS TO PASS A
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING HI
JACKSON.
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE AMARO.
MORALE AYE WIENER.
BILL STILL ECHO AB EIGHT OH
THREE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER.
MORE BY.
IN OUR AYE MOORLACH [inaudible]
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER.
THAT'S A NOT VOTING.
NO FROM THE HEAD.
AB ONE CALL. EIGHTY NINE NO ONE
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO EDUCATION
[inaudible]
CHAIR I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI WIENER.
ALREADY BE KNOWN WHEN A STORE
CALLED.
HERE.
YOU KNOW EIGHTY NINE OH SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING I BRADFORD
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER.
RIGHT AB NINE OH SEEN IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AB TEN FIFTY TO
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN HIGH
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
SORRY WHICH WOULD BE.
TEN FIFTY TWO ITEM ELEVEN
MINIMALIST [inaudible]
HI.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
AB TEN FIFTY TWO YEARS OUT.
SIX ZERO AB.
TEN SORRY SO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL. TO SEE OUR WINNER
THE WINNER I SO AB US.
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
WE NEED A MOTION.
THIS IS ITEM.
THIRTEEN THE MOTION TO PASS TO
BE EMPTY SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND [inaudible]
WIENER.
THIS IS ITEM THIRTEEN AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE ANIMAL.
STORY TIME. THIRTEEN ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT -- AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
CARE VOTING I BRADFORD.
HI WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE IS
OUT.
SIX ONE AB TWELVE NINETY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS THE GOVERNMENT
FINANCED CHAIR VOTING HI.
MOORLACH.
I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER WIENER ARE.
ALL RIGHT AB TWELVE NINETY SIX
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO AB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR CHAIR VOTING HI.
JACKSON.
I'M SORRY WHICH WOULD.
BE.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN JACKSON I AM
AROUND.
WELL NOW WINNER.
WIENER AYE.
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN IS OUT.
FIVE TWO AB FORTINO SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING FIVE
MORE LOT.
MOORLACH I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
WIENER WIENER AYE [inaudible]
MITCHELL I AB FORTINO SEVEN IS
OUT.
SIX ZERO AB FIFTY NO ONE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING HI MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
WIENER WIENER HI.
AB FIFTY NO ONE IS OUT.
SIX ZERO AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADE THE MOTION
[inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY IN OUR AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
WIENER WIENER AYE.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN IS OUT. FIVE
ONE AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR.
VOTING HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
BILLS OUT.
ZERO AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THERE WAS ONE TO NARROW IT.
AB [inaudible]
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT MY THERE IS
A VOTE ONLY THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA START REOPEN.
YEAH IT REQUIRED TO REPORTS
MORGAN EMERGING MEN AND IT WOULD
BE VOTE EARLY NEXT WEEK.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO ITEM
ONE AB ONE THIRTY FIVE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
RIGHT SO HOLD ON A MINUTE
SKINNER POSTING ON ALL.
NINE THIS ONE A CLEAR FIVE
BECAUSE WE HAD SO MEMBERS.
THAT HE AB -- SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT IS HELD NEXT WEEK FOR A
VOTE ONLY.
AND I KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
OVER HERE THAN HERE.
SO THAT TORN AVERTING ON IT
TODAY.
AND NOW WE WILL TAKE.
GO AHEAD SECRETARY READ THE NEXT
ONE THAT WERE RE OPENING RIGHT
NOW BACK TO THE BEGINNING AB ONE
THIRTY FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR OF STAIN.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
JACKSON.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
L. THREE ZERO WE CAN GRANT THE
FOSTER RECONSIDERATION.
EVEN AT WHICH WE WILL DO ADDRESS
RECONSIDERATION ON THAT BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING FIVE
JACKSON [inaudible]
OF HI WITH AMENDMENTS YES.
JACKSON HI WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AB THREE HUNDRED IS OUT
[inaudible]
FIVE ZERO WHAT [inaudible]
YEAH I ALL RIGHT MAYBE.
I WILL CORRECT THAT.
AB THREE HUNDRED IS OUT.
SIX ZERO ABC FILING FOR EIGHTY
SIX OR SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS A
PROBATION SO CHAIR VOTING HI
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
HI TAX IN AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
WIENER.
NUMBER.
FOUR SIX ZERO SEVEN MITCHELL AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE.
SB SIX OH SEVEN IS OUT.
SIX ONE ITEM SIX EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
VOTING HI JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
YEAH.
AB SIX EIGHTY IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
ITEM SEVEN A. B. SEVEN OH ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS A PREPARATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE JACKSON.
ALL RIGHT JACKSON AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AB SEVEN OH ONE IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM EIGHT AB EIGHT
OH THREE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
VOTING I TAX -- WIENER HIGH
[inaudible]
JACKSON HI.
AB EIGHT OH THREE IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO ITEM NINE EIGHTY NINE
A ONE MOTION IS DO PASSED
EDUCATION.
CHAIR VOTING I WIENER.
WIENER HI. EIGHTY NINE NO ONE IS
OUT. FIVE FIVE FIVE FIVE ONE ALL
RIGHT.
MAKE SURE WE'VE GOT ALL OF THEM.
PROPERLY ANNOUNCER RECORDED OKAY
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
STANDS ADJOURNED